SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER- THIS IS THE CHAIR WILL
NOTE THAT HIS LITTLE BROTHER IS
CELEBRATING A BIRTHDAY TODAY SO
PAUL HAPPY BIRTHDAY. WARNING IN
RESPONSE BECAUSE OF IT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS. MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS SONORA PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS HE LEADS
THE PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. IN HE
CAPITAL. WITH MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
ROOM THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE. THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PROTESTS MANY REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
LAMINATING AN ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. S. IT EVERY TIME THAT
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED. TWO
THREE SURE HAS FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
TO THE- IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
AND MUTE PLEASE SELECT A MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING ARE
I. T. PERSON THAT WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE. WHEN YOU ARE DONE
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME.
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THEIR-
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR- COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THE NEW
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. AND I WOULD AFFECT
UNANSWERED NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS
844-291-4185 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN. FOUR NINE SEVEN NINE
EIGHT SEVEN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
ENTER COMMITTEE WEBSITES.
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEAR INTO OVER TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU TOO
MUST MEET YOUR DEVICE WHEN
YOU'RE WATCHING. THE HEARING-
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED
MAY BE REMOVED. FROM THE ROUGH
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THAT
CONNECTION MUTED. PUBLIC
COMMENTS WILL BE HEARD. AFTER
ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN.
PRESENTED IN BOTH PART A AND
PART B. WELL OVER HERE FOR.
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINED
HEARING PROCESS. TECH HEARING.
HIS C. MANNERS CUSTOM. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES. FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENT FOR ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. LASTLY FOR EVERYONE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE TODAY
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON.
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES SO IT'S BECOME A
PARTY. ISSUE ONE WHICH IS THE-
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. BUDGET OVERVIEW AND
WE HAVE WITH US. MISS PETERSON
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING
YOU MAY. BEGIN. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR WHAT HOUSEKI HONORABLE
SHARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE YES GOOD TO SEE YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING AND I'M GOING TO
PRESENT A SHORT OVERVIEW OF OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL PROPOSALS THAT
ARE INCLUDED AS PART OF
GOVERNOR NUISANCE MAY REVISE MY
GRIEF OVER VIEW WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY A MORE IN DEPTH
PRESENTATION OF THE BROADBAND
FOR ALL PROPOSAL BY ROBERT
OSBORNE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CPC'S COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION.
THE PROPOSAL THAN JUST GOING TO
TOUCH ON BRIEFLY TODAY INCLUDE
BROADBAND FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE. A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO AN AUTHORIZED
LEGAL SERVICES CONTRACT RELATED
TO UTILITY BANKRUPTCY. AND
AMERICANS FROM BANKRUPTCY. A
PROPOSAL FOR OUR ACCOUNTS
RECEIVABLE UNIT. AND THEN WE
HAVE A NEGATIVE BUDGET PERTAINS
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU AS PART OF
THE- TRANSITION OF OUR WILD
CARD FIFTY DIVISION. TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. AND WITH THE THINKING
OF STATE HAS A PORTION OF THE
CLEAN RESILIENT ENERGY PLAN I
WON'T TOUCH ON THAT THIS
MORNING BECAUSE THAT IS ALL A
PART B. OF YOUR HEARING. BUT I
WILL STAY ON THE LINE ALONG
WITH SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE
CPC'S ACTIVITIES WITHIN. THAT
MUCH LARGER PLANT. BROADBAND
FOR ALL OUR PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
AND PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. BY EXTENDING
BROWN VERY BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HARD TO REACH
AND HIGH COST AREAS. EXPANDING
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
COMMUNITIES. AND IMPROVING
INTERNET SPEEDS FOR UNDERSERVED
CUSTOMERS. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES INFRASTRUCTURE
COMPETITIVE MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES AND AUTHORITY AND
TOOLS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES TO IMPROVE
THEIR OWN BROADBAND ACCESS.
MOST SIGNIFICANT IS A FOUR
BILLION INVESTMENT TO CONSTRUCT
A STATE OWNED OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK USING
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAY AND
UTILITY RIGHTS OF WAY.
COMPLEMENTED BY A THREE BILLION
INVESTMENT IN LAST MILE
FACILITIES TO UNSERVED
LOCATIONS. THE PROPOSAL TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF THE ONE HUNDRED
BILL ABILITY OF FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE STIMULUS FONG.
IT ALSO EXPANDS EXISTING IF YOU
SEE UNIVERSAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL TO
DATE IN MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD
ELIMINATING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
INEQUITIES. BUT REQUIRE AN
INVESTMENT OF FUNDS TO FINALLY
CLOSE THE GAPS THAT THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE SO
CLEAR. A PORTABLE AND HIGH
QUALITY BROADBAND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IS AN ACHIEVABLE
GOAL AND OUR PROPOSAL IS
DESIGNED TO HELP ACHIEVE IT.
OUR CALIFORNIA LIFELINE
PROPOSAL IS DESIGNED TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
AND ESSENTIAL WIRELESS AND
WIRELINE SERVICE AT AFFORDABLE
RATE TOO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. WE PROPOSED AN
INCREASE IN STATE OPERATIONS
AND A SMALL DECREASE IN LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. TO COVER THE
PROJECTED PARTICIPATION AT THE
STATE AND FEDERAL CODE NINETEEN
RELIEF PROGRAMS COME TO AN END.
IF YOU FACE TRIED TO ADMINISTER
THIS PROGRAM IN A WAY THAT IS
EQUITABLE NON DISCRIMINATORY
AND WITHOUT COMPETITIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ALSO STRIVE
TO ADMINISTER IT TO MINIMIZE
WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE. OUR
PROPOSAL RELATED TO GET UTILITY
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING. WITH THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE LEGAL
SERVICES CONTRACT THAT
CONTINUES THE ADVICE AND
REPRESENTATION THAT WE HAVE
RELIED ON FOR CORPORATE AND
UTILITY FOR STRUCTURING
FINANCIAL PROPOSAL
SECURITIZATION AND OTHER POST
BANKRUPTCY RELATED MATTERS.
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT AS THE
UTILITIES THAT ARE IN
BANKRUPTCY EMERGE FROM THAT HE
COULD REGAIN FINANCIAL
STABILITYAND AT THE SAME TIME
CONTINUE PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FROM VARIOUS
SPECIAL FUNDS. ROBY AT LEAST
THAT OUR ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE
UNIT. IS IN RESPONSE TO AN
AUDIT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE QUEEN I HAVE
REALIZED THAT WE NEED AT THE
POSITION IN ANY EVENT. STRENGTH
IN THE UNIT PERFORMANCE AND
ENABLE US TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE
REPORTING AND PAYMENT OF
RECEIVABLES BY THE ENTITIES
THAT WE REGULATE BECAUSE
MILITARY CHARGES IN TURN FUNDED
THE PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM. I
WOULD JUST REITERATE THAT- WE
ARE ALL HARD AT WORK ON THE
TRANSITION OF OUR WILD CARD
FIFTY DIVISION TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY. TO BECOME THE NEW
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY AND THE NEGATIVE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU.
ACHIEVE THAT TRANSFER. AND THEN
LAUGHED AGAIN I CAN STAY ON AS-
PART B. OF THE HEARING TO TALK
ABOUT THE CPC'S ACTIVITIES
WITHIN THE CLEAN ENERGY
RESILIENT PLANTS CLEAN
RESILIENT ENERGY PLANT PART OF
ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AND
ALSO ROBERT OSBORNE IS READY TO
PRESENT MORE DETAIL ON THE
BROADBAND FOR ALL PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT WE'LL
DO IS WE'LL GO THROUGH THE
WHOLE PRESENTATION AND THEN
HAVE MEMBERS HAVE THEIR
QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS SO- MR
OSBORNE- PLEASE GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE BACKGROUND THE PROBLEM AND
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS ADDRESSED
THE PROBLEM. THE FIRST ON THE
BACKGROUND WHAT THE PANDEMIC
IT'S MADE CLEAR THAT FAST
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND ACCESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS IS CRITICAL TO
SUPPORT REMOTE LEARNING. FELLOW
WORKS HELLO HELP INTO THE
CORNERSTONE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. IT LONGSTANDING
INEQUITIES IN INTERNET ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY
PERCENT. THE PROPOSAL WOULD
HELP COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO DRIVE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND DEVELOPMENT BY
FINDING JOBS FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. FOR
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND IS MISSING
OR INSUFFICIENT INCREASE
ECONOMIC EXPANSION ENABLED
DISTANCE LEARNING TELEWORKING
TELEMEDICINE. THE CIVICALLY
FAST RELIABLE NON
DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS ENABLED
CONNECTION TO COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE BARRIERS TO CONNECTIVITY
HAVE SEVERAL LAYERS THE PRIMARY
ONE BEING A LACK OF MIDDLE MILE
PREVENTING A LAST MILE
PROVIDERS FROM GOING THERE. IN
THE MIDDLE MILEAGE EITHER
NONEXISTENT OR TOO EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD OR LEASE. AT A HIGH LEVEL
BROADBAND NETWORKS ARE GROUPED
INTO THREE CATEGORIES YOU HAVE
BACKBONE WHICH IS A LONG HAUL
NETWORK. THIS IS COMPOSED OF
TRANSCONTINENTAL CABLES THAT
RUN ALONG INTERSTATE HIGHWAYS
AND RAILWAYS. YOU HAVE MIDDLE
MILE WHICH IS THE HIGH CAPACITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CONNECTION
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES OR NODES
THAT CONNECT THESE NODES TO THE
WIDER INTERNET. AND FINALLY
LAST MILE WHICH ARE THE CABLES
WIRES OR INTENT AS THE CONNECT
HOUSES AND BUILDINGS TO THE
CLOSEST MIDDLE MOM DOES. DALY
ALL MIDDLE MILE NAY. IN
OPERATION THEIR SINGLE PURPOSE
AND MEANING THEY ARE OWNED AND
OPERATED BY A SINGLE PROVIDER.
THE LACK OF THEM AVAILABLE
MIDDLE MILE INFRASTRUCTURE IS A
MAJOR ISSUE IN CONNECTING
CALIFORNIA'S UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE CAN PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE SERVICE FOR
ANCHORAGE DETECTION AND REDUCE
THE PRICE OF BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS. BY ENABLING COMPETITIVE
LAST MILE NETWORKS. LAST MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE RELIES ON MIDDLE
MILE TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO
RESIDENTS LARGE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES SCHOOLS GOVERNMENT
OFFICES PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
LIBRARIES. AND A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THE PROBLEM. I CAN ONLY
EIGHTY THREE POINT 4% OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE USING
BROADBAND AT ANY SPEED BUT ONLY
JUST OVER HALF ARE USING
BROADBAND THE HUNDRED MEGABIT
PER SECOND BENCHMARK. SERVICE
BELOW A HUNDRED MEGABITS PER
SECOND IS NOT ENOUGH FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE JUGGLING
THE DEMANDS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING TELEWORK ONLINE HEALTH
CARE. AS WELL AS ACCESSING
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. MURLE
COMMUNITIES ARE HIT THE HARDEST
WITH FIFTY ONE POINT 3% OF
RURAL HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS
TO ANY BROADBAND AT A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND. AND ALMOST
HALF THE HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT
ACCESS TWO HUNDRED MEGABITS PER
SECOND I LOCATED IN URBAN AREAS.
TRIBAL LANDS ARE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WITH TWENTY EIGHT POINT 4% OF
HOMES LACKING THE POTENTIAL
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
STATE'S LARGEST INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS OFFER REDUCE
COSTS PROGRAMS FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS BUT SUBSCRIBER SHIP
WITH LIMITED WITH ONLY ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
SUBSCRIBED. GROUNDS ARE NOT
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
ESTIMATED TWO POINT THREE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS FALLING
BELOW CALIFORNIA'S TARGET LEVEL.
CALIFORNIANS RELY ON SUBSIDIES
TO PRIVATE COMPANIES TO BRING
BROADBAND SERVICE TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- BUT
THAT APPROACH IS NO LONGER
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
STILL UNSERVED. LACKED
SUFFICIENT POPULATION DENSITY
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OR TOO
EXPENSIVE FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO REACH TO BE PROFITABLE SO
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
SECTOR ASSISTANT THESE
IMPORTANT HIGH COSTS YOU NEED
UNABLE TO GET CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET. AT THE SAME TIME
PARTS OF URBAN COMMUNITIES LACK
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
BROADBAND WHEN THEY'RE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE BROADBAND WE
ONLY HAVE ONE CHOICE. THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS AND TO DO THE
FOLLOWING FIRST CONSTRUCTED
STATE ON MIDDLEMAN THAT WORK
USING A COMBINATION OF STATE
LOCAL AND PRIVATELY OWNED RIGHT
OF WAY. THE MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
WILL EXPAND ACCESS AND CAPACITY
FOR NEW AND EXISTING LAST MILE
NETWORKS AND PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS WILL BRING IN
NEW PROVIDERS OFFER MORE
OPTIONS TO ALL CUSTOMERS AND
LOWER SERVICE COSTS. SECOND
ADDITIONAL LAST MILE FUNDING TO
CONNECT TO THE MIDDLE MILE.
THIRD SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT CAN RAISE MONEY TO DEPLOY
IT WITH PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS- FORGE MAKES
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO EXPEDITE UPGRADES
IN AREAS SERVED BY SMALL
INDEPENDENT TELECOM
CORPORATIONS. THE FOUNDATIONAL
INVESTMENT BUILD ONCE BILL
RIGHT AND BUILD FOR THE FUTURE
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
DIGITAL TREE NINETY FIVE WHICH
CONNECTS BARSTOW TO RENO WHEN
IT WAS BUILT BUILDER INSTALLED
TO CONDUCT ONE WITH FIBER ONE
WITHOUT. ONE WITHOUT IT'S
REALLY BUILDING FOR THE FUTURE
IS THE COMPLETE FIBER IN AT A
LATER TIME. AN OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK WILL
PROVIDE THE BACKBONE FOR LAST
MILE PROVIDERS TO SERVE
CONSUMERS LARGE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES SCHOOLS GOVERNMENT
OFFICES PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
LIBRARIES. THIS ENABLES LAST
MONTH PROVIDERS TO SERVE HIGH
COST AREAS. I'D CONNECTIVITY TO
MORE THAN ONE PROVIDER
INCREASING COMPETITION AND
AFFORDABILITY AND THEN FINALLY
SUPPORT UNIVERSAL SERVICE
OBJECTIVES IMPROVES OVERALL
NETWORK REDUNDANCY. IN THIS
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW. VERY
GOOD- LET'S HEAR FROM THE ALEJO
FROM. WE HAVE COMMENTS ON THE-
CPUC AROUND PROPOSALS. GOOD
MORNING MR SHARON NUMBERS ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- INSTANCE THE
REVISION WAS JUST RELEASED A
FEW DAYS AGO WE HAVE HAD ONLY A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME TO
REVIEW- THE UC PROPOSALS ON THE
REST OF THE PROPOSALS IN THE
BUDGET- WE STILL HAVE SOME
PRELIMINARY COMMENTS WE DON'T
HAS- ON THE ITEMS ON ISSUE ONE
ON THE UC. AGENDA WE DON'T HAVE
ANY KIND OF IMMEDIATE ISSUES TO
RAISE I THINK THE ONLY ONE I
DID WANT TO FLAG WAS THE
PROPOSED TRANSFER OF THE
WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION TO
THEN- OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY HI
THERE IS THIS- A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN STAFFING ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT- SHIFT AND TRANSFER-
THAT- PROPOSALS BEING LED BY
THE RESOURCES AGENCY- SO YOU
MIGHT WANT TO DISCUSS THAT MORE
IN THE NEXT PART OF YOUR
HEARING ALL RIGHT OR RELIGION
TO- BUT I JUST WANT TO LIKE
THAT ONE ISSUE AND I DON'T
WANT. FOR THE- BIGGER PROPOSAL
AROUND BROADBAND I'M GONNA HAND
OVER HAND IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN NOT STORE FOR
SOME OF OUR NATIONAL. COMMENTS
ON THAT. THANK YOU. THE MORNING
METZ LEDGE. ANALYST'S OFFICE-
AS ROSS MENTIONED SOME OF THE
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION FOR
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE SO WE WILL PROVIDE
OUR HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS AT THIS
HEARING. AND FOLLOW UP WITH A
MORE DETAILED ANALYSIS. UP
FIRST IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES TWO BILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS FROM THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE AUTHORIZED
FOR USE UNDER A NEW BUDGET
CONTROL SECTION. THAT ALSO
CONTAINS INTENT LANGUAGE FOR
ANOTHER FIVE BILLION IN FUNDING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. OF WHICH THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION AS FEDERAL FUNDS
AND ONE POINT FIVE BILLION. IS
GENERAL FUND- IT IS UNCLEAR TO
US WHY THE INTENT LANGUAGE FOR
FUNDING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE IS NECESSARY WHEN
THESE AMOUNTS. WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO APPROPRIATION IN THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE. AND MORE OVER
SEVERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSALS ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSIDERATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. THAT INCLUDES
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
ADDITIONAL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. AND SO
THEREFORE MIGHT BE PREMATURE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
MEMORIALIZING IT'S INTENSE IN
THE BUDGET ACT. TO COMMIT FIVE
BILLION INCLUDING ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN STATE FUNDS- IN
THE NEXT. BUDGET CYCLE WHEN IT
IS POSSIBLE DISCOMFORT OR
FUNDING COULD BE AVAILABLE BY
THEN. A SECOND THE PROPOSAL
ESTIMATES THE COST OF A MIDDLE
MILE OPEN ACCESS. BROADBAND
NETWORK AT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
USING A NEW COST ESTIMATES THAT
CALCULATES THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE COST PER MILE. FOR
CALTRANS TO PERFORM THE WORK.
AND THE ESTIMATED TOTAL NUMBER
OF MILES TO BE INSTALLED WITH
SOME MODIFICATIONS FOR EXISTING
OR PLANNED NETWORKS- IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY OF
THE BROADBAND ACTION PLAN
INCLUDED ANOTHER COST MODEL
THAT ESTIMATED. THE COST OF A
SIMILAR NETWORK IN HEORY- AT
TWO POINT TWO BILLION WHICH IS
ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
LESS THAN WHAT'S ESTIMATED NOW.
WE BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD REQUEST MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE NEW COST TESTAMENT.
AND ASK FOR A COMPARISON
BETWEEN THE TWO COST MODELS-
THIRD THE FOCUS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
HERE'S TOLD. BE ON LONGER TERM
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. AND NOT ON SHORTER
TERM ASSISTANCE WITH BROADBAND
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY. AND
NEW ACCOUNTS AND PROJECTS ARE
IDENTIFIED INSTEAD OF CHANGES
IN EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND
FOURTH IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER SI
PC OR AND OR OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. WILL TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS TO ENSURE THE STATE
MAKES COST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE BROADBAND ACTION
PLAN THE ADMINISTRATION RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
DATA ABOUT BROADBAND
AFFORDABILITY AND AVAILABILITY
IN THE STATE. AND SO FAR WE
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY INVESTMENTS-
BETTER PROPOSED IN STATE
OPERATIONS TO GATHER AND
ANALYZE THAT ADDITIONAL DATA TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE MAKING INFORMED
INVESTMENT. IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO. AS WE
GATHER MORE DATA AND MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
WILL SHARE THAT INFORMATION AND
ANALYSIS OF IT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU WE ARE
DEFINITELY LOOKING TO COLLECT.
THAT IS SUBMITS A FAST MOVING
TRAIN HERE ON THIS YEAH THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. FINANCE WOULD
YOU CARE TO. RESPOND TO ANY OF
THE FOURPOINTS THAT ALEJO
REYES OR I CAN GO BACK TO MISS
PETERSON IF THAT'S IF YOU'D
LIKE TO HANDLE IT. I'LL JUST BE
TO A MAN NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THE
CONTROL SECTION THAT WE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET TO BUILD
IN A MECHANISM TO RECEIVE AN
ANTICIPATED FEDERAL FUNDS. BUT
I GUESS THE QUESTION WAS IS WHY
DO WE COMMIT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION NOW WITH STATE FUNDS.
IF THEY MAY PICK UP THE WHOLE
TAB. ALL RIGHT. I WOULD I WOULD
SAY THAT WE'RE NOT COMMITTING
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL IS FOR THE TWO
BILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR WE'D
LIKE TO SIGNAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION- INDICATES THAT
THE TOTAL. OZELL SHOULD COME TO
SEVEN BILLION. OKAY MISS
PETERSON IS THAT HOW YOU SEE
THINGS THAT THE CPUC. MEDIC OF
THE VALLEY I WAS ASKING WHY IS
THE INTENT OF LANGUAGE
NECESSARY. IF WE COULD RIGHT
NOW- THEN WE ALL WANT TO HAVE
BEEN SENATORS. PARDON ME
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND- WE WILL KEEP ON
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO CLARIFY AND
UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE APPROACH FOR THE
LANGUAGES. GOOD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT- MR OSBORNE ON THIS-
THE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
BILLION FOR THE ESTIMATED COST
PER MILE PURSES THE CALTRANS-
FOR BILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE
THIS SEEMS LIKE A- A BIG CHUNK
IN FIVE MONTHS OR CHANGE. YEAH
ALL RIGHT AND HAD THAT OKAY
THREE CAN MISTER OSBORNE OUR
TEAM HAS BEEN HARD AT WORK AT A
NUMBER OF COST ESTIMATE FOR
THIS ENTIRE PROPOSAL BUT LET ME
HAND IT TO HIM THANK YOU. SO
THANK YOU CENTER AND THANK YOU
RACHEL PLAYED A HIGH LEVEL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- THE COST
ESTIMATE THAT WE PRODUCED FOR
THE BROADBAND ACTION PLAN WAS
BASED ON A COST MODEL. AND IT
USED- DISTANCE BETWEEN
LOCATIONS AS THE CROW FLIES SO.
ESSENTIALLY YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING
FROM POINT A TO POINT B. IN THE
AIR AS OPPOSED TO USING ACTUAL
ROAD MILES SO THAT'S THE
PRIMARY DIFFERENCE. ANOTHER
DIFFERENCE IS THE MIX OF
UNDERGROUND VERSES AERIAL THAT
WE USE SO. THE NUMBER THAT WE
HAVE FOR NOW BUT FOR BILLING IS
BASED ON UNDERGROUND PRIMARILY
AS OPPOSED TO A LARGER MAKES AN
AERIAL PERSONS UNDERGROUND SO
WE SEE THAT NUMBER. EVENTUALLY
CHANGING AS WE GET DOWN TO
IMPLEMENTATION. WELL EVEN A GUY
LIKE ME RESTAURANTS FOR KNOWS
THAT UNDERGROUND COST A WHOLE
LOT MORE MONEY THAN THAN THAN
ARIEL AND- THE BRINGS US TO THE
THIRD POINTED THE L. A. O.
RACES THAT. WHAT WE'RE GOING
FOR BIG ADDITIONS CHANGES THEY
SUGGEST THAT MAYBE SOME OF
THESE WHY NOT FOCUS ON SOME OF
THE SHORT TERM. FIXES WERE IT'S
JUST A MATTER PEOPLE NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD THE INTERNET I
MEAN THEY THEY SAY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INTERNET AND WE KNOW
THAT THEIR- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR A LOT OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'VE AT. LEAST THAT WE'VE
LEARNED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
IS PEOPLE JUST NEED AN UPGRADE
OF THEIR THE SYSTEM THAT THE
THIRD VICTIM THEIR HOUSES IT'S
CRASHING. IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THE HOUSE KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT ONE MY- WIFE WORKING ON
HER DISSERTATION AND MY SON
WORKING ON HIS THESIS IS. THAT
TIME FOR THE SENATOR SO WHY.
NOT PUT SOME FOCUS ON THAT. SO
THERE'S A COUPLE ELEMENT BUT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON AS WELL TO
ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM THE FIRST
IS ON THE LIFELINE SIDE WHERE
IT WILL CONSIDERING WAYS THAT
WE AND THERE'S ALREADY A
FEDERAL PROGRAM UNDER WAY RIGHT
NOW FOR THE EMERGENCY BROADBAND
BENEFIT THAT IS LOOKING TO
SUBSIDIZE BROADBAND FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. ON THE
AFFORDABILITY BY. THE PROBLEM
THAT WE SEE IS. IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE BROADBAND FORD
ABILITY AS AN OPTION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS AND WHAT
THIS MIDDLE MOM PROPOSAL WILL
DO. IS PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR LAST
MILE PROVIDERS SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A ONE PROVIDER ONE
TOWN SITUATION- THE OPEN ACCESS
ALLOWS. MULTIPLE PROVIDERS TO.
IF WE GET ON THE NETWORK ACCESS
TO COMMUNITIES SO WITH WITH
SERVE MATCH WITH HOUSEHOLDS BUT
ALSO LIBRARY PUBLIC SAFETY-
HOSPITALS ALL THE COMMUNITY
ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS SO THE
FOCUS IS REALLY UP SERVING THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY. I DO HAVE SOME
IDEAS JUST FOR US AS A WORKING
MODEL HOW MUCH OF YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A DEFICIENCY OKAY THAT'S
GREAT HOW MUCH OF THAT IS. THE
BILL. COMMUNITY OR THE BILL
MIDDLE MILE AND HOW MUCH OF
THAT IS JUST THIS. LOCALIZE I
CAN'T AFFORD THE BROADBAND OR
YOU KNOW THE BROADBAND RUNS
RIGHT PAST MY HOUSE I JUST. I'M
NOT IN ON IT BECAUSE WHEN WE
WHEN WE HEAR THESE NUMBERS
RECEIVING NUMBERS AND THIS AND
THAT. NEWSPAPER ON THE RADIO
IT'S A GIGANTIC NUMBER YOU'VE
FIFTH MISS PETRSON. TOLD US
ABOUT IT BUT HOW MUCH OF THAT
IS REALLY JUST. APPLE COMPUTER
ALL UP WITH SOME SORT OF
MINIMUM FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH
CHARGE THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
BROADBAND VERSUS THIS- TURN UP
THE ROAD AND BRING IN THE
MIDDLE MILE AND CREATED THIS
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
LAST MILE YOU KNOW PROVIDERS.
HE WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU MORE DETAILS ON THAT
SENATOR. ON THE WITH THE GAP
BETWEEN WHERE YOU HAVE
AFFORDABILITY PROBLEM PERSISTS
AND ACCESS PROBLEM. AND YOU
THINK THAT BY THE HAVING THIS
OPEN ACCESS FOR THE MIDDLE MILE
SORT OF. EQUALIZES THINGS A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THAT FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE BEING LEFT OUT OF
THE BIG BROADBAND GAME. IS AT
THAT IS THAT THE THEORY THERE
AT THE CPUC. THAT'S CORRECT SO
THE MINIMUM PROPOSAL IS BASED
ON CONNECTING ALL THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE BEEN ARE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND AND- SO WE
PUT THAT THAT PLAN TOGETHER.
AND IT RUNS ALONG STATE
HIGHWAYS WHEN WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN WE
OBVIOUSLY WILL FOCUS NOT JUST
ON STATE RIGHT AWAY BUT ALSO.
CITY AND COUNTY AND PRIVATE
RIGHT THE WAY- BUT THE BENEFIT
FOR THE MIDDLE MILE UP PROPOSAL
INCLUDE NOT JUST CONNECTING THE
HOUSEHOLDS BUT PROVIDING BUT
CONNECTIVITY SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN. DO THEIR WORK THEY CAN DO-
TELEWORK TELEMEDICINE ACCESS
GOVERNMENT SERVICES IT ALSO
PROMOTES ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT AS- A
BASELINE THAT PUBLIC CONNECTED.
CITIZENRY AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
THE HAVES AND HAVE NOTS WHICH
THE SITUATION WE'RE IN RIGHT
NOW. GOTCHA- LET'S HEAR FROM.
RURAL CENTERED RECOGNIZED YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OVER HERE JUST
ABOUT TO LOSE IT- FIRST OFF I
WANT TO TALK MISTER CALDERON UP
SOME I'M AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
BROADBAND FOR MINUTE. AND I
THINK THE INTENT LANGUAGE IT
NEEDS TO BE WE NEED TO HAVE THE
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND I
THINK IT IS TIME FOR US TO
REALLY CONNECT AND BUT THIS IS
THAT THIS THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO. IF YOU GO
LOOK AT DIGITAL THREE NINETY
FIVE WHICH I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
PUT IN THERE I THINK THERE'S
LIKE ONE PERSON HOOKED UP. IT'S
THE- IT'S THE ABILITY TO GET ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN IT'S IN
PLACE AND I'M FROM A RURAL
COMMUNITY AND I AND I REPRESENT
MOST OF THE RULES THE SOME OF
THE RULES PARTS OF THE STATE
THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
THEIR- PRIVATE COMPANIES LET ME
GIVE AN EXAMPLE. THE RAIL LINE
RUNS UP. BOB TWO FIVE FIVE AND
THERE'S A RAIL LINE THAT GOES
ALL THE WAY TO WASHINGTON IN
EIGHTEEN T. HAS A LINE THAT
RUNS RIGHT TO DUNN'S MERE THAT
IS HI SPEED INTERNET WHICH
CONNECTS THE WESTERN PART OF
THE UNITED STATES. AND MY
COMMUNITY COULD NOT HAVE GONE
TO THAT LINE BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T THAT THAT DOES NOT IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN. WE DO CAST A
FUNDS WE DO ALL KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRY TO CONNECT
RULE AMERICA. AND WE'RE NOT
GETTING IT DONE I THINK THIS
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS SHOULD BE
PUT IN THERE BUT THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS ABOUT HOW WE GO
ABOUT IT WE'RE GOING TO PUT IN.
THE MIDDLE MILE- CAN'T CONNECT
pTO IT DOESN'T DO US ANY GOOD.
IF AND I. ASK YOU TO GO LOOK AT
DIGITAL THREE NINETY FIVE AND
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY. HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE SERVICE. THIS IS
NOT A GOOD USE FOR MONEY WE
NEED TO ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET. PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
SERVICES AND- IS IN THE SENATOR
Y. CASKEY TALKED ABOUT HIS
HOUSEHOLD. LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT MY HOUSEHOLD. I LIVE. WAY
OUT THE BODIES I HAVE A
SATELLITE. DISH ON THE TOP OF
MY SHOP WHICH I GET. IS THE
COMPANY'S CALLED COMPARE. TO
THEM. I HAVE KIDS DISTANCE
LEARNING RIGHT NOW AT HOME.
WITH VERY VERY POOR. INTERNET
THERE IS NO BROADBAND OUT
THERE. AND I HAVE A LAND LINE
AND IT DOESN'T WORK AND I'M SO.
I GUESS MY FRUSTRATION IS THAT
I THINK THAT. FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO COMMEND. THE GOVERNOR
FOR PUTTING THAT. PUTTING THE
MONEY UP BUT I WANT TO KNOW HOW
WE'RE GONNA SPEND IT BECAUSE-
QUITE FRANKLY WE SHOULD.
ALLOCATE TO SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
USE EVERY BIT OF IT TO CONNECT.
THOSE UNDERSERVED AREAS WHICH I
AND CENTER REQUIRED. REPRESENT
WE ACTUALLY PASSED A BILL A
COUPLE YEARS AGO TO DO DIGITAL.
TO NINETY NINE TO AND IT'S
STILL NOT IMPLEMENTED SO I
GUESS FOR ME THE FRUSTRATION
COMES. IN GETTING THE PRODUCT
TO THE PEOPLE. AND THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE DETAIL ON HOW WE DO
THAT BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY THERE'S ROOM SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS RUN AND ANOTHER
BILL TO DO CAST A FUNDS AND WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT WE HAVE
THESE. NON PROFITS THAT ARE
SUPPOSEDLY GETTING US THIS
INFORMATION BUT WE THERE HAS TO
BE SOME ABILITY TO BRING THE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE ALREADY OUT
THERE WITH THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WHAT WE
HAVE HERE AVAILABLE TO US TO
CONNECT. CALIFORNIANS TO WORLD
CLASS WE SHOULD HAVE WORLD
CLASS- INTERNET HERE AND WE
DON'T IT'S ACTUALLY IT'S JUST
IT'S APPALLING TO ME THAT WE
CAN'T FIGURE OUT AND WE'VE
SPENT. HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE TALK ABOUT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS I THINK WE
SHOULD COMMIT THE MONEY. NOT
PUT IT INTO LANGUAGE COMMITTED
AND LET'S GO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET THIS DONE BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY. COMMUNITIES
CANNOT SURVIVE. ECONOMICALLY
WILL FURTHER HEALTH CARE FOR
SCHOOLS FOR LIBRARIES. FOR
PEOPLE TRYING TO DO BUSINESS
ONLINE IN LESS WE GET THEM THE
ACTUAL SERVICE AND NOT JUST
TALK ABOUT IT THE MIDDLE MILE
DOESN'T DO ANY GOOD UNLESS YOU
GET THE LAST MILE WITH IT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN HEARING
FROM NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
LET'S TURN IN NORTHWESTERN
CALIFORNIA SENATE MCGUIRE YOU
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCH HERE- I'LL TAKE. A TWO
MINUTES OR LESS NUMBER ONE
THERE'S A REASON WHY RURAL
CALIFORNIA PER CAPITA HAS THE
HIGHEST RATES. ADULT POVERTY
HIGHEST RATES OF CHILDHOOD
POVERTY HI IT'S RATES OF
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
HIGHEST RATES OF HOMELESSNESS.
HIGHEST RATES OF UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS. IN HIGHEST RATES
OF OPIATE ADDICTION. THE LACK
OF THE ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
EARN A CAREER JOB. IT'S ONE OF
THE MAIN DRIVERS. AND THE ONLY
WAY THAT THESE RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA GONNA SUCCEED IS
HAVING ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. IN RIGHT NOW BUT WE'D
LIKE IT'S JUST TO HAVE ACCESS
TO INTERNET. ACCESS TO A CELL
PHONE SIGNAL THAT ACTUALLY
WORKS. SO I AGREE WITH- MY
COLLEAGUES AT CENTER DOLLY ON
THE DETAILS A FEW ITEMS NUMBER
ONE THIS STATE CANNOT COUNT ON
LEGACY CARRIERS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. IS BEING CANDID ABOUT IT
AND NOT TRYING TO THROW THE
MONEY TO BUY US. EIGHTEEN T.
VERIZON COMCAST FRONTIER
THEY'RE GONNA DO WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS. NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE THE TOUGH CONVERSATION TO
FORCE COMPANIES TO ALLOW ACCESS
TO THEIR LIFE FIBER LINES.
THAT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH
DISCUSSION. THREE WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON THE MOST UNDERSERVED.
THAT'S GONNA BE BOTH RURAL AS
WELL AS URBAN FOUR WE HAVE TO
FOCUS ON PUBLIC OPTIONS AND HOW
TO ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I
TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
BROADBAND DISTRICTS OR ADD ON
TO COMMITTEE SERVICE DISTRICTS
THREE WOULD PROVIDE BROADBAND
OPTIONS. FIVE WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE
RIGHT NOW WHERE I THINK THE
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE IS
GOING TO BE OUR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THE CHALLENGES
SPECIALLY FOR ROLE GOVERNMENTS
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL OR THE
ENGINEERING WE GOTTA FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC TECHNICAL SYSTEMS
MARKETS. IN IN SIX- I THINK
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS RIGHT WHAT I WOULD ASK
MISTER CHAIR. IS TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH. A COMMITTEE OF URBAN
AS WELL AS RURAL INTERESTS TO
COME TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO
CONSULT. WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND HOW
THIS IS GONNA ROLL OUT. WE HAD
A GROUND TRUTH- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I THINK RURAL
CALIFORNIA HAS AND HOW TO BE A
NAVIGATE FORWARD. MISTER TERRY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU MISS PETERSON
MISTER OSBORNE. THAT WAS
HOPEFULLY ENLIGHTENING ON THE
AT LEAST THE SENATE. VERSIONS
OF THE INITIAL ROLLOUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THEY WILL MOVE
ON TO THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION- WITH THAT SAID I
UNDERSTAND THANK. I UNDERSTAND
FOR THE- ISSUE NUMBER THREE
BEFORE WE DO THAT. THE CHECKER
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR
THIS- CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BY CAL SKI HERE DOLLY
HERE MCGUIRE STERN. ASTEC FORM
IS ESTABLISHED ANALYSTS HAVE I
THINK COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN YOU
WERE ON THE CALLS AND THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. GOOD MORNING
PLEASE PROCEED. MORNING WELL
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE- MY
NAME'S PATTY MONAHAN I'M A
COMMISSIONER AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND I AM
GOING TO PROVIDE A VERY HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY AND THE NAY
REVISED PROPOSAL TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BUDGET. I'M ALSO
GONNA LEAD AND DEEP DIVE
DISCUSSION INTO THE CLEAN
ENERGY PACKAGE WHICH HAS COPIED
THE IMPLICATION. FOR ME REVISED
PROPOSES THAT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION MANAGE APPROXIMATELY
TWO POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT THREE FISCAL
YEARS. AND ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN THE UP COMING FISCAL
YEAR IN THE FOLLOWING THREE
CATEGORIES FIRST THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MANUFACTURING. SECOND CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND FINALLY A CLEAN
RESILIENT ENERGY PACKAGE. THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP THE STATE
DECARBONISE SO THE BIGGEST AND
MOST CHALLENGING SECTORS
INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION AND
INDUSTRY. THEY'RE ALSO ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE LONG DURATION
STORAGE AND NEW OFFSHORE WIND
WHICH WILL BE CRITICAL 321100%
CLEAN GRIN AND A CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THE PROPOSAL FOR THEIR MISSION
VEHICLE IN CONSTRUCTION
MANUFACTURING IS GOING TO BE
DISCUSSED IN THE NEXT SECTION
ON THAT FROM GOING TO STATE
STREET GLOBAL- GO THERE'S-
RESOURCES BOARD AND IDENTITY
ENERGY COMMISSION ARE
COORDINATING. CLOSELY ON THE
THREE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
MULTI AGENCY THREE YEAR PACKAGE
TO ACCELERATE ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION AND SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ENERGY
COMMISSION WOULD MANAGE ONE
POINT ONE SIX FIVE BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS AND SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION. A YEAR.
YEAH 85% OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING IS FOR THE BUILD OUT OF
YOUR MACHINE VEHICLE FOR
EXAMPLE INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
CALIFORNIANS CAN FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT NO MATTER WHERE THEY LIVE
WHERE THEY LIVE IN THE NORTHERN
PART WHICH THAT QUESTION- DOLLY
LIVES WITH EACH OTHER PARTS.
THAT THEY CAN REFUEL THEIR
THEIR MISSION VEHICLE. THE
COUPLE BUDGET PUT CALIFORNIA ON
COURSE TO RAPIDLY SCALE UP
ELECTRIC ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
COMMERCIALIZATION INCREASE JOBS
BUILDING OUT NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE ALSO
HELPING ME. GOVERNESSES
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON YOUR MACHINE
VEHICLES. ON CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BUT PROPOSES A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION OVER
TWO FISCAL YEARS. TO HELP MEET
THE STATE'S PRIORITY CHRONICLES
AND ADDRESS CLIMATE RESEARCH IN
EXTREME HEAT. THIS FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM A FIFTY MILLION PER
YEAR FOR TWO YEARS. TO MAKE LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS WITH MORE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF A
WARMING CLIMATE. THE COUNTRY
LANES PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE CHEST CLIMATE ASSESSMENT
THE NEW TRAVEL GRANT PROGRAM
FOCUSING ON FILLING RESEARCH
GAPS. I'M GONNA TALK OF QUICKLY
ABOUT IT. YEAH NEAR AND DEAR TO
THE HEART OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WHICH START PRIMARY
FUNDING SOURCE- THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT FOR-
BUSTER SHORT. AND MANY OF YOU
ON THE COMMITTEE NOW FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS- HAS BEEN IN
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. AND
IT'S BEEN AUTHORIZED TO SPEND
MORE MONEY THAN IT'S TAKING IN
EACH YEAR AND THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL. AWAY COULD FIX THIS
PROBLEM. SO NOW. VERY DEEP DOWN-
THE- RESILIENT ENERGY PACKAGE.
THE ENERGY PACKAGE PROPOSES TO
INVEST NINE HUNDRED TWELVE
MILLION ACROSS SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS AND PROGRAMS.
PUBLISHED ENERGY COMMISSION
WOULD MANAGE A TOTAL OF EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION. THIS PACKAGE WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH A 100%
CARPENTRY GRADE AND A CARBON
NEUTRAL ECONOMY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE COMBINATION OF
PLANNING AND ANALYSIS. YOUR
MISSION GENERATION STORAGE AND
EFFICIENCY. THE PACKAGE OF
THREE TRANCHES OF INVESTMENTS
THE FIRST OUR ENERGY UPGRADES
FOR INDUSTRIAL AND FOOD
PROCESSING FACILITIES. THE
SECOND IS LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE AND THE FINAL IS A
SUITE OF INVESTMENTS FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT AND SB ONE HUNDRED
TRAINING. THE PACKAGE WAS
DEVELOPED IN COORDINATION WITH
MY AGENCY THE ENERGY CHRISTIAN
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. ATTENTION COUNCIL
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THE PACKAGES INTEGRATED AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HELPING DECARBONISE OUR ECONOMY
AND ACHIEVE OUR CLEAN ENERGY
AND GREEN ECONOMY GOALS. THE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE CARBONIZED
INCLUDING ELECTRIFICATION GREEN
HYDROGEN BY A GAS AND OTHERS
ARE CURRENTLY TECHNOLOGICALLY
CHALLENGING AND THEY ARE
EXPENSIVE. THE DEMON VESSELS
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING ARE
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO BOTH THE
TRACK CUTTING EDGE INNOVATORS
AND SHOULD NOT THE INDUSTRY
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ACHIEVING OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE
HE CARBONIZATION GOALS. SO THE
FIRST CATEGORY OF CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IS THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO
CUT CARBON IN INDUSTRIAL AND
FOOD PROCESSING FACILITIES.
UNDER XI TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION WOULD BE USED FOR
INDUSTRY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE BILLION FOR FOOD
PROCESSING. THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR IS RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER
35% OF THE STATE'S NATURAL GAS
USE AND MORE THAN 20% OF THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THE HOLLYWOOD
SUPPORT THE NEW GRANT PROGRAM
FOR INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION.
IT WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE
CURRENT FOOD PRODUCTION
INVESTMENT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES GRANTS TO CALIFORNIA
FOOD PRODUCERS TO INSTALL
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES. I JUST FOR
A MINUTE ON THE FOOD PRODUCTION
ABOUT THE PROGRAM SO FAR IT'S
AWARDED FIFTY ONE GRANTS AT
SIXTY SEVEN PROJECT SITE. 85%
OF THOSE SITES ARE AND
DISADVANTAGED. AND OR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE NEW
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT WILL
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR EXISTING
AND EMERGING HE CARBONATION
TECHNOLOGIES AND STRATEGIES
SUCH AS ELECTRIFYING PROCESSES
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE USE FOSSIL
FUELS. INCORPORATING ENERGY
STORAGE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY USING
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE AND
EXPORT OTHER DECARBONIZATION
STRATEGIES LIKE REMOVAL GAS OR
SOLAR THERMAL. THE SAME
CATEGORIES LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE THE BUDGET PROPOSES
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR THIS CATEGORY. LONG
DURATION STORAGE IS REALLY KEY
TO ENSURING RELIABLE AND
RESILIENT. ELECTRICITY SERVICES
SORRY I THINK MY DOG JUST OPEN
MY DOOR- WE ARE USUALLY NOT
AVAILABLE OR THE GREATEST DOWN
FOR OTHER REASONS. CHEESY
ANALYSIS INDICATES THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR ABOUT A ONE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OR GIGAWATTS
OF LONG DURATION STORAGE BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND FOUR
GIGAWATTS BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THIS ONE TIME FUNDING IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADVANCE
LONG DURATION ENERGY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES. PHASES THAT WILL
SCALE THE TECHNOLOGY FROM SMALL
SCALE. WITH MEDIAN DURATION
LIKE EIGHT TO TEN HOURS. TWO
LARGE COMMERCIAL APPLICATIONS
WHICH WITH MUCH LONGER DURATION.
WITHOUT THIS ONE TIME INSERTION
OF FINDING THESE EMERGING LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES. WILL BENEFIT A
MUCH SLOWER PACE AND MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN THE TIME THAT WE
NEED BY TWENTY THIRTY. FINALLY
THE BUDGET PROPOSES A SUITE OF
INVESTMENT GREEN HYDROGEN I'M
SURE WHEN AND SB ONE HUNDRED
PLANNING TOTALING ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY POINT NINE MILLION. OF
THIS TOTAL A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION IS FOR CULTURE GREEN
HYDROGEN. THE FUNDING WOULD BE
USED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL USES OF CLEAN
HYDROGEN AND ADVANCE THE STATE
OF TECHNOLOGY ON PRODUCING AT.
THREE HUNDRED AND SHOWS PROMISE
AS A STRATEGY TO PROVIDE A ZERO
CARBON SHIELD REPLACE NATURAL
GAS FOR SOME APPLICATIONS SUCH
AS HIGH TEMPERATURE INDUSTRIAL
PROCESSES INCLUDING CONCRETE
AND STEEL PRODUCTION. SOME
GENERATION CAPACITY MAY BE
NEEDED TO STABILIZE THE GRID-
PROVIDING YOUR **** IN DRIVE
MODE FOLLOWING RENEWABLES ARE
NOT AVAILABLE. URBAN GENERATION
SOURCE LIKELY HYDROGEN COULD
PLAY THIS CRITICAL- WE WOULD
USE THE FUNDING IN SEVERAL
TECHNICAL AREAS INCLUDING
BLENDING HYDROGEN WITH NATURAL
GAS TO BE USED EXISTING POWER
PLANTS WITH A GOAL OF REACHING
A 50% CLEAN HYDROGEN PLANT. IN
ADDITION THE FUNDING WILL
ADDRESS THE ONSITE PRODUCTION
THREE HUNDRED RIGHT NOW
HYDROGEN PRIMARILY MADE TO
FOSSIL FUELS THE CONVERSION OF
NATURAL GAS. BUT WE WANT TO
HAVE A ZERO CARBON RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRIAL AND AGRICULTURAL
APPLICATIONS. PROCTOR WHEN THE
BUDGET PROPOSES TWENTY MILLION
TO SUPPORT IT YOUR AGENCY
APPROACH. SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THIS PROPOSED
FUNDING WILL SUPPORT A SERIES
OF CROSS AGENCY ENVIRONMENTAL
STUDIES BY CALIFORNIA'S MOTION
AGENCIES. WHAT THE STATE'S
FEDERAL. RUBIO UNDER THE
COASTAL COASTAL ZONE MANAGEMENT
ACT. THE COASTAL COMMISSION
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
ARE ALL HERE TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STUDIES.
THIRTEEN POINT TWO MILLION IS
FOR THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
SUPPORT THE SWEET ACTIVITIES TO
PERSONAL TO SHOW THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OFFSHORE WIND
ENERGY. THIS SPRING BY
LIMITATION ON A NATION WIDE
GOAL OF THIRTY GIGAWATTS OF
OFFSHORE WIND BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH IS REALLY EXCITING- AFTER
WIND ISN'T. INDUSTRY IN EUROPE
AND IT'S QUICKLY EMERGING IN
THE EAST COAST AND NOW WE WANT-TO CAPITALIZE ON THAT
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDER SEVERAL SCENARIOS THOUGH
SB ONE HUNDRED LOOK REPORT SAYS
WILL NEED AT LEAST TEN
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND. AND
TO DO THAT WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON HOW TO DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND BALANCES THE
PARTY THE OTHER OCEAN USERS AND
OCEAN AND COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING COMMERCIAL FISHING.
RESCUE ONE HUNDRED-
IMPLEMENTATION AND EMERGENCY
PLANNING THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
THE ENERGY COMMISSION. AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION IS PROPOSED THAT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
THANK YOU EARLY THEY'RE HERE TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
SB ONE HUNDRED BECAUSE YOU KNOW
REQUIRED THAT BY TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE THE GREAT BE 1100%
CARBON FREE. PLANNING TECHNICAL
ANNOUNCED- ANALYSIS AND
ENGAGEMENT BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBES IT'S GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
IN ADDITION CATEGORY WOULD
FIND. ENERGY EMERGENCY PLANNING
TO IMPROVE MANAGEMENT PROCESSES
AND DATA COLLECTION. SO THIS
PACKAGE OF PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
WILL HELP THE STATE WE COULD
GOALS FOR CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY WHAT THE FORTY IN STATE
COMPANIES AND WORKERS. I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS IN THE DISCUSSION
AND I'M ACCOMPANIED BY MANY
PEOPLE INCLUDING FOR MY AGENCY
YOUR AVAILABLE HAN OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LAURIE CAN
HELP WITH THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ENERGY RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND INDUSTRIAL THE
BET YOU DIRECTOR FUELS AND
TRANSPORTATION. NATHALIE
LIEVEN. RENEWABLES FINALLY YOU
LIKE HIGHLAND INVITE YOUR KIDS
COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS SO REALLY
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS HERE
READY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE- I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT. VERY GOOD- LET'S HEAR
FROM THE ALLEY- FIRST ON THE-
ENERGY COMMISSIONS OVER YOU
VIEW THE BUDGET. AND THEN THE
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. IF YOU
MISTER SURE FROM AGAIN WITH THE
L. A. I'M FOCUS ON MIKE. ON THE
CLEANER PACKAGE THE COMMISSION
MONAGHAN JUST PRESENTED THAT
SAYS ONE OF THE BIGGEST PACKAGE
IN ADDITION TO THOSE ADS- AS
YOU HEARD FROM COMMISSIONER
MONEY AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING A VERY LARGE INCREASE
IN SPENDING FOR CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAMS WITH MOST OF THAT
FUNDING ACTUALLY GOING TO. THE
NEW PROGRAMS THAT ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND SO BASED ON OUR
PRELIMINARY REVIEW WE DO HAVE
TO A VERY HIGH LEVEL
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- FIRSTS TO ENSURE
THE ULTIMATE PACKAGE THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS IS
COORDINATED STRATEGIC AND
COMPREHENSIVE. OUR RECOMMENDS
CONSIDERING THIS PACKAGE IN
TANDEM WEST SOME OF THE OTHER
PROPOSED PACKAGES THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HEARING THIS HEARING AND
ELSEWHERE- FOR EXAMPLE RELATED
TO CAP AND TRADE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES. BUT IN COMBINATION
ALL THE LEGISLATURE'S KIND OF
RELATED PRIORITIES ARE
REFLECTED ITS DESIRED LEVELS.
AS I CAN I AGREE THAT IT WAS
LIKE A EASTER EGG HUNT GOING
THROUGH THE BUDGET TRYING TO
LOOK AT THE RESILIENCE CLIMATE
STUFF THE A. K. CAP AND TRADE.
WILDFIRES AND THEN EACH BUDGET
IN BETWEEN AND SAYING OKAY HOW
TO I GOT YELLOW PAD I'M WRITING
DOWN THINGS AND SAYING WHAT
THIS IS ALL CONNECT. HOME SO. I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU YOUR
SECOND POINT. YEAH SO THIS THE
SAKE POINT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE SPEND AND THEN OF I.
THAT ARE BEING. IN THIS.
DELIVERS MIGHT. THE FOR
DECISIONS ON THIS PACKAGE UNTIL
THIS SUMMER- IS THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO. LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL'S
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF THE NEW
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES THAT
ARE PART OF THIS PARTICULAR
PACKAGE- CRAFT IMPLEMENTING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND TO ENSURE
THAT ALSO INCORPORATES KEY
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AS WE
JUST DISCUSSED- MORE- KIND OF
SPECIFICALLY I GUESS JUST SORT
OF THOSE THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSAL. I WE DO THINK THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S GENERALLY
TARGETED AT PROMOTING
TECHNOLOGIES IN AREAS THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THE
CARBONIZATION GOALS THE
CALIFORNIA HAS SET- BUT WORK
COMMERCIAL SCALE TECHNOLOGIES
MIGHT NOT YET BE AVAILABLE AND
SO. WE THINK- YOU KNOW THAT
KIND OF FOCUS IS REASONABLE AND
CONCEPTS- BUT THERE ARE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS AND DETAILS THAT
STILL. NEED TO BE WORKED OUT
AND ANSWERED. A COUPLE THAT ALL
HIGHLIGHTS. ONE OF A KIND OF
KEY QUESTION TO THINK ABOUT IS.
IS GENERAL FUND AN APPROPRIATE
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES ARE TYPICALLY IN
THESE TYPES OF KIND OF CLEAN
ENERGY ACTIVITIES ARE FUNDED
DIRECTLY OR FUNDING OR OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS. HOWEVER WE DO
THINK IT WOULD BE REASONABLE TO
THINK ABOUT USING ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD OF
RATEPAYER FUNDING. FOR SOME OF
THE ACTIVITIES AT LEAST
INCLUDING THE INCENTIVES AND
GRANTS- THIS IS. PARTLY BECAUSE
AT AS MANY OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW
WHAT CHRISTIE RATES ARE ALREADY
VERY HIGH WHICH RACES. ARE
QUITE A FEW CONCERNS AROUND
SORT OF JUST ENVIRONMENT
ACHIEVING OF OUR MIDDLE GOALS
ARE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES IN
EQUITY CONCERNS. SO USING
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD COULD
PREVENT FUTURE. RATE INCREASES
RATHER THAN KIND OF RELYING ON.
ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS. ALSO
MANY OF THE PROPOSED PROGRAMS
ARE INTENDED TO PROVIDE BROAD
PUBLIC BENEFITS WHICH MEANS
THERE COULD BE A REASONABLE
CASE AND I'M ROLE FOR A STATE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT- AND I
THINK I THINK THE ARGUMENT FOR
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR SOME
OF THE OTHER PLANNING
ACTIVITIES I. THINK IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE'RE STILL
EXPLORING OR NOT. ENTIRELY SURE
ABOUT THAT BUT I THINK FOR SOME
OF THE- ON SERVICE. THERE IS A
REASONABLE ARE- THE SECOND
QUESTION- THEN I'LL IN MY FROM
OR- IS HOW MUCH IS. SHOULD BE
PLACED ON. INCREMENTAL IF
THEY'RE GAINS AS PART OF THESE
PROGRAMS. VERSUS PROMOTING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES NEEDED
FOR DEEP DECARBONIZATION- SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS LIKE THE
INDUSTRIAL PROPOSED INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONISATION PROGRAM WOULD.
MAKE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR BOTH
OF THESE THINGS BOTH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AS WELL AS- A NEWER
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE GREEN
HYDROGEN OR CARBON CAPTURE FOR
EXAMPLE- ANYTHING IN GENERAL WE
THINK PROMOTING EARLY STAGE
TECHNOLOGIES AGAIN IS IT A
REASONABLE AREA OF FOCUS BUT
THERE IS KIND OF A TRADE OFF
THAT THOSE. TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE
MORE EXPENSIVE AND FOCUSING ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY MIGHT BE A
MORE. COST EFFECTIVE NEAR TERM
STRATEGY- SO THAT'S JUST KIND
OF ONE OF THE TRADE OFFS I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT IN WAYNE WHEN
STRUCTURING THESE PROGRAMS IF
FUNDING IS PROVIDED. HOW IT
WANTS TO WAY KIND OF SOME OF
THOSE LONG TERM GOALS IN
PROMOTING NEW OR INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. AGAINST COMMITTEE
ON PERHAPS MORE COST EFFECTIVE
BUT SORT OF SHORT TERM GOALS
ARE. AND PROJECTS AROUND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. SO WE HAVE A
SEVERAL OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
THEY'RE LAID OUT IN YOUR AGENDA
BUT I'M NOT IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME- IN MY COMMENTS THERE. THE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. YOU COULD
TO TOUCH MINE. WE YOU'VE TOURED
US FOR YEARS ABOUT- THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAMS ARE COVERED
ENTITIES INCLUDING THE FOOD
PROCESSING. INDUSTRY THAT THEY
SHOULD THERE EMITTERS A CARBON
DAY SHOULD PAY THEIR OWN WAY
AND WE KNOW WE HAVE. A CARVE
OUT THE CAP AND TRADE TO PAY
FOR THEIR MANUFACTURES TAXES SO
THEY DON'T PAY THIRTY TWO
MILLION. DOLLARS AND THAT THIS
IS. FOR YOU KNOW FOR PROCESSING
TO REACH. A CAR FELL TO REDO
THEIR AND- YOU IS. WHAT AN
COMPANY TO. INCREASE IN THE
FLOW PRICE ON THE CAP AND TRADE
IS SORT OF FIFTY THAT THAT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE IS A- A
BALANCE BETWEEN OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GIVE YOU THIS BUT THEN.
YOU COULD PAY MORE EVERYBODY
WILL PAY MORE. I'M GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND WHAT THEY THINK IT'S- WITH.
WHY SHOULD WE BE DOING THAT IS
A LEGISLATIVE WHY SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT ONE INDUSTRY
ADMITTEDLY IT MIGHT BE LOCATED
IN A LOW INCOME AREA AND IT
MEDICALLY IT MAY BE A GOOD
ENERGY. A BIG ENERGY. USER BUT
WHY WOULD WE- WHY WOULD WE WANT
TO. FOCUS JUST ON THAT ONE
INDUSTRY. YES I THINK THERE ARE
A COUPLE IS KIND OF IMPORTANT
POINTS ON THAT QUESTION ONE IS
JUST KIND OF BROADLY- YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF CAP AND
TRADE VERSUS YOU KNOW A STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS TO PROMOTE
TECHNOLOGY OR SUPPORT A CERTAIN
TYPES OF INDUSTRIES I THINK.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION A POINT
THAT WE RAISED BEFORE AND WE DO
THANK THE KIND OF TRYING TO
PROMOTE THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THE STATE'S
FOCUS SHOULD LARGELY BE ON I
HAVE BEEN TRAINED CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS SET UP IN A WAY. TO
DO THAT AND IN A WAY THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
GOALS NOW THERE MAY STILL BE-
HAVE A GOOD RATIONALE FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON THINGS
THAT MAYBE CAP AND TRADE
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY
INCENTIVIZE BUT ARE STILL KIND
OF NEEDED OR NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED BUT A
COUNTRY DOESN'T DO A GREAT JOB
OF COVERING AND HANDLING AND
SO. PROGRAMS LIKE THIS TO KIND
OF PROMOTE YOU KNOW NEWER
TECHNOLOGIES IN DEMONSTRATIONS
MIGHT BE KIND OF A GOOD FIT FOR
YOU SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS
TO GO ALONGSIDE CONCENTRATE
AGAIN ASSUMING AS WE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE COUNTRY TO SET UP
AND IN A WAY THAT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S GOALS. THAT'S
ONE THING I THINK THE OTHER THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT YOU RAISED
SOME I WAS ALSO ONE OF OUR
COMMENTS THAT'S OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA AS BY THE ARGUMENT FOR-
PROVIDING A SPECIFIC CAR ABOUT
PROGRAMMER FUNDING FOR A
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY SO- AS YOU
NOTED THERE'S A PROGRAM FOR
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION
ACTIVITIES AND TECHNOLOGIES AND
THERE'S A SEPARATE PROGRAM FOR
FOOD PROCESSING- INDUSTRIES AND
SO I THINK- I THINK THAT A GOOD
QUESTION I AM ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS. THAT WAS ON OUR MIND
WAS- WHAT IS THE SORT OF THE
RATIONALE FOR. UNNECESSARY
FOCUS ON JUST THE PROCESS
INDUSTRY RATHER THAN JUST
WALKING ABOUT MY INTO ONE. OF
PROGRAM. AND FUNDING TO THE
MOST MERITORIOUS. WITHIN THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR AND SOME OF
THOSE LIKE A FOOD PROCESSING
BUT SOME OF IT MIGHT BE OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SO. ANYTHING ABOUT
THE DESIGN AND STRUCTURE OF
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS WE
THINK THAT'S- KIND OF ONE
IMPORTANT QUESTION TO ASK AND I
THINK ABOUT. HOW TO STRUCTURE
THEM IN A WAY THAT KIND OF GETS
OUT THE MOST MERITORIOUS
PROJECTS WOULDN'T YOU'RE
THINKING BEAT SINCE WE HAVE 80%
OF THE MANUFACTURES ARE COVERED
UNDER CAP AND TRADE. AT
TARGETING THE OTHER 20% SORT OF
THE SLOW LOPE PLAYERS THAT ARE
ENERGY INEFFICIENT. OR THAT
NEEDED DECARBONISATION AT THAT
WOULD BE. A WISE WISE
INVESTMENT. TO MOVE THAT
SECTOR. ASIDE I MEAN WE'RE NOT.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE
DON'T GIVE ANYTHING TO THE
COVERED ENTITIES TO DECARBONISE
THEM. BE NICE THAT WE USE OUR
CAP AND TRADES TO ACTUALLY
DECARBONIZE THE COMMUNITY
RATHER THAN. WORK AFTER
POLLUTION AND OTHER PROJECTS
THAT ARE. WONDERFUL BUT THEY
DON'T DO THE JOB OF. THAT IS
THAT IT IS AT A TARGET ARE.
TARGETED IF WE DO GO FORWARD
WITH THIS. LONG TERM. DICKER
EFFORTS AT SHOULD BE LOOK AT
THOSE ANTI ENTITIES. COVERED
ENTITIES. YEAH I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF KIND OF THE
PRINCIPLES IN AREAS THAT WE I
THINK WE'VE OUTLINED THAT IS-
WHAT ARE SORT OF REASONABLE
AREA OF FOCUS ON KIND OF
FOCUSING ON THOSE ENTITIES THAT
ARE NOT COVERED LIKE YOU SAID I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T HAVE A SENSE
TO MAKE IT MINISTRATION DOES ON
KIND OF HOW MANY. ENTITIES THAT
WOULD CAP THAT WOULD CAPTURE
KIND OF THIS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL HOW MANY SORT OF
SMALLER- INDUSTRIAL SOURCES ARE
KIND OF OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL
I THINK ONE THAT IS ONE
REASONABLE SORT OF AREA TO
EXPLORE AND ONE KIND OF
REASONABLE CRITERIA TO USE TO.
PART OF THE FUNDING IN ADDITION
TO EVEN FOR THE LARGE PLAYERS
THATARE COVERED AS WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT- BUT IT THERE'S
SORT OF A- PILOT AND
DEMONSTRATION OF RATIONALE AND
TECHNOLOGICAL- KIND OF
PROMOTION ASPECT OF THE PROGRAM
WHICH MEANS EVEN IF THEY ARE
COVERED WE DO THINK THERE IS.
SOME REASONABLE RATIONALE FOR
GOING TO THE STATE PLAYING A
ROLE IN AN AND PROMOTING THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS FINANCING
DELIVERY SPONSORED COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN. AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
CENTER DOLLY. I'LL THE TO THAT
IN COMMISSION. WELL I'M I'M NOT
AN EXPERT ON A CAP AND TRADE
WHAT WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT FOR
ME IS VERY DIFFICULT TO THE
CARBONIZED SECTORS AND WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
STILL NATION. THAT THAT CAP AND
TRADE DOESN'T DO A GOOD JOB OF
INCENTIVIZING THOSE DEEP
DECARBONIZATION INVESTMENTS
THAT WE WILL NEED. THE SAME
THING N THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR WHERE IT'S NOT EASY TO
SWITCH ONE FUEL TO ANOTHER
EXPENSIVE AND THERE'S- THERE'S
A LEARNING CURVE AND THERE'S A
COST THERE. AND SO WE WILL- YOU
KNOW INVESTORS THAT ARE REALLY
TARGETED. AND I THINK
INDUSTRIAL IS WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE A SOLUTION SET YET FULLY
MAPPED OUT. AND SO THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY TO HELP
THIS IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS TO
DECARBONISE. WHAT I WOULD CALL
IT SERIES OF NEXT GENERATION
INVESTMENTS I MEAN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AS PART OF THAT
BECAUSE THAT REDUCES THE AMOUNT
OF ENERGY THAT WE HAVE TO USE
FOR THESE. THESE ABOUT- MORE
YOU KNOW EXPENSIVE AND
DIFFICULT STRATEGIES- I DO HAVE
A LOT OF STATES THAT WITH THE
RIGHT SET OF HARDY DIDN'T
INVESTMENTS. WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS IN THESE. NEXT
GENERATION DECARBONIZATION
STRATEGIES FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR. MISS HOPE YOU'RE.
RECOGNIZE I SAW YOUR HAND UP. I
WAS JUST GOING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO I'M GLAD. I'M LAURIE
TENTO BY THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
RESEARCH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND I WOULD
JUST ADD A COUPLE OF COMMENTS I
THINK THIS AROUND IT'S REALLY
ARTICULATED SON CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TRADE OFFS AND
CONSIDERATIONS. AND PART OF OUR
EXPERIENCE WITH THE AFTER
PROGRAM TO DATE IS THAT BY
TARGETING COVERED ENTITIES.
YOU'RE YOU'RE HELPING THOSE
ENTITIES ACHIEVE THESE GHG
REDUCTIONS EARLIER THAN THEY
WOULD OTHERWISE BEEN KIND OF
STUDYING- LEADERSHIP FOR THE ON
COVERED ENTITIES TO FOLLOW. AND
IT'S ALSO WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THE BIGGEST- GHG REDUCTIONS
SO I THINK IT'S- I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
IT- THE THINK ABOUT BOAST AND-
COVERED ENTITIES AND ON COVERED
ENTITIES- I'M JUST IT THE- AND
SEE IF BY. WE WANT TO FOLLOW UP
WITH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
RIGHTS WORK WILL JUST WE'LL
JUST ARTICULATED CENTER SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS ARTICULATED A
DESIRE TO INCREASE THE FLOOR
PRICE ON THE CAP AND TRADE IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE ECONOMIC
INCENTIVE. FOR THE POLLUTING
AND POLLUTING POPULATION
INCLUDING MANUFACTURERS TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO DO TAKE THE
ACT ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE TO DO
WE'RE NOT THAT FIRST TO HELPING
HIM ALONG. BUT WE STILL HAVEN'T
HAD THAT. BY INCREASING THE
FLOOR PRICE THAT IS REFLECTIVE
OF WHAT THE WORLD MARKET SAYING
I KNOW THAT TEND TO THE
AIRPORT. AND THEY HAVE BEEN.
CITY AND NOT RESPONDING TO ANY
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
RAISED HERE SO WHAT. YOU KNOW.
MAYBE WHEN YOU TALK TO THE-
BOARD LET THEM KNOW THAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN. IN A PARTNERSHIP
WHERE THEY CAN RAISE THE FLOOR
FLIGHTS SO WE'VE EVERYBODY CAN
HELP OUT THAT COVERED ENTITIES
WOULD BE INCENTIVIZED TO SAY.
WHY ARE WE PAYING THESE
ALLOWANCES RATHER LET'S PUT
THIS EQUIPMENT ON AND NOW
HERE'S SOME MONEY TO HELP THEM
DECARBONISE RATHER THAN. A FREE
TRAIN CHECKED YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THAT'S A- PART OF I THINK THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME HESITATION
FOR US TO. TO DO THAT CENTER
DOLLY YOU RECOGNIZE WELL I JUST
WANT TO. SAY YOU KNOW NOT ALL
OF US HERE WANT TO RAISE THE
FLOOR PRICE. MAYBE YOU TO
MISTER. Y. CASKEY I JUST WANNA
MAKE A COMMENT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE FOOD PROCESSOR NIGHT
WOMEN'S WHEN EXPAND ON IT LOOKS.
85% OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE GOING
TO DO IT LOW AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ANYBODY THAT
MANUFACTURES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
COULD LEAVE IS ALREADY LEFT.
BUT I HATE TO TELL YOU. THE
PEOPLE THAT PROCESS FOOD AREN'T
LEAVING BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
STILL FARM IN CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK IT'S- THE- IT'S MORE OF A
CHARACTER IT'S MORE OF AN IDEA
TO SAY HEY. WE CAN HELP THESE
PROCESSORS- STAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND PROCESS IN THESE LOW AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
HELP REDUCE THE CARBON
INDUSTRIES WE TALK ABOUT. THE
VALLEY- IN THE FOOD PROCESSORS
ALL THE TIME AND THAT'S ONE OF
THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE
I ACTUALLY THINK WE CAN. HELP
REDUCE CARBON AND IT'S AN
INCENTIVE MORE THAN IT IS- A
STICK- BUT I WANT TO BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT AND TALK ABOUT THE-
BUT AND I JUST I HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND I JUST. BECAUSE
BECAUSE THIS. CECE'S THE OTHER
DUTIES THE SEA. OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION OF EXPANDED- THE
ONLYACTIVITIES THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT RATEPAYERS FOR INSTANCE
CLIMATE FOCUS POLICIES LIKE THE
BUILDING INITIATIVE. FOR LOW
EMISSIONS- DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
OR THE MANDATE FOR SOLAR ON ALL
NEW HOMES. ADDITIONALLY THE CC
HAS RECENTLY ADOPTED MAJOR
POLICIES WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
INPUT SO I. AS A LEGISLATOR I
LIKE SOLD ME RESEMBLES ALL
SOLAR ON NEW HOMES BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION. WITHOUT MUCH
OVERSIGHT FROM THE FROM US AND
SO I HAVE A POLICY QUESTION.
CAN WE EVEN PUT A SURCHARGE ON
THE BEHIND THE METER
CONSUMPTION. SO BASICALLY IF I
IF I PUT SOLAR ON MY HOME AND
I'M GENERATING MY OWN LECTURES
CITY ARE THERE IS ARE GOING TO
BE AN ASSESSMENT. TO MY ENERGY
THAT I PRODUCE. THAT I'VE THAT
I'M NOT GETTING OFF THE GRID. I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
OF OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- TO
BOTH HANDS. WELL DONE THANK YOU
COMMISSION ON HAND THANK YOU
SENATORS ARE SENATOR DOLLY. YOU
RAISE GOOD QUESTIONS IN THAT
THE SHORT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
IS YES OUR PROPOSAL WOULD
EXTEND THE- THE SURCHARGE THAT
CURRENTLY APPLIES TO ALL RATE
PAYERS- FOR THEIR METERED
ELECTRICITY. AND IT AVERAGES TO
ABOUT SIXTEEN CENTS PER MONTH
PER RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYER IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS TO EXTEND THAT
CHARGE TO THOSE. FOR WHOM THEY
HAVE SOCIAL OF SOLAR- ON THE
ROPES AND THAT WOULD COST THOSE
RATEPAYERS WE ESTIMATE. ABOUT
TWENTY CENTS PER MONTH- FOR IT
TO SUPPORT YOUR TO CHARGE AND
WE FEEL IT'S AN APPROPRIATE WAY
TO SPREAD THOSE COSTS OUT OVER
ALL THE- UTILITY RATEPAYERS.
AND AND THAT'S WHAT WE PROPOSE
THAT WE BELIEVE IT WILL
GENERATE. ABOUT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. SO BASICALLY
THE YOUR THE SURCHARGE ON THE
SO AND BECAUSE THAT'S WHICH DID
IF YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
GENERATION. WILL A LOT OF FOLKS
ARE TRYING TO GET OFF THE GRID
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT
AND THEREFORE AND THEY'RE IN
THEIR GOING GREEN. AND NOW
WE'RE BASICALLY ACTUALLY THERE
THERE'S GONNA BE MORE THAN THE
THAN THE- COMMERCIAL GENERATION
EASY SO SIXTEEN CENTS FOR.
SOMEBODY WHO IS IF IT IS I
GUESS IN FRONT OF THE METER AND
THOSE BEHIND THE METER ARE
GONNA BE TWENTY CENTS. THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
OUR PROPOSAL IS HOW DO THAT
JUSTIFICATION. WELL THIS
WOULDN'T APPLY TO ANYBODY WHOSE
OFF THE GRID SO TO YOUR POINT
IF SOMEONE WERE TO HAVE SOLAR
AND NOT BE CONNECTED TO THE
GRID THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
CHARGED WITH THIS CHARGED FLOWS
FROM THE BENEFITS WE ALL ENJOY
THOSE OF US WHO ARE CONNECTED
TO THE GRID- ENJOY FROM FROM
HAVING THAT IN OUR ACTIVITIES
ARE ALL DESIGNED. TO IMPROVE
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE GRANT
AND- ALL THE OTHER BENEFITS WE
SEEK TO ACHIEVE FOR CALIFORNIA.
SO BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT SO IF
YOU'RE I'M TALKING ABOUT
SOMEONE WHO IS HAS SOLAR WHO
STILL CONNECTED TO THE GRID ONE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WORK WHEN
THE SUN IS NOT SHINING AND-
BUT- BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
PENALIZING THE PERSON WHO
ACTUALLY PUT. SOLAR ON. OR AS
BUILT WITH SOLAR- THERE'S JUST
TWENTY CENTS AND SOMEBODY WHO
DOESN'T HAVE THAT IS GOING TO
BE SIXTEEN SAYS WHAT'S THE
JUSTIFICATION AND THAT. WELL WE
FIGURED THAT. THIS WAS THE IT
WAS A COMPARABLE RATE IT WAS
CLOSE- AND WE THAT THIS IS THIS
IS BEEN A BENEFI THAT THOSE
WHO HAVE HAD- SOLAR ON THEIR
ROOFS AND NOT PAID- FOR. AND SO
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS- AND I GREW
EQUITABLE WAY TO GO ABOUT IT.
STILL WAITING FOR THE BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE ON THAT AND
THE- THE ANTICIPATED TWO THIRDS
VOTE THAT WILL BE REQUIRED FOR
THAT A CHANGE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE PATROLS WITH
WE HAVE A SMORGASBORD BOARD OF
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHY DON'T WE-
HAVE THE PRESENTATION.
PARTITION NUMBER FIVE. ALL
RIGHTS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR I'LL JUMP RIGHT IN HERE
SIGNED TYSON ACCURATELY ON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT THAT GO B. AS
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT THIS PROPOSAL
I THINK YOU KNOW WE PRESENT IN
THE PAST ABOUT THE STEP MARKET
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY OR YOUR GO
TO MARKET STRATEGY IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S REALLY
THAT'S RIGHT HE'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON. EQUITY AND SCALE I
THINK THIS OCT THIS BUDGET
REALLY PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO BOTH RIGHT SO IT'S THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS YOUR COMMISSIONER
MONAHAN GIVES A GOOD OVERVIEW
SOME OF THE NUMBERS IT'LL HELP
DELIVERS AT OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
DRAYAGE TRUCKS THOUSAND TRANSIT
BUSES A THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES
BLESSED I'M MARKET ENABLING
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
MANUFACTURING MAKE SURE THAT-WE'RE BUILDING THE MARKET HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO
INVESTMENTS AND- LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME ACCESS TO THE
MARKET THROUGH THIS TV ARE
BEING CLEAN CARS FOR ALL AND SO
THE INVESTMENTS ALL OF THE HIT
THE FOUR PILLARS OF THEM FADS
THAT MARKET ELEMENT STRATEGY
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN VEHICLES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
ORGANIZED TO HELP THE END USERS
ACCESS THE CAP MARKET CAPITAL
AND IT'LL CREATE WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO YOU'LL
HEAR FROM CARBON AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BUT SEEN. RESOURCES
BOARDS FOCUS ON A VEHICLE
INVESTMENTS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS FOCUSED ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS BUT
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON
BRINGING THOSE TOGETHER TO MAKE
IT LOOK LIKE ONE PROGRAM FOR
THE END USER I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT DISTINCTION-
THE CHANGES FROM JANUARY- WE'VE
DROPPED THE SECURITIZATION OF
AB A PROPOSAL IN FAVOR OF THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION INVESTOR
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE FOUR
TO FIFTEEN MILLION GOING INTO
SUPPORT THAT THOUSAND THOUSAND
THOUSAND PROJECT THE TRADES
TRANSIT SCHOOL BUSES FOR THE
ENERGY COMMISSION INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'VE ADDED IN
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
CONSUMER VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
UNIT FIFTY MILLION TO EXPAND
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. STATE WIDE.
UNDER FIFTY MILLION. ADS IS AND
SEVEN FACT- AND THEN FOR
MILLION TO HELP RAISE.
AWARENESS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE UP MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
GET TO YES- BOTH IN THE FLEET
SIDE BUT ALSO ON THE CONSUMER
SIDE. AND SO THE LAST POINT I
WANT TO MAKE FOUR HANDED IT OFF
TO- IS CARBON CITY BURGESS IS
THAT. THEY WE STILL HAVE THE AB
EIGHT RE AUTHORIZATION PROPOSAL
AND THERE AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT TO KEEP
THAT AND REALLY THAT'S DRIVING
AFTER TO WORD THIS IT'S FOR
MARKET SEARCH THAT MARKET
CERTAINTY AND SO. THIS FIRST.
YOU KNOW- BIG INVESTMENT FROM
AT A THREE POINT TWO BILLION
THAT'S REALLY THAT EARLY MARKET
LET'S GET THIS THING
KICKSTARTED. IN AB EIGHT
EXTENSION IS TO KEEP. THE
MOMENTUM GOING THROUGH TIME AND
THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW WITH THOSE
TWO TOGETHER IT'S REALLY ABOUT
ATTRACTING PRIVATE CAPITAL THE
PRIVATE CAPITAL WE NEED REALLY
JUST GET THE FEELING THAT THAT
HAVE PERCENT TARGETS THAT
WE'RE- ALL FAMILIAR WITH FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
IN SEPTEMBER. AND SO WITH THAT
WOULD BE HANDED OVER TO SENIOR
BURGESS AND THEN WE'LL G TO.
AN END AT AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. AFTER THAT SAYS.
SAID KEROBOKAN. SURE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SYDNEY BURKE. AND I A
DIVISION CHIEF AT THE- AIR
RESOURCE BOARD. SO IN THE MAY
REVISE ON THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE SIDE WHAT YOU REALLY
SEE IS A RECOGNITION THAT ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES ARE
BECOMING WIDELY AVAILABLE AND
THE LIGHT. MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY SPACE. WHICH CAN OFFER A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT CAN
OFFER HEALTH BENEFITS TO OUR
COMMUNITY IS. IT CAN PROVIDE
CONTINUES SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ZERO EMISSION
ECONOMY THAT'S LEADING AND
EXPANDING WITH ME HE'S OUR
COMPONENTS BEING CALIFORNIA'S
NUMBER ONE EXPORT. AND WHAT YOU
ALSO SEE IS A RECOGNITION THAT
NOW IS REALLY THE TIME TO BE
DOUBLING DOWN ON SUPPORTING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ZERO
EMISSION OPTIONS FOR PRIORITY
COMMUNITIES. SO SPECIFICALLY ME
ROCK MAY REVISE PROPOSAL YOU
SEE DOLLARS- A LIGHT DUTY SIDE-
TOWARDS EXPANDING THE CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE. EARLY THAT PROGRAM
IS ONLY ADMINISTERED AND LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM CURRENTLY SO BAY AREA
SAN JOAQUIN SOUTH COAST IN
SACRAMENTO. BUT THIS PROPOSAL
IS REALLY RECOGNIZING THAT
ACCESS TO ZERO EMISSION
MOBILITY OPTIONS. SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE STATE WINE. I'M
SENIOR HE- IN THE MAY REVISE
THERE IS FOR HUNDRED AND DOLLAR
A BIRTH YEARS A FOCUS ON LOW
AND MEDIUM INCOME VEHICLE
FIRES. AND THE HAVE YOU DECIDE
THE MAIN REVISED INCLUDES
EXPANDED RESOURCES TO PUT OVER
A THOUSAND DRAINAGE TRUCKS AT
THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES AND THE
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES THEIR
MISSION. FOCUSED ON ROLL ON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. SO THE
MAIN REVISED SPECIFICALLY WOULD
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO ADOPT ZERO MISSION
BY JETS AND AS I'M SURE YOU ARE
ALL AWARE. I TRANSIT AGENCIES
BUDGETS HAVE BEEN HACKED
ARTICULATE HARD BIKE HOLDEN-
AND ALSO DUE TO THE STRONG
PRESENCE OF- JUNCTION BOX
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS ENHANCED INVESTMENT. IN
ZERO EMISSION BUSES WILL ALSO
DELIVER. ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
THE STATE. WITH RESPECT IS
BUSES. THANK SAYS REQUIRES WERE
ON THIS AND MUCH MUCH HAS BEEN
DONE BUT ALSO MUCH REMAINS FOR
US TO DO. THERE'S OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES IN THE
STATE AND ONLY ABOUT 1% OF THEM
ARE ZERO MISSION. SO THIS
BUDGET WOULD REALLY REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
HELPING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARTICULARLY ROLES BALLISTICS
COLLECT TRACK. I'M IN THE
DROEGE STINKS WITH THE
IMPENDING TRUCK COMBUST
TURNOVER REQUIREMENTS EIGHT
THOUSAND RIDGE TRUCKS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO TURN OVER BETWEEN
NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
IT'S PARTICULARLY TIMELY TO
MAKE A CONCERTED EFFORT TO HELP
SMALL FLEETS AND INDEPENDENT
OWNER OPERATORS GET INTO ZERO
EMISSION HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS- AS
TYSON MENTIONED THIS FUNDING
WOULD OCCURRING CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH CDC GOMEZ AND
YOU TO ENSURE THAT OUR VEHICLE-
DEPLOYMENT INVESTMENTS. REALLY
DOVE TAIL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION- EMISSIONS
INVESTMENTS- IN ZERO EMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WITHOUT I
WILL TURN THIS OVER TO CC. IN
ORDER. HI GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HANNAH
RUSSELL ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE FUEL THE TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON THE
FEW KEY PORTIONS OF THE
PACKAGE. THIS PROPOSAL REALLY
PRESENT EXCITING AND UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO SOLIDIFY
CALIFORNIA AS A LEADER IN THE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS. I WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
RESORT THE BOARD CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITY CONNECTION GO
BAD DEPARTMENT. OF FINANCE. TO
NAME JUST A FEW. BUT ALSO LIKE
KNOW THAT THIS FURTHER A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA IMPORTANT GOAL. THIS
INCLUDES PUBLIC HEALTH THE
CLEAN AIR ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
CONVERT HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE.
WOULD BE TO SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
INCOME LEVEL. TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND OFFERED TO
ACT OF THE ECONOMIC STIMULUS
CREATING JOCKEY MANUFACTURING.
THANK YOU NOTE THEIR JOB IN THE
FUTURE AND LOCAL JOB IN
ENGINEERING CONSTRUCTION. I WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED CDC IS A LEAD
FOR THAT PURPOSE RECORD THE
STATE AND WE HAVE A REALLY
STRONG INTEREST IN GRIDLOCK THE
LIABILITY AND RESILIENT AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANYTHING TO
CONNECT TO THE GRID IS A GOOD.
NUMBER GRAD AND SO NEARLY 80%
OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR THIS EVENT
THE TRUCKER PACKAGE GOES
TOWARD- INFRASTRUCTURE AND THIS
IS BOTH ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. THE WHEN WE
TALK LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
IMPACT WILL. THE WE'RE
PROPOSING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
IS A BROAD INVESTMENT AND YOU
CAN REALLY I'M NOT IN THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
PORTIONS. ONE PORTION BEING THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO CLOSE THE LIGHT DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE GOT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND AGAIN I WANT
TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE BOTH ON
THE ELECTRIFIED THE ENTIRE
INSIDE OPERA POPULAR VEHICLE.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
GOOD FOR STRUCTURE THE POPULAR
VEHICLE. SO THE PORTIONS OUT OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO THE
COURT AND DEPRESSED COULD
TRANSITION FOR MEDIUM. DUTY AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK ABOUT THE-
THIS INCLUDES BROUGHT ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE. INTEREST TO FOR
DELIVERY TO. BOB TRUCKS GOOD
MOVEMENT. OR VEHICLE. THE
RANGERS AND THE HD VEHICLE AND
AGAIN SUPPORT BOTH ELECTRIC AND
HYDROGEN. BUT NOTHING NOTHING-
IT'S FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE THAT THE
DIMENSION THE OVER THOUSAND
GRADES TRUCK. ONE THOUSAND
TRANSIT BUSES ONE THOUSAND GOLD
BUT THE SUPPORTING BOTH
ELECTRIC AND HYDROGEN AND WILL
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH CARD
ISSUE ROLL THIS OUT THANK YOU
COMMISSION WILL UTILIZE THEIR
ENERGIZED PROJECT. AND PARTNER
WITH CARDS H. THE PROJECT AND
TO GO HAND. IN HAND TO MAKE IT
ABOUT THE OTHER. THE LAST OF
THAT- AND YOU HUNDRED FIFTH
MILLION. WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
THAT. AND I RELATED
MANUFACTURING. I WANT NOTED
ENERGY COMMISSION HAD A LONG
HISTORY IN MANUFACTURING
INVESTMENT. WE'VE INVESTED
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON TWENTY SIX
PROJECT. AND THIS IS A STATE-
COMPANIES LIKE PROTERRA CHARGE
POINT. ZERO MOTORCYCLES AND
TRANSPOWER. YOU SHOULD BE
INVESTMENT BY THE FEET HE HAD
RESULT IN MATCH FUNDING IN
EXCESS OF ONE DOLLAR ONE DOLLAR
BUT WE PUT IN. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS THEY'RE PUTTING IN MORE
THAN THAT THIS IS REALLY TRACK
PRIVATE FIND THE CALIFORNIA. WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD BE THE NEW
MICHIGAN ONE COMPANIES THAT
MANUFACTURE. WE ALREADY HAVE
OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND JOBS. AND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY COMPANIES
BUSINESSES AND MANUFACTURERS.
IN THE STATE WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE MORE MANUFACTURING
COME TO CALIFORNIA. AND WE WANT
TO HELP. PROMISING NEW
COMPANIES GROW. A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT GREAT. AB OFFENSE
THE TYPE SANCTIONS. WE
ORIGINALLY OUT THANK YOU TO
FORTY. WE ARE NOW ASKING FOR A
SHOW THANK AND I JUST THIRTY
FIVE. WE'RE NO ONGER
REQUESTING BONTA FORTY AND
WE'RE NO LONGER REQUEST TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM. WE THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO EXTEND
EIGHTY EIGHT BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE RELIABLE
PREDICTABLE FUNDING FOR BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT. RELATABILITY THE
SPECIALLY IMPORTANT REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS THAT RETIREMENT CYCLE
AND PEOPLE RETIREMENT SCUTTLED
WE WANT TO PROVIDE A CLEAR PATH
DOWN TO CONVERT OVER TIME THIS
ALSO BRINGS IN A LOT OF. TRYING
TO FIND THE CAPITAL TO THE
STATE YEAH I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY COMPETING
WITH OTHER STATES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES. FOR THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND IF WE DON'T MAKE
THE INVESTMENT WE SHOW THAT A
LONG TERM COMMITMENT TO WHAT WE
COULD LOSE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES-
WITHOUT OKAY GOOD MY REMARKS
AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. HI SIR I RECOGNIZE. WE IT
HE L. L. WE'VE GOT THE UNDER
COMMISSION WITH FOR THE L. A.
AND YOU CALL MAY. THEY'VE GOT.
CLOSE COORDINATION BETWEEN KOBE
IS IN THE AIRPORT AND ENERGY
COMMISSION AND CPUC. ITS FINGER
LAW. WHAT ARE YOUR COMMENTS ON
THIS. SPLIT BETWEEN HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CARBON CC IN THIS SORT OF THE
TRADE OFFS AND IS IN THE
PROPOSAL. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SO AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING BILLION I'M PRESSED
PRESIDENT AN INCREASE IN
SPENDING FOR IS OUT OF PROGRAMS
AND SO. ON THIS COMMITTEE
ASSIGNED A COUPLE HEARINGS
RECENTLY ON THIS TOPIC SO I
WON'T GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL
BUT MONIES AS IS GENERALLY
CONSISTENT WITH VARIOUS STATE
KLEINER QUALITY GOALS
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AS TRANSPORTATION AS A AS A
MAJOR SOURCE OF THOSE
EMISSIONS. HOWEVER BEFORE
APPROVING ALL OR SOME OF THIS
PACKAGE WOULD MAKE THE
LEGISLATURE ONE I'M SURE THE
PACKAGE IS CONSISTENT WITH ITS
KIND OF BROADER FINER QUALITY
STRATEGIES AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT THERE IS AN ADEQUATE
PROCESS IN PLACE TO EVALUATE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES SO MY PROVIDE
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
ONSOME OF THOSE COMMENTS AND
I. AND A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS
SO WHEN HIGHLIGHT I REALLY FOUR
G. QUESTIONS BASED ON OUR
PRELIMINARY REVIEW. FIRST IS
ARE THE PROPOSED SPENDING
CATEGORIES AND PROGRAM DESIGNS
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE- THIS
PACKAGE I'M NOT A MONEY WOULD
GO TO HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
PROGRAMS THAT'S ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION COMPARED TO LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS WHICH
WOULD GET ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION. SO ALMOST TWICE AS
MUCH FOR HEAVY DUTY ALSO THE
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR CVR P.
WOULD- GO TO ENTIRELY TO THE
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME PORTION
OF THE PROGRAM. OUR ELIGIBILITY
IS ONLY UP 24100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL SO THAT'S
A YOU CAN CHANGE FROM KIND OF
THE BROADER CTRP PROGRAM AND-
IS A MUCH LOWER INCOME CUTS FOR
ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE REBATES.
THE LEGISLATURE WE JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT THOSE SPENDING
ALLOCATIONS AND PROGRAM DESIGNS
ALIGN WITH ITS PRIORITIES
HOWEVER MUCH MONEY IT ENDS UP-
ALLOCATING. I SECONDS HOW WILL
THE PROGRAMS BE EVALUATED- AS
NOTED IN PRIOR REPORTS MORE
OFFICE AND OTHERS THERE IS
LIMITED RELIABLE INFORMATION ON
THE RELATIVE COST EFFECTIVENESS
ORANGE DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. THE
LEGISLATURE WARRANTED CONSIDER
MAYBE REQUIRING. THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
PLAN. ACTING CONSUL WITH
OUTSIDE RESEARCHERS TACKLE THE
NEST DATA. AND EVALUATE OUR OF
THE PRO BOTH THE FUN OF THE WAR-
WHICH COULD ENSURE THAT THERE'S
GOING TO. OF WHAT'S THE- AND
FUTURE YEARS ABOUT. WHAT WE'RE
GETTING FOR THIS. OF WORKING
WELL AND WHAT ISN'T. THIRD-
SHOULD THE FUND FOR THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS BOTH
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE BE
SPLIT BETWEEN CARBON CC HEARD
THAT- THE PROPOSAL WOULD
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR- BOTH OF
THOSE AGENCIES WHEN IT COMES
TO- DRAYAGE TRUCKS. TRANSIT
BUSES AND SCHOOL BUSES SO CC
WILL GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PORTION OF THAT FUNDING AND CAR
WOULD GET THE- FUNDING FOR THE
VEHICLES- AND SWELL THIS. HAS
TRADITIONALLY SORT OF BEEN THE
SPLIT ON THE LIGHT DUTY SIDE OF
THINGS WERE CARD GETS THE
FUNDING FOR VEHICLES ENERGY
COMMISSION GETS INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING- WITHIN SORT OF THE
RATIONALE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT ON THE HEAVY DUTY
SIDE OF THINGS WHERE. A LOT OF
CASES- IT'S INITIALLY IS
ADOPTING THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY.
THEY ARE PUTTING IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADOPTING THE
VEHICLES AT THE SAME TIME AND
SO THERE'S- OF THE FUNDING WILL
BE COMING OUT ABOUT THE SAME
TIME TO THE SAME ENTITIES AND
SO- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT IT
CONTINUES TO MAKE SENSE TO KIND
OF HAVE THAT FUNDING. AND THE
PROGRAMMATIC ADMINISTRATION
SEPARATE BETWEEN A. R. B. AND
ENERGY COMMISSION- BECAUSE IT
COULD CREATE POTENTIAL. ISSUES
AROUND COORDINATION AND ACCESS
TO MINISTRY OF COSTS SO. THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. AND THEN FINALLY THE
FOURTH QUESTION WHICH HAS BEEN
RAISED A COUPLE TIMES THE
EXTENSION OF AB EIGHT CITIES
WHICH IS. STILL PART OF THE
PROPOSAL- SINCE THE- CURRENT
PROPOSAL THE MAYOR VISION
DOESN'T CONTINUE THE- PROPOSED
SECURITIZATION OF THOSE AB
EIGHT. AND THE FEES DON'T
SUNSET UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR- THE EXTENSION OF THOSE
FEES ISN'T REALLY NECESSARY TO
AN AXE. THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PACKAGE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING. AS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO DEFER
ACTION ON THAT PARTICULAR PART
OF THE PROPOSAL JUST TO ENSURE
THAT HAS. SUFFICIENT TIME TO
WEIGH THE MERITS OF THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF ONE OF ITS BROADER.
OVERALL TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION STRATEGY. BUT SO I
WILL IN MY COMMENTS THERE HAVE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS DON'T YOU
INTERPRET THIS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NOT HAVING
CONTINUOUS FUNDING ON THE
PROGRAM SORT. OF A PROPER AS WE
THE LEGISLATURE THAT WILL WE
CAN. THE FOR. HOW WE SPEND IT
IS GOING TO BE SET UP BY FUTURE
LEDGE. LEGISLATURE THERE THERE-
AND THAT'S IT THAT'S A-
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE OR IS IT NOT.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK- YOU KNOW
THERE THERE'S- ADAM WAS WITH US
WE TALKED ABOUT ON KIND OF THE
EIGHTY EIGHT THE STUFF BEFORE
THERE'S- THERE'S GONNA
RATIONALE TO KIND OF TAKE
EXTEND THE SEASON THE PROGRAMS
TO KIND OF PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE I THINK AND- AND DIFFERENT
KIND OF FUNNY DIFFERENT AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS THERE ARE BIG
QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT BEST MAKES A PROGRAM
SHOULD BE GOING FORWARD- AND SO
YOU KNOW THE THAT YOU KNOW IT
MADE VERY WELL BE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SORT OF THE SITES
YES WE DO WANT SORT OF THAT-
THAT FUNDING STREAM TO EXTEND
GOING FORWARD I THINK. THE MAIN
ISSUE ON THAT PARTICULAR PIECE
OF IT IS JUST IT TURNED OUT
THAT THE EXTENSION I'M NOT
DECISION DOESN'T NECESSARILY
NEED TO HAPPEN RIGHT NOW IN
PARTICULAR TO KIND OF ABOUT
THIS THIS PACKAGE BUT IF THE
LEGISLATURE SORTS USE THAT AS A
VALUABLE FUNDING STREAM GOING
FORWARD AND- CLEARLY THAT'S
KINDOF WITHIN. A WITHIN ITS
PURVIEW TO IT TO EXTEND THAT
FUNDING AND WORK OUT EXACTLY.
HOW IT'S HOW IT'S BEEN GOING
FORWARD. WELL I THINK CHECK
BENNY SAID TIMING IS EVERYTHING
ALRIGHT. AS ME LEFT WITH THAT-
OKAY. SENATOR DOLLY HAS THE
QUESTIONS. I'VE BEEN OVER
DESERVE PROGRAM. THANKS THANK
YOU FOR THE- DISCUSSIONS WE
WILL HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
OFFLINE- OBVIOUSLY IS THE
SENATOR WHO AS TESLA AND THEIR
DEATH THEIR DISTRICT I'D LIKE
TO SEE THEM IT'LL HAVE A ROBUST
AND SEVENTY OR 80% OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
AND THEY THAT THEY WOULD BE A
ROBUST PORTION OF THE- THE
PROGRAMS THERE AND OBVIOUSLY
THE ERROR BOARD. KNOWS WHAT'S
ON MY FEELINGS ON THE OTHER
PART OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM SO CENTER DALI DOESN'T
WHAT I JUST WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT I KNOW THAT. I AM IN
THE TRUCKING BUSINESS AND I'VE
BEEN- REVIEWING LIKE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS AND THERE IT IS TO
MY KNOWLEDGE THERE ISN'T-
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AVAILABLE. AND
SO WERE YOU KNOW GRADUALLY
MOVING TOWARDS TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE AT A- FASTER RATE IN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. BUT THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF- THE NOT ON THE
BUS ON THE BUS AND- IN TRANSIT
SIDE OBVIOUSLY WE'VE THAT
THAT'S WHAT THOSE REPUBLIC AGES
BUT THE PRIVATE FOLKS THAT ARE
WORKING AROUND THE DOCKS AND-
THE LIKES OF AND HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO CHANGE OUT THERE-
VEHICLES TO MEET THE STANDARD
THAT WE HAVE TODAY- WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE- PROCESS LOOK LIKE
FOR THEM THAT IF THEY'VE HAD
JUST MADE THIS INVESTMENT. AND
THEN WERE PUSHING THEM TOWARDS-
YOU KNOW SO AS AS HAVE A WEEK
HOW THE AND THE THOSE ARE THESE
ARE OWNER OPERATORS A LOT OF
THEM HOW ARE THEY GOING TO MAKE
THAT CHANGE AND WHAT WHAT'S
THE- INCENTIVE FOR. MANAGED
THEY JUST MADE A CHANGE ARE
PROBABLY HAVE PAYMENTS. FOR
SOMETIME ALLOTTEES OR VERY
SHORT DISTANCE THEY MOVE
MATERIALS VERY SHORT DISTANCE
OTHER THE- THEIR QUICKNESS LAST
A LONG TIME. CHERYL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- AND
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
IN DEPTH INVOLVEMENT IN THE
STATUS SO I'LL JUST START BY
SAYING THAT IN TERMS OF THIS
YOUR MISSION AVAILABILITY FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
THAT REALLY HAS EXPANDED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS OVER
SIX MAJOR OEMS HAVE ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY ARE IN PRODUCTION OR
WILL BE IN PRODUCTION BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ZERO EMISSION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS- A PART OF THE
OVERALL IS PORTFOLIO HERE IS
ALSO THAT ACCORDING TO THE
DANCE CLEAN TRUCK REGULATION
ABOUT THE CARDBOARD RECENTLY
ADOPTED THAT TRUCK
MANUFACTURERS INORDER TO BE
ABLE TO SELL IN CALIFORNIA WILL
NEED TO BE BRINGING ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS TO MARKET
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
WITH ESCALATING PERCENTAGES
FROM THEIR- IN TERMS OF HELPING
OUT YOU KNOW THE SMALL
INDEPENDENT OWNER OPERATORS ARE
SMALL FLEETS YOU DISCUSS I
REALLY THINK THAT THE MAIN
REVISED. IS REALLY INTENDED TO
HELP SUPPORT- THE TURNOVER TWO
ZERO MISSION PARTICULARLY
TARGETED. AT THOSE PLEASE THAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT TO HELP
THEM GET INTO ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS AND HELP MAKE THAT UP
FRONT INVESTMENTS- CERTAINLY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE EIGHT
THOUSAND THREE TRUCKS THAT ARE
TURNING OVER AT THE FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WE REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HELPING
THEM GET JUST YOUR IMMERSION
TRUCKS. ARTICULATED HEAD OF ANY
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS MIGHT
BE COMING. TO BE CONTINUED
THANK YOU EVERYONE THIS WILL
CONCLUDE PART AA ARE BECAUSE WE
HAVE ANOTHER FOR BRINGING A
GENDER. WE WILL BE IN CONTACT
WITH EACH OF YOU THANK YOU FOR.
THAT I'M GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE
A SHORT RECESS BECAUSE OUR
STAFF NEEDS TO MOVE OUT HERE
AND DO A CLEANING BEFORE WE
START PART B. BUT- IN A FEW
MINUTES WILL RESUME PART B.
YOU. BACK TO ORDER. WE WILL
BEGIN PART B. WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
THAT CAL FIRE. DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT FISH
AND- WILDLIFE. THE PARKS THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
HELLO EPA THE AIR RESOURCE
BOARD THE DEPARTMENT TAXES
SUBSTANCE CONTROL. THE CAL
RECYCLE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AND
MAYBE THE ENERGY SHOULD
COMMISSION THE- CPUC FIVE BANKS
AND THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AS WELL AS FINANCING
THE L. A. L. I THINK I CAN GET
IT ALL DONE- THIS IS. NOTHING
LIKE TO CHALLENGE THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH START UP
FOR YOU SECRETARY ROSS TELL US
ABOUT ALL THE GOOD THINGS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES FOR THE-
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE ON
THIS TUESDAY MORNING AND I WILL
COVER- OUR PORTION OF NAY
REVISED AS QUICKLY AND SAFELY
AS I POSSIBLY CAN- WE HAVE
BASIC- THREE MAJOR BACKUPS THAT-ALL START WITH THE FOUNDATION
OF AGRICULTURE WHICH IS. IS ON
THE FARM AND WHAT KEEPS US
PROACTIVE IN A CHANGING CLIMATE
SO OUR FIRST OUR FIRST CATEGORY
OF FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED NAY REVISED HER AROUND
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE FOR
SUSTAINABILITY AND RESILIENCY.
FOR THESE ARE OUR ON GOING
CLIMATE SMART AG PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO TWO PROGRAMS AT OUR
HOUSE AT THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THAT I WILL
ALSO TOUCH ON. THE TOTAL OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND BUDGET YEAR AND
THE BREAKDOWN IS AS FOLLOWS-
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED AN
INCREASED INVESTMENT FAN ARE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM. WHICH IS
WHICH IS ONE THAT PROVIDES A
MULTITUDE OF BENEFITS INCLUDING
THE PRODUCTIVITY OF OUR SOILS
OVER THE LONG TERM THE ABILITY
TO DRIVE DOWN CARBON AND STORED
IN OUR SOILS CLASS ALL ORGANIC
MATTER THAT INCREASES
BIODIVERSITY ACTIVITY AS WELL
AS NUTRIENT CYCLING AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY WATER HOLDING
CAPACITY THE PROPOSAL IS FOR.
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FINAL
CHANGE INVESTMENT FUND- THE
PROPOSAL FOR MAY REVISED
INCLUDES SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LIVESTOCK METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAMS THESE HAVE BEEN HOUSED
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE THE JERRY SECTOR IN
PARTICULAR THAT FAMILIES HAVE
REALLY STEPPED UP INTO THIS
SPACE. TO LOOK AT HOW THEY CAN
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND ESPECIALLY NOTHING DUCTION
WHICH IS JUST CERTAINLY HAVE
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS. THE
PROPOSAL FOR SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN OUR DAILY
DIGESTS YOUR PROGRAM WE HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT. PROGRESS ON
THE MANDATE. TO REDUCE METHANE
REDUCTION WITH THESE TWO- THE
NEW YORK. THAT'S BEEN. IS
THIRTY NINE DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND FOR PUBLIC HAVE PROGRAM.
WE ENVISION THIS IS TO ALLEN TO
ONE WOULD BE DIRECT CENTER
GRANTS TO INDIVIDUAL FARMERS TO
CREATE FORAGE AND HABITAT FOR
POLLINATORS. SOME OF THESE
PRACTICES ARE INCLUDED IN OUR
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM HAVE
ACROSS AND HAD SHOWS FOR TWO
EXAMPLES OF THAT. BUT WE ARE
ESPECIALLY INTERESTED WITH THE
LAUNCH OF A NEW CALIFORNIA
POLLINATOR COALITION LAST MONTH
REALLY LOOKING AT MORE AT
LANDSCAPE SCALE PROJECTS ON A
REGIONAL BASIS. BUT WHAT
HAPPENED NUMBER OF LANDOWNERS
INVOLVED. TO BE ABLE TO AND- A
CREATE THAT CONTINUOUS HABITAT
AND FORAGE FOR THE HEALTH OF
OUR OUR NAY DEEP AS WELL AS-
IMPORTED- BEES AND OTHER- O
POLLINATORS WHICH INCLUDE
MONARCH BUTTERFLIES BATS AND
BIRDS- THAT'S THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS. I KNEW OUR PROGRAM BUT
ONE HAS BEEN UNDER DISCUSSION
BAYERN BAYERN MENTAL FARMING
SCIENCE HEALTH FOR THE PAST
YEAR. YES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO PARTNER WITH ROWERS TO
CREATE CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT
PLANS THIS CAN BE A WHOLE FARM
CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT PLAN TO
TAKE IN A VARIETY OF PRACTICES
INCLUDING. I PM THEIR ADDITION
MANAGEMENT WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE THESE ARE
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAMS
THAT CAN COST AS MUCH AS TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO DEVELOP
THEM THEY ALSO WILL LEVERAGE
THAT FARMER TO BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY HAPPY AND TWO NRCS
DOLLARS IN THE. UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE. OR A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW TO. WHICH
ONE OF OUR PROGRAM THING TO DO
TOO WE DO GREENHOUSE GAS AND-
INCLUDED IN THESE WOULD BE
TRANSITION TO ORGANIC. PLANS OF
IT TAKES A THREE YEAR PROCESS
IT'S A PRETTY BIG INVESTMENT TO
DECIDE YOU WANT TO GO THIS WAY
AND HAVING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO CREATE THESE
PLANS. IS A FARMER A GOOD SENSE
OF WHAT KINDS OF RISKS THAT
MIGHT BE TAKING ON AND SHARING%
THE COSTS OF DEVELOPING THAT
PLAN. WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
FUNDING CARBON FARM PROGRAMS-
ON THE FAR THE TO AIRPORT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSAL. IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND- TO SUPPORT THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY- TO REDUCE AND
PHASE OUT OPEN AGRICULTURAL
BURNING THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN PRACTICE.
THAT IS FACING THE INDUSTRY BUT
THE BASE OUT OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME. AND THE LAST
ONE IS ONGOING INVESTMENT IN
THE FARMER PROGRAM WHICH IS
ENGINE REPLACEMENT AND
EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND TO REDUCE
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS. THIS IS
BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTOR. TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR DISTRICT. BEING ABLE
TO ACHIEVE. COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL CLEAN ACT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENT FUND
AT FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND. AT FOUR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE. NO FROM THE GENERAL
FUND I MISSPOKE I'M BACK. THE
SECOND CATEGORY IS REALLY
CONNECTING THE PRODUCTIVITY
THAT WE DO ON THE FARM. TO HOW
WE PUT THAT INTO THE CHANNELS
OF TRADE TO REACH EVERY
CONSUMER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY RESILIENT
AND EQUITABLE FOOD SYSTEMS.
OBVIOUSLY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS FOR THE
SHUT DOWN OF THE ECONOMY THE
LOTS OF FREE SERVICE THE
CREATIVENESS OF THE FARM
COMMUNITY AND DOING MORE
ONLINE. PLATFORMS TO REACH
CONSUMERS DIRECTLY. AND ONE OF
OUR NEWER PROGRAMS THAT
LAUNCHED LAST YEAR AS A FORM
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. REALLY
THINKING THROUGH HOW DO WE
REACH THOSE HARD TO REACH
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE GOOD AND SECURE OR NOT
GETTING THE KINDS OF NUTRITION
THAT THEY MAKE. AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING MORE LOCALLY FROM
CALIFORNIA PRODUCED FROM GERMAN
SO THAT WE'RE CREATING LOCAL
ECONOMIES AT SCALE AND REGIONAL
BASIS- THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSES INCREASING THE
INVESTMENT. IN THE INCUBATOR
PROGRAM FOR FARM TO SCHOOL BY
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
WOULD INCLUDE. NOT ONLY
INCREASING ACCESSIBILITY TO
GRANT FUNDS THAT WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN BEST TO DO
A THREE YEAR EVALUATION. YOU
KNOW WHAT WORKS BEST AND FOR
REALLY GETTING OUTCOMES THAT WE
PROPOSE IN OUR GRANT PROGRAMS.
IT INCLUDES TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR IMPROVEMENT AGRICULTURE
GRANT PROGRAMS. THIS IS TO
REALLY ASSESS THE INCREASING
NUMBER OF URBAN FARMS AND LARGE
SCALE. COMMUNITY GARDENS THAT
ARE BEING CONVERTED INTO FARMS
TO CREATE MORE ACCESS BUT THOSE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AFTER TIME
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE REALLY DEPENDED ON HAVING
THAT KIND OF ACCESS TO FRESH
AND LOCALLY GROWN PRODUCE. UP
AND JUST REALLY REVITALIZING.
URBAN FARM SYSTEMS. I CAN. OF
OUR- NUTRITION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. THIS IS ONE THAT THEY
ON THE- THAT WERE DONE IN THE
CHIU YEARS THAT DONE THIS.
REALLY UNDER HOW WE BEST REACH
LOW INCOME SHOPPERS TO SUPPORT
THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS LOCALLY FRESH
PRODUCE CALIFORNIA PRODUCED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
GENERAL FUND FOR THAT PROGRAM.
A CONTINUATION AND EXPANSION OF
OUR PILOT HEALTH REFRIGERATION
GRANT PROGRAM WITH A ONE TIME
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENT. WE PROPOSE TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM TO SERVE
NEW TYPESCRIPT GRANTEES
INCLUDING FOOD BANKS AND FOOD
DONATION PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
TO CORNER STORES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WHAT WE
CHARACTERIZE AS FOOD DESERT
COMMUNITIES. IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING FOOD BANKS AND THEIR
DONATION PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. OVER THE YEARS TO
INCREASE OPERATING IN THOSE
FAMILY FOOD BOXES TO AND TO
INCLUDE MORE FRESH PRODUCE. BUT
WITH THE SURGE OF A 73%
INCREASE IN NEED. THROUGH FOOD
BANKS FOR FAMILIES THAT FOUND
THEMSELVES SUDDENLY UNEMPLOYED
THEY NEED THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE THE NUTRITION OF
THOSE BOXES. AND LAST A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS
AND TO LEVERAGE A SENIOR
FARMERS MARKET NUTRITION
PROGRAM. WITH SO MANY SENIORS
WHO DURING CLOUT PORTANTINO.
NOT ABLE TO. USE A COUPON
PROGRAM THAT WE CAN RUNNING FOR
NOT OF YEARS OF BEING ABLE TO
OUT OF THE BANKS WE'VE FOUND
CREATED WAYS DO MARK.
COMMUNITIES OF. AGRICULTURE BOX
DELIVERED TO THEM AND
PARTNERING WITH FARMERS MARKETS
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND WE SEE
THAT YOU NEED FOR THAT KIND OF-
A STOPGAP PROGRAM FOR ONE MORE
YEAR WITH THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO LEVERAGE
USDA PROGRAMS LAWLER SAID. I'M
TO THE STATE. THE LAST CATEGORY
IS REALLY AROUND HOW DO WE USE
IN OUR FARMING COMMUNITIES
INVESTMENTS FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WITH AFOCUS ON HIGH
ROAD JOB GROWTH. AND INCLUSIVE
EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS
A FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL
INCLUDES THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE FRESNO
MERCED FUTURE OF FOOD
INNOVATION INITIATIVE. THIS WAS
ACTUALLY PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY
JANUARY BUDGET. AND THEN WITH
THE CHANGE IN OUR REVENUE
SITUATION WAS ELIMINATED AT
THAT TIME. THEY HAVE CONTINUED
TO DO THEIR STRATEGIC PLANNING
FOR THEIR OUT REACH AND THEIR
PLANS DEVELOPMENT THIS IS ABOUT
CAPITALIZING ON AGRICULTURE AND
THE SPECIALTY CROP THAT WE HAVE
IN THE DIVERSITY OF PRODUCTS
THAT WE HAVE. OF BEING ABLE TO
FOCUS ON WATER IN DROUGHT
MANAGEMENT REALLY CREATING
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY
CENTERS THE PROGRAM IT
PROGRAMMING JOBS THAT GO WITH
THAT AND REALLY IMPROVING AND
ENHANCING THE INTELLECTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BETWEEN YOU SEE
MORE SAD. THE ISSUE FRESNO AND
OTHER CAMPUSES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO REALLY IMPROVE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE ECONOMY AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BY A FOCUS
ON AGRICULTURAL TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION. AS WELL AS UP
SKILLING FARMWORKERS PHYSICIANS
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS FOR
pDOLLARS WOULD HELP IN THE IN
THE FIRST YEAR OF A TEN YEAR
BUILDING PROGRAM FOR THAT
INNOVATION CORRIDOR. IT
INCLUDES A ONE TIME TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MOVING BEGINNING
FARMER TRAINING THIS IS A FOCUS
ON FARMWORKERS WHO WHAT YOU
HAVE FARMERS AS WELL AS THE
FARM MANAGER APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IT'S AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES FOR MANAGER JOBS OF
THESE ARE GOOD JOBS.IN THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AN ADDITIONAL-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SERVE
UNDERSERVED FARMERS TO HELP
THEM TAP INTO GRANT PROGRAMS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS WELL AS AT
THE STATE LEVEL. AND FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT. AN ALIGNMENT OF
REGULATORY RECORDING TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THAT PAPERWORK FOR
THAT SO MANY OF OUR SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS FAILED. IN
COMPLYING WITH OUR PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WANTED TO CLOSE ON A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL- FOR
FAIRGROUND AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND EVACUATION
CENTERS THIS IS REALLY LOOKING
AT THE MULTITUDE OF STATE OWNED
FACILITIES. THAT REHAB
THROUGHOUT ON DECEMBER STATE
HELLO. THAT ARE NORMALLY FOR
BUT NOT X. FOR GROUNDS THAT ARE
USED YOU BACK PURPOSES. AND
INCREASING IMPORTANT RESPONSE
PURPOSES THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
WE WOULD BE PARTNERING WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
HELLFIRE AND THE AND THE- PR-
OFFICE FROM THAT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. TO REALLY
ENCOURAGE AND INCENTIVIZE MORE
LOCAL RESILIENCY PLANNING AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE EQUIPPED
FOR SAFE EVACUATION CENTERS
MERGES THE RESPONSE CENTERS OF
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THEN
THINKING ABOUT THE FLIPPING
FUSSED EXCEPT THE FACILITIES
FOR LONGER TERM SOCIETAL AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS WITHIN THE-
COUNTIES- AND THEN THE LAST
PROGRAM I DID WANT TO MENTION.
MISTER CHAIRS ARE SUSTAINABLE
CALIFORNIA. GROWN CANNABIS
PILOT PROGRAM. THE LEGAL I'M
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN ONE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A NUMBER OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS THAT WE
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE DATA ON THE
GROWING PRACTICES BE ABLE TO
SET BENCHMARKS AND THEN CREATED
SENT TO PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
ALIGN WITH THAT. WE PROPOSE
THIS IS ONE TIME NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CAPTURE THE DATA
WORK WITH OUR LICENSE GROWERS
WHO ARE OUTDOOR GROWERS AND
SOME OF OUR LEGACY COMMUNITIES
TO BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER THE
MANUALS ON BEST MNAGEMENT
PRACTICES. TO MITIGATE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS WHETHER
IT'S ON WATER USE A PEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES NUTRIENT
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND BE
ABLE TO. INCORPORATE SOIL
HEALTH PRACTICES TO SEQUESTER
CARBON AND WITH THAT I WILL
WAIT FOR HUMAN HEY- I HOPE I
DIDN'T RAISE TO THAT TOO
QUICKLY THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
WAS DETERMINED. IT'S THAT TYPE
OF MORNING THANK YOU SECRETARY
ROSS LISTEN. TO SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD WE HAVE. THE
PROPOSAL THE CIRCUIT ECONOMY AS
WELL AS OTHER. ACTIVITIES CAL
RECYCLED PARTNER TOXIC
SUBSTANCE PRESS THE SIDE. WATER
BOARD GOOD MORNING SECRETARY
BLOOM FELL. GOOD MORNING CHECK%
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
APPRECIATE THE TIME- FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME'S JEFF
BLUMENFELD I'M THE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA'S EPA. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
WITH YOU TODAY- AS YOU SAID- IT
SAYS THAT IT BASICALLY TO THING
THE YOU SAID LAST WEEK WHAT ONE
IS HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER AND
TODAY IS HOW WE CAN. CONNECT
THE DOTS- AND REALLY AS AS YOU
SAID MANY TIMES YEAH THIS CLIMB
EVER CRISIS REQUIRES US TO TAKE
BIG BOLD STEPS- THE TIME IS
REALLY RUN OUT THE CLOCK
MEASURES AND SAYS THIS. MAY
REVISION BUDGET REALLY PROPOSES
THE GIGANTIC INVESTMENT IN AN
EQUITABLE COBB AND YOU CHILL
TOMORROW- AND IF YOU HAD FROM
SECRETARY ROSS AND WE'LL HEAR
FROM SECOND YOU CREDIT FOR THE
MOMENT. THIS IS AN ALL OF THE
GOVERNMENT ALL OF GOVERNMENT
COORDINATED BUDGET AND APPROACH
TO TACKLING CLIMATE AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND SO AS
WE WILL THAT. DECIDING THAT-
MAY REVISION AS IT RELATES TO
CLIMATE AND OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES WE LOOK AT THREE CORE
PRINCIPLES JUST HELP
CONTEXTUALIZE THAT HEALTH THAT
COULD BE AND JOBS. WE ALSO LOOK
FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THAT OUT DOLLARS
WE GET FED THAT WHETHER THAT'S
ONE ELECTRIFYING SCHOOL BUSES
FOR REBUILDING DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE SAYS. JUMPING
RIGHT IN I'M IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR POPE FOR THE BUDGET
KELLY P. A. AT JUST THE VOCAL
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS AND
NEARLY NINE BILLION DOLLARS THE
MAYOR VISIONS ALMOST TWICE THAT
MARKED THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL BUDGET AND-
STATE'S HISTORY. AND
IMPORTANTLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THE BUDGET RAISES ALL BOATS
TOGETHER AS THE RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC AND RIGHTS TO MEET
THE CHALLENGES INCLINED THAT IN
THE STATE. THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISED TARGETS 60% OR
MORE OF ITS OVERALL FUNDING TO
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ACROSS. THE STATE.
OF THE OVERWHELMINGLY. OF COLOR.
WE'RE A LIFELINE FIND TO CALL
THE CAL RATHER THROUGH A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR AND TO COVER I'M
TAKE MORE BILLS TO KEVIN
NINETEEN IF I DID MY NEEDED
RELIEF IN THE AND FOR ACROSS
THE STATE AND SOME ABOUT MY
VULNERABLE CAN BE WITH ALSO X.
THE GROUND OPPORTUNITIES TO
COUNTY DA'S BY MENTAL JUSTICE
PROGRAMS. TO HELP BUILD LOCAL
CAPACITY GIVE ME J. COMMUNITIES
ABILITY TO HELP STATE
INVESTMENT IN THE BUDGET THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY THAT'S
PART OF THE MAY REVISED
GOVERNOR NEWSOM UNVEILED A FIVE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
YET PLAN FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE DROUGHT RESPONSE
AND IMPROVE CLIMATE RESILIENT
THAT INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT FACE
DRINKING WATER THAT INCLUDING
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TO DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION TO
GRAPPLE TO CLEAN UP AND WATER
RECYCLING TO IMPROVE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE BY PROTECTING
DRINKING. WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU HAD EARLY
THIS MORNING FROM COBB THE C.
GO THE ABOUT THEIR- LIKE TO
BELIEVE BULLS DATEABLE. AND
EQUITABLE TO. SYSTEM BY
CREATING A AND- THIS IS CENTRO
TO OUR MAY READ. AND CHECK OF
FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS LAST WEEK WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE PROJECTS. THAT
WE ARE INVESTING AND- THEY
REALLY RELATE TO THIS TWAIN
GOAL OF BEING ABLE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
REDUCING CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
AND THERE'S NO BETTER WAY THAN
DOING THAT AND THIS GOES THE L.
A. AS COMMENTS- THEN FOCUSING
ON HEAVY DUTY- AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS A BALANCE
BETWEEN- BUT AND RURAL. SO THE
SCHOOL BUSES THE FALCONS THEIR
MISSION SCHOOL BUSES IT BECAUSE
IT'S ON THE RURAL COMMUNITY-
THE TRANSIT BUSES ALL OVER THE
STATE AND THE DRAINAGE TRACKS-
PARTICULARLY- REPORTS GOING TO
WAREHOUSING. I DID WANT TO SAY
ONE FIVE US EVERYTHING I THINK
WAS COVERED IN THE LAST
PRESENTATIONS BUT THAT WAS
THERE. A QUESTION ABOUT EIGHTY
EIGHT- WHICH IS RE
AUTHORIZATION OF A FUNDING I'LL
LOVE THAT FUNDING GOES TO ADD
DISTRICTS AND OTHERS FOR THE
CABALLERO PROGRAM. THAT IS
ACTUALLY REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT
AS YOU KNOW SEVEN OF THE TEN
WEST THAT SHEDS IN THAT
COUNTRY- UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA- WE RELY ON THE
CREDIT WE GET. UNDER THE STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS FROM
COMMONWEALTH FUNDING AND
UNFORTUNATELY IF WE DON'T MEET
THE TARGET SET OUT IN THOSE WE
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO LOSE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION- FUNDING. AB HAS
UNITED THE CLEAN AIR ACT THE
IS. A PENALTY FOR NOT ACHIEVING
THE MILESTONES IN THE CLEAN AIR
ACT WHICH IS REDUCING THOSE.
AND POTENTIALLY LOSING FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS SAYS WE
WOULD PLACE A LOT OF EMPHASIS-
AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT IN
YOUR CAR IMINT KERR ABOUT-
WILLINGNESS WORK WITH
LEGISLATURE- ON THAT ON THAT
ISSUE RELATING APPROACH. WE
NEED TO GET DONE IF YOU. I
THING THAT WE NEED TO GET DONE
YEAR WHICH YOU'VE BEEN H. ON
AND THIS COMMITTEE. I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU. IS THAT ONCE
AND FOR ALL. PROPOSING AND-
INSURING THE REFORMS OF THE
POPULAR TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL
WHICH ABOUT THE COUNT ABILITY
AND- CHANGING THE FEE STRUCTURE.
SO WE- HUNDREDS OF HOURS LIKE
MISTAKE HOLDERS- AND YOU'LL
COMMITTEE STOP AND OTHERS TO.
GET TO THAT PLACE WHERE WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT
COULD MOVE FORWARD. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO SECURE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
VIOLATIONS SCORING PROCEDURE-
WHICH WILL ALSO STRENGTHENED
TIMING PROTECTIVENESS TIME AS
LEGAL DEFENSE ABILITY IN
ENFORCEMENT. AND IT PROVIDES-
THAT FOUNDATION FOR FORTHCOMING
ACTIONS TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
WHO LIVE THERE HAVE THIS WAY
FACILITIES. AND AVAILABLE TO
HARM FROM MULTIPLE
ENVIRONMENTAL BATONS BILLS HAVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THIS
BUDGET RELATING TO DGSE. TO
PROVIDE CONSISTENCY BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS- AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE MAINTAINS
WHICH IS PRETTY CRITICAL.
POLITICIANS AND U. S. EPA DID
MINISTER I REGRET THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION AND RECOVERY ACT
THE CALIFORNIA- THAT THAT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING IT. IS KIND OF
CLASS THAT. THE CRITICAL THING
THAT WE NEED TO DO. AND FINALLY
AS IT RELATES TO DGFT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. OVER TWO
YEARS THAT COMBINED WITH THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JAN TEN BUDGET. BUT
FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. TO HELP ACCELERATE
CLEANUP OF CONTAMINATED
PROPERTIES IMPACTED.
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE TIME I
WILL WANTED TO TIE. THAT TO THE-
FORMAL PASSAGE THE TO THE OF ON
DUTY. RECALL OF THE SITE AND
TRANSPARENT. AND THEN FINALLY
THIS CAT OF CLEANING UP-
COMMUNITY. PAUL XII- WHICH IS
THAT I MADE TOPIC OF THE OAK
COMMITTEE AND YOUR- COMMITTEE-
MA'AM AT FOR NUMEROUS YEARS
THAT MAYOR. PROPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED NINETY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS THE GENERAL
FUND OVER THREE YEARS. THE
CLEAN UP ADDITIONAL PROPERTIES-
AND THAT- ADDITION OF THAT IS
THAT BUILDS UPON TO JUST TO SAY
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE CHANGE.
THAT FREDDIE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION- IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND THAT WAS IN JANUARY THAT
WENT FROM THIRTY ONE POINT FOUR
TWO TWO HUNDRED NINETY ONE
MILLION AND TODAY. WE SPENT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE MILLION
FOR RESIDENTIAL CLEAN UP AND
OTHER ASSOCIATED COSTS EXCITED.
AND THE MAY REVISION ALSO
CONTAINS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION THE CONTINUE
CLEANUP AT THE FORMER EXCITED
FACILITY ITSELF. WHICH RESULTED
FROM A FLAGRANT MANIPULATION OF
BANKRUPTCY LAWS. THAT THE STATE
IS STILL CHALLENGING. THE
EXCITED AT THE AMOUNT OF MY
THAT WE PAY TO SPEND- I THINK
IS REALLY AN EXAMPLE OF WHY WE
NEED TO REFORM AT THE YES THE-
WHY WE NEED TO- THE INCREASE
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
ALL. CHECKED BAGS DO NOT EVER
HAPPEN AGAIN GET OUT STATE. I'M
AND THEN BRINGING OUT THE CLOSE
AS YOU TEED UP AT THE BEGINNING
CHAD. I'M REALLY WANTS TO BEGIN
SEARCHES FOR CONTINUE TO FOSTER
INNOVATION- AND THINK ABOUT
WAYS OF LOOKING AT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND SOLUTIONS TO
FACE BAYERN MENTAL CHALLENGES
FRONT. FACE OF PEPPA FIVE
PRACTICES TO EMIGRATE- PLASTIC
PROBLEMS IN OUR- IN OUR LIVES
SAYS SECTOR KANEMI- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON- AS HAVE. YOU AND WE
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COLLIDE TO
PROCESS RECYCLABLES. AND
MANUFACTURED PRODUCTS ARE
RECYCLABLE. MATERIALS INSTEAD
OF SHIPPING. ELIZABETH THE- IN
ADDITION THAT COMPOSTING AND
CREW CAB CROWD THIS WOULD
INCLUDE FIFTY FIVE MILLION IN
GRANTS TO NEW COMPOSTING AND
ORGANIC WASTE FACILITIES- THAT
CAN GREATLY REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS FROM LANDFILL.
FIFTEEN TO PROVIDE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT GRASS RECYCLING
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND FIFTY MILLION TO PROVIDE
LOW INTEREST LOANS TO ATTRACT
RECYCLING AND RE USE THAT THE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
FINALLY. THE FIGHT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET WE
PROPOSED REVISIONS LET ME ALL
CANADIANS HAD. TO PESTICIDES
MILLS C. A. DEFECTING HIGHER
FEES ON MORE TALK THE
PETRIFIED. TO ACCELERATE THE
TRANSITION TOWARD SAFER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE AND PRACTICES-
THIS IS A VERY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP. WITH SECRETARY
ROSS- AND WANT TO THANK HER FOR
HER LEADERSHIP AND INDEX- THOSE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE FUNDING
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESEARCH AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. RESET TRANSFER
DEVELOP DEVELOPING SAFER
ALTERNATIVES AND STRENGTHENING
ENFORCEMENT MONITORING AND CAN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT TO PRODUCE
BETTER HELP AN ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES. MAY REVISE PROPOSES
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR THE TOP AND THAT PESTICIDE
REGULATION. TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY PESTICIDE
NOTIFICATION THAT AT WHAT THE
NETWORK WILL PROVIDE PESTICIDE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES WITH
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. ABOUT LOCAL
HAZARDS PESTICIDE APPLICATION.
AND WILL ENABLE THEM TO TAKE
STEPS TO PROTECT AGAINST
POTENTIAL PESTICIDE EXPOSURES.
FOR STATEWIDE NOTIFICATION THAT
WHAT WILL PROVIDE A CONSISTENT
SINGLE SYSTEM TO GROW AS FAR
BACK AS AN COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
TO SUBMIT AND TRACK LOCAL
APPLICATION. IN SOME RAISES
BUDGET WILL FUND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY
BUILDING COMPUTERS AND
COMMUNITIES. OF THE MAGNITUDE
NOT SEEN IN GENERATIONS
EXHILARATING FUNDING WILL HELP
US ACCELERATE THOSE THEIR
AMBITIONS. AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF ACTIONS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
CLEAN A LAND AIR AND WATER ALL
WHILE BUILDING CLIMATE JUSTICE
AND RESILIENCY. I'M AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE. MAY HAVE AND WE
HAVE A WHOLE HOST OF GREAT
FOLKS- FROM THE BOARDS OF POP
AND ALL THAT IS. ALL READY STOP
THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SHOULD
YOU HAVE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- THANKS FOR THE
PRESENTATION- CONTINUING ON
WITH OUR GENDER LET'S. MOVE TO
SECRETARY CROWFOOT WITH THE- HI
NATURI. AGENTS AND ALL THE
SENTRY DEPART. UNDERNEATH THAT
WERE PICKED UP ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE BEYOND IN OUR-
AGENDA. WE GOT A LOT IN HERE
SAID GO AHEAD. YEAH I THINK SO
MUCH SURE BECAUSE THE MEMBERS
OF THE- HAVE A DAUNTING TASK
AND THAT IS OF COURSE DICKENS
THIS RANGE OF INVESTMENTS THAT
WERE PROPOSING. SO I'LL DO MY
BEST TO FOLLOW YOUR LEAD AND
CONNECT THE DOTS ARE IN A FEW
OF OUR KEY PRIORITY AREAS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS BUILDING
OUR CLIMATE RESILIENCE. WE'VE
TALKED A LOT OF THIS HEARING
ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS WE
PROPOSE TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
LEADING THE WORLD BUILDING OUR
ECONOMY AND MOVING TOWARD
CARBON NEUTRALITY. AND THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AT THE
SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT CLIMATE
RESILIENCE CRIME AN ADAPTATION
IS NO LONGER A FUTURE PLANNING
EXERCISE IT'S A MATTER OF
PROTECTING OUR RESIDENTS AND
OUR NATURAL PLACES RIGHT NOW.
ARE WE KNOW THAT CLIMATE DRIVEN
THREATS ARE GETTING MORE
DESTRUCTIVE. THE LAST WILDFIRE
SEASON PROVED AT THE RECORD
BREAKING TEMPERATURES LAST
SUMMER APPROVED AT. THAT
PERNICIOUS DROUGHT WE'RE NOW IN
THE- I EXPERIENCING PROVES
THAT. AND SO- WHILE THESE ARE
BIG SUMS OF MONEY I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY AND MAKE THE MAKE
THE INVESTMENT THAT WE NEED TO.
ACT TO PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS
FROM THESE CLIMATE DRIVEN
THREATS SO I'LL OUTLINE OUR
INVESTMENT IN FIVE TO. FIVE
SPECIFIC THREATS THAT ARE THAT
ARE WORSENED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
WILDFIRE DROUGHT FLOODING
EXTREME HEAT AND SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND THEN I'LL TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF OTHER CRITICAL
PRIORITIES OF OUR OF OUR
AGENCY. SO ON WILDFIRE HUGE
THANKS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ARE
SPEARHEADING THE MOVE TO
ALLOCATE OR APPROPRIATE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
EARLY ACION. THAT I IS GETTING
MONEY INTO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE TO BUILD OUR WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. I'VE TALKED AT THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RESPONSE- CAL PRIOR I'M REALLY
PROUD TO BE PART OF AN AGENCY
THAT INCLUDES CAL FIRE- I
CONSIDER THEM THE WORLD'S
LARGEST AND MOST SOPHISTICATED
WILDLAND FIREFIGHTING FORCE.
AND THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP
WE'RE GONNA HELP THEM ARE EVEN
STRENGTHEN THEIR CAPACITY TO
RESPOND BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA
RESPOND OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
CHALLENGE- WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
AUGMENT THAT. WITH SIGNIFICANT
SCALED INVESTMENTS UP FRONT I
IN ADVANCE OF WILDFIRES TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF THESE
WILDFIRES THAT ARE INEVITABLE
IN OUR STATE FROM BECOMING
CATASTROPHIC WHICH THEY BECOME.
I'M MINDFUL THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE GROUND IN
L. A. COUNTY ARE STILL FIGHTING
THE PALISADES OF FIRE AND THAT
THIS IS ALARMING JUST GIVEN
THAT SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES SO
EARLY AND- IN THE YEAR- SO LET
ME JUST IDENTIFIED THAT IN THE
MAY REVISION. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES INCREASE FUNDING
FOR WILDFIRE SAFETY I TO THE
TUNE OF UP UP AN ADDITIONAL
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT INCLUDES
THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS THE
STAFF BOTH CURRENT AND THREE
ADDITIONAL FIRE CREWS FOR A
TOTAL OF THIRTEEN FIRE CREWS
UNTIL THE END OF THE YEAR
FOCUSED ON RESPONSE. FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
CONTINUE THE PHASE IN OF THE
TWELVE NEW CAL FIRE HAWK
HELICOPTERS AND THE SEVEN AIR
TANKERS. THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ACCELERATE BASEMENT
TO CAL FIRE HELICOPTER BASES
AND IMPORTANTLY TO ESTABLISH.
AN EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. LED BY
OUR OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. NINE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BUILD THE WILD HIGH WILDFIRE
FORECAST AND THREAT
INTELLIGENCE CENTER THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO BE A CAN TO THE
NATIONAL HURRICANE CENTER. AND
IS A JOINT PROJECT OF
CALIFORNIA- INFO WE ASKED TO
BRING THE BAST SCIENCE. AND
TECHNOLOGY TOGETHER. TO PROTECT
OUR CALIFORNIANS ARE FROM THE
GROWING WILDFIRE REST.
CRITICALLY THE ESTIMATE
REVISION ALSO PROPOSED TO
INVEST SEVENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA- AND- WE
ASK AND THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT. WHILE WE'VE
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO
CALIFORNIA IN RECENT YEARS OFF
FOR OUR BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND
DIRECT FIREFIGHTING SERVICES
ARE ARE ADMINISTRATIVE BACKBONE
HASN'T KEPT UP. AND WE HAVE
UNIFORMED FIREFIGHTERS I CAN BE
OUT- FIGHTING FIRES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY IN ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS AND WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN THE
BACKBONE TO ENABLE HOW FAR TO
DO ITS JOB MORE EFFECTIVELY SO
THAT'S SOMETHING I'M REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT. AND THEN
LASTLY A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
RESEARCH GRANT FOR EQUIPMENT
AND STRATEGIES TO PROTECT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS FROM DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PRESENT
DURING WILDFIRES. THAT'S A REAL
THAT'S A REAL PRIORITY FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN ON THE FRONT
LINES. AND THIS ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL- THAT
THE GOVERNOR NOW MAKES TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT INCLUDES MAY
REVISED AS PART OF A LARGER TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
DISASTER RESILIENCE PACKAGE.
I'LL MENTION BECAUSE IT WAS
ADDRESSED AND- MISS PETERSON'S
PRESENTATION FOR THE CPUC- THE
WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION THAT
HAS BEEN IN THE CPUC IS WHERE
PROPOSING TO MOVE IT TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. TO
FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE DIRECTIVE
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ELEVEN
SIGN IN THE LINE TWENTY
NINETEEN. I WHICH CALLED FOR
THE SET UP OF THE WILDFIRE
SAFETY DIVISION AND ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS AT THE C. P. U.
C. AND ITS TRANSFER. TO THE
RESOURCES AGENCY- THAT'S BEEN A
REALLY GOOD I'VE TRANSITION
PLANNING I EXPERIENCE WE'VE GOT
GREAT LEADERSHIP. IN THE NEW
DIVISION AND WE ARE STE WE ARE
PROPOSING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
IN PART BECAUSE THE NEW
DIVISION IS ADDING DIRECT
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. IT'S
BEATING UP ITS LEGAL TEAM I AND
IT'S POSITIONING ITSELF WITH
THE SUPPORT FUNCTIONS IT NEEDS
AS A PERMANENT DIVISION WITHIN
THE AGENCY. THAT'S WILD FIRE
LET'S MOVE TO DROUGHT AND WATER
RESILIENCE DROUGHT FLOOD WATER
RESILIENCE- I MENTIONED THAT WE
YOU KNOW ARE NOW FACING THESE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THE GOVERNOR
HAS AN EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION
ACROSS FORTY ONE COUNTIES. IN
THE STATE. WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT THAT WE NEED TO DO RIGHT
NOW TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE THE ENVIRONMENT
AGRICULTURE FROM THE IMPACTS OF
DROUGHT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP OUR EY ON THE
PRIZE AND CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
BUILDING. DROUGHT RESILIENCE
ACROSS OUR STATE. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S- A REVISION FIVE
FIVE BUILDS ON THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL AND NOW PROPOSES FIVE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IN
DROUGHT ACTIONS AND WATER
RESILIENCE WITH A FOCUS ON
PARTNERING WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND REGIONS. TO
BUILD REGIONAL RESILIENCE.
ABOUT ALMOST A BILLION IN NINE
HUNDRED NINE BILLION DOLLARS OF
THE PACKAGE IS FOCUSED ON
DIRECT DROUGHT SUPPORT.
INCLUDING EMERGENCY WATER
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
MAY FIND THEMSELVES WITHOUT
THOSE SUPPLIES. SHOVEL READY MY
FUNDING FOR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS IN SMALL VULNERABLE
SYSTEMS ARE BEFORE THEY LOSE
WATER SUPPLIES. IMPROVED REAL
TIME ENVIRONMENTAL MONITORING-
SO THAT OUR DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE CAN SAVE THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE- FROM THE IMPACTS OF
THE DROUGHT. THE ADDITIONAL
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IS FOCUSED
ON MAKING QUICK ACTION TO
DIVERSIFY OUR WATER SUPPLIES
ACROSS THE STATE. ENABLE THAT
GROUNDWATER USE WHICH IS A
CRITICAL A SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
THAT ALLOWS RURAL COMMUNITIES
TO GET THROUGH DROUGHT. AND AS
SECRETARY BUMENFELD MENTIONED-
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING ON DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER
GROUNDWATER CLEAN UP RECYCLING.
THE REALLY INNOVATVE PROPOSALS
INCLUDING A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR
VOLUNTARY LAND RE PURPOSING
FIVE FOR COMMUNITIES AS THE
IMPLEMENT STATE MY IDENTIFYING
THAT DAY THERE COULD BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SHIP LAND USED
AS PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR THAT-
CALM FOCUSED EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
pCONTINUING TO SHORE UP OUR
FLOOD PROTECTION A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THERE
WHICH IS KIND OF. LEVERAGE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING.
CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON THE
SALTON SEA WITH A PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THERE. AND THEN ALMOST THREE
QUARTERS OF A BILLION DOLLARS
ARE FOCUSED ON OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT- I THINK IF WE LOOK
AT THE LAST DROUGHT WE KNOW
THAT MAJOR IMPACTS WERE FELT BY
OUR SMALL RURAL **** BUILT I
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. BY
OUR AGRICULTURE SECTOR AND
CERTAINLY BY OUR FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND OUR ENVIRONMENT SO
OUR OUR DROUGHT ACTIONS NOT
ONLY BUILD ON ALL OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED THE LAST
DROUGHT BUT ARE REALLY FOCUSED
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING HERE. I WOULD SAY
THAT THEM THAT THAT IF WE GET
THIS FINDING OUT- THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS NOT ONLY THE
DROUGHT ACTIONS BUT THE BROADER
WATER RESILIENCE ARE AGENCIES
COMMITMENT IS TO CUT. THE RED
TAPE TO GET THESE PROJECTS ON
THE GROUND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE TALKED WILDFIRE
DROUGHT. FLOODING KNOWLEDGE
TALK EXTREME HEAT. CALIFORNIA
RECORD TIME. OVER A HUNDRED
TWENTY DEGREES IN GREATER LOS
ANGELES LAST SUMMER. WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO DO MORE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AGAINST
WORSENING EXTREME HEAT. OUR
AGENCY IS PARTNERING WITH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
THIS YEAR TO UPDATE OUR
CALIFORNIA ADAPTATION PLAN AS
MANDATED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THAT WILL BE A FRAMEWORK THAT
REALLY TIES ALL OF THESE
SECTORAL EFFORTS TOGETHER
BETWEEN WILDFIRE DROUGHT IT
CETERA. THAT WILL INCLUDE A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY ON
EXTREME HEAT FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE THAT REALLY HASN'T BEEN
DEVELOPED I LIKE IN THE WILD
FIRE OR WATER SECTOR. BUT THERE
ARE INVESTMENTS WE KNOW WE CAN
MAKE NOW EVEN AS WE FORM THAT
THAT STRATEGY FOR OUR BROAD
CONSIDERATION INCLUDING TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
INVESTMENT IN URBAN GREENING WE
HAVE AN EXISTING URBAN GREENING
GRANTS PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
LOCAL. VISIT VANTAGE
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFER FROM
EXTREME HEAT TO CREATE AND
EXTEND THEIR TREE CANOPY TO
CREATE GREEN SPACE SAYS POCKET
PARKS. WE PROPOSE A HUNDRED
MILLION INTO THE COOL BUILDING
PROGRAM TO AUGMENT I HAD A
PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO. SUPPORT
PROJECTS IN LOW INCOME HOUSING
AND MULTI UNIT HOUSING TO COOL
THOSE BUILDINGS AND IMPROVE
THEIR ENERGY EFFICIENCY SO
PEOPLE LIVING THERE CAN
ACTUALLY SUSTAIN THEMSELVES
THROUGH THESE THESE INTENSE
HEAT HOT PERIODS. ADDITIONALLY
NOT ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM FOR
SOMETHING SIMILAR. LOCUST ON I
ENABLING THESE ARE LOW INCOME
UNITS TO REMAIN- SAFE PLACES TO
LIVE DURING THESE HEAT
EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCE AS- AND
ALLOW CITIZENS MARIN SECRETARY
ROSS'S- AGENCY BUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A SHE
MENTIONED. TO CDFA FOR
FAIRGROUNDS TO REALLY POSITION
FAIRGROUND AS RESILIENT
CENTERS- TO BE PLACES OF REFUGE
DURING THESE CLIMATE DRIVEN
CHALLENGES INCLUDING EXTREME
HEAT. THE LASTLY ON ON
RESILIENCE WHEN HE MOVED TO SEA
LEVEL RISE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FOCUS AND ENERGY AND
PROGRESS ACTUALLY ALIGNING
STATE AGENCIES WORK ON SEA
LEVEL RISE AND THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO DO. WITH THE AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE KNOW THERE ARE
INVESTMENTS WE CAN MAKE NOW
THAT WILL MITIGATE SEA LEVEL
RISE AND COASTAL EROSION. SO
WE'RE PROPOSING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
INTO COASTAL WETLAND
RESTORATION THIS IS REALLY ACT
NEED THESE WETLANDS NOT ONLY
BENEFIT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO COASTAL
COMMUNITIES BUT THEY SERVICE
SPONGES THAT SOAK UP THE STORM
SURGES- OFF THE COAST. AND THEN
EXCITED TO PROPOSE ELEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
TO IMPLEMENT STATE PARKS ON NEW
C. LEVEL RISE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY. OUR STATE PARKS ARE
COMPRISES OR ITS JURISDICTION
ALMOST OVER ALMOST A THIRD OF
OUR COAST HI AND IT SHOULD BE
ADVANCING A PROACTIVE EFFORT TO
PROTECT THE PARKS IN THE
COMMUNITIES ADJACENT TO THE
PARK'S FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
NEST. WOULD FIND THAT. SO TOLD
THOSE THOSE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS DEPENDING ON HOW
YOU CUT THEM- ARE WELL OVER
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. COMPARE
THAT TO THE INVESTMENTS IN
JANUARY AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OF ABOUT TWO BILLION. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS OUR
GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THIS DOWN PAYMENT IN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NATURAL PLACES FROM WHAT WE
KNOW IS. IS HERE AND GETTING
WORSE ALL OF THESE CLIMATE
DRIVEN THREATS. TWO MORE
PRIORITIES I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE IS INVESTMENTS INTO OUR
STATE PARK SYSTEM AND OUR FOCUS
ON EXPANDING RECREATIONAL
ACCESS WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
EQUITABLE RECREATIONAL ACCESS
INTO OUR STATE PARKS AND OPEN
SPACES- SIX OUT OF TEN
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN PARK POOR
COMMUNITIES MEANING- THEY ARE
GENERALLY DEVOID OF PLACES TO
BE OUTDOORS IN NATURE- FOUR OUT
OF TEN CALIFORNIANS HAVE NO
ACCESS TO. ANY OPEN SPACE
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE. WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE
THIS WELL WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THIS THE STATE PARK SYSTEM
WHICH IS THE BIGGEST IN THE
COUNTRY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY.
UNITS WITHIN OUR STATE PARKS WE
KNOW THAT THAT ACCESS IS
ENJOYED IN IN AN EQUITABLE WAY
MEANING SOME OF US CAN ACTUALLY
GO FAIRLY EASILY OTHERS CAN'T.
AND SO WE ALSO KNOW THAT COLD
ED ARE DEMONSTRATE HOW
IMPORTANT THESE OUTDOOR SPACES
ARE ARE FOR US BUT ALSO
THEY WERE CONTEMPLATING THEIR-
PERSISTING THROUGH THE STAY AT
HOME ORDER AND ALL THE
CHALLENGES WE HAD. I DIDN'T
HAVE PLACES TO BE OUTSIDE AND
COULDN'T ACCESS THESE PLACES.
SO WE PROPOSE A BILLION DOLLARS
IN OUR STATE PARK SYSTEM AND
EQUITABLE ACCESS. ARE FULLY
OVER THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO STATE PARKS
OR WILDLIFE OR I SHOULD SAY
WILDFIRE RESTORATION PROJECTS
RIGHT NOW FIVE OF OUR STATE
PARKS ARE FULLY CLOSED AS A
RESULT OF WILDFIRE IMPACTS AND
ANOTHER NINE ARE PARTIALLY
CLOSED. THIS IS GONNA HELP
THOSE PARKS ABI RESTORED AND
REOPENED AND THEN SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING INTO OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ACROSS OUR PARKS
WHICH IS CRITICAL AND THAT'S
EVERYTHING FROM RESTROOMS TO
PARKING LAST A TRAIL HEADS. ARE
THE. PLACES WHERE- WE CAMP. SO
NOT ONLY STATE PARKS IS THE
FOCUS OF THIS INVESTMENT BUT-
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO AN EXISTING PROP
SIXTY EIGHT GRANT PROGRAM- SO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN APPLY TO
DEVELOP- PARKS AND REFERRED
BURBAGE PARKS IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES- A HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. IN FOCUSED
ON ACCESS PROGRAMMING.
EXPANDING AN EXISTING VERY
POPULAR PROGRAM CALLED THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM.
I EXPANDING THE EXPLORE THE
COAST GRANT PROGRAMS. AND
PROVIDING ONE TIME STATE PARK
MONEY TO POSITION STATE PARKS
TO WORK MORE CLOSELY WITH OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEMS. TO BE
SORT OF PLUG AND PLAY FIELD
TRIP LOCATIONS ARE FOR STUDENTS
FROM OUR OUR OUR URBAN- AND-
AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS I DON'T
TYPICALLY HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
STATE PARKS. ALSO VERY EXCITED
NOT A LOT OF MONEY BUT FOCUSED
NINE MILLION DOLLARS ON. HI I'M
EXPLORING AND LAUNCHING SOME
INNOVATIVE PILOTS TO GET MORE
KIDS AND FAMILIES IN THE PARKS
THAT DON'T NORMALLY GET THEIR-
INCLUDING A ADVENTURE PASSED
OFF FOR FOURTH GRADERS- THAT WE
WOULD PILOT IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE TATE. TO SEE IF I COULD
HELP GET- IN IMPROVE OUR
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE PARKS.
LAST PRIORITY ALL IDENTIFY IS
OUR LAND AND BIODIVERSITY
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION. SO
AT HEART OUR AGENCY STEWARDS
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AND THAT
OF COURSE INCLUDES OUR NATURAL
PLACES AND THIS TREMENDOUS
RICHNESS OF PLANTS AND ANIMALS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE. AND
THAT THAT THAT THOSE PLANTS AND
ANIMALS THAT ENVIRONMENT IS
UNDER A RANGE OF STRESSORS
INCLUDING ALL OF THE CLIMATE
DRIVEN DISASTERS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. SO WE HAVE FOCUSED
FUNDING TO SAFEGUARD OUR OUR
PLANTS AND ANIMALS ARE RESTORE
OUR HABITATS CREATE MORE
HEALTHY SYSTEMS- SO LAST SUMMER
PLANTS AND ANIMALS FIND
THEMSELVES IMPERILLED OR OR
ALTERNATELY THAT GET LISTED AS
ENDANGERED. OUR FOCUS WITH
THESE INVESTMENT IS MULTI
MULTIPLE BENEFITS SO NOT ONLY
IS ARE THEY SMART SMART
INVESTMENTS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION BUT THEY CAN ALSO-
IMPROVE RECREATIONAL ACCESS.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE TO
RECORD IN THE OUTDOORS LIKE
FISHING AND HUNTING- AND THEN
ALSO TOSSED MARC LAND
MANAGEMENT FOR CLIMATE PURPOSES
BUILDING OUR RESILIENCE AND
REMOVING CARBON FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. SO WE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A WILDLIFE CORRIDOR AND
FISH PASSAGE PROJECTS- GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES THAT A LOT OF
OUR FISH AND OTHER ANIMALS
HAVE. TO MIGRATE- ACROSS- THEIR
LIFE CYCLES I AM REMOVING
BARRIERS- AND CONSTRUCTING
WILDLIFE FRIENDLY HIGHWAY
CROSSINGS EVERYTHING FROM LARGE
ANIMALS BIG GAME TOO FAST. AND
THEN TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HABITAT RESTORATION
THE SUPPORT WETLANDS
FLOODPLAINS MULTI BENEFIT FLOOD
REDUCTION PROJECTS. AGAIN WITH
THAT MULTIPLE BENEFIT FOCUS.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THAT THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES TARGETED
FUNDING TO OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. YOU ALL KNOW
THAT A SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
PROCESS OCCURRED OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS TO MEASURE THAT'S
THE DEPARTMENT'S RESOURCES
VERSES THAT STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. AND WHAT WE FIND
IS A MAJOR GAP BETWEEN THE
RESOURCES THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
HOUSE TO DO ITS JOB. AND WHAT
WE ASK IS THAT- NOW THIS FIVE
PROPOSED BUDGET DOESN'T PROVIDE
THE BEST SOLUTION BUT IT
PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT BRIDGING
SOLUTION WHICH IS EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. TO ACTUALLY ENABLE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE HIGHER IN CRITICAL
POSITIONS INCLUDING TO PROTECT
ENDANGERED SPECIES MANAGES
ECOLOGICAL PRESERVES AND OTHER
PLACES TO LIAISE WITH ACTIVE
RECREATIONAL LAST LIKE FISHING
AND HUNTING- ARE THOSE WHO WORK
RECREATION AT THAT WAY. AND
IMPORTANTLY TO DO SOMETHING I
CALL UTTING THE GREEN TAPE
WHICH IS TRYING TO GET- BREAK
DOWN THE BARRIERS THE
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES TO GETTING
THE GETTING MORE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION DONE MORE QUICKLY
AND COST EFFECTIVELY. ALL TOLD
OUR PROPOSED BUDGET. BETWEEN
DROUGHT INVESTMENTS
CONSERVATION DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WILDLIFE WENT OUT
OVER TWO HUNDRED POSITIONS AND
OVER I THINK AROUND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
FUNDING TO THE DEPARTMENT GIVEN
THAT MUCH NEEDED. MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING INFUSION. SO CHAIR
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE LISTENING TO ALL OF US
AND OF COURSE GLAD TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS
YOU HAVE. THAT WE WANT TO GIVE
YOU GUYS A CHANCE TO PRESENT AT
THERE'S A GOOD TO GO TO THE
BROWNS YEAH OVER AT THE LA YOU
KNOW. YOU GOT A WATER
RESILIENCY AND DROUGHT PACKAGE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE A
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
PACKAGE AND A WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCY EXPENDITURE
PLAN UNLESS YOU'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY OR
CALIFORNIA OUTDOORS FOR ALL
INITIATIVE SELF SLOT IN. THERE
ARE PLEASE. GIVE US YOUR RESP-
YOUR THOUGHTS. RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN
BROWN THE L. A. O. I THINK I AT
THE AS YOU SAID THERE IS QUITE
A BIT THERE I COMMITTEE STAFF
OF ASSET THAT AYBE I START OFF
WHICH IS SOME HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS ON THE OVERALL
ARCHITECTURE OF THE GOVERNORS
MAY REVISION AND THEN I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WHO HAVE BEEN
DIGGING INTO THE INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSAL AND CAN ADDRESS
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WANT TO- IT
GOING TO EACH OF THOSE. OVER
THE COMING MINUTE- I DO WANT TO
PREFACE MY REMARKS IN THOSE IN
MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN OKAY WE'VE
ONLY HAD THESE PROPOSALS FOR A
COUPLE OF DAYS AND SO WE'RE
STILL WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GET MORE
INFORMATION IN MANY CASES AND-
WILL BE CONTINUING TO SHARE OUR
OUR THOUGHTS- OVER THE COMING
WEEKS OF IT. BY THE CANADIAN
THE LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP ITS
FINAL BUDGET PLAN- MAYBE TO
START IT I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL JUST TO STEP BACK THE
SECRETARY'S VERY ABLY WENT
THROUGH THE MYRIAD OF PROPOSALS
THAT ARE IN THE MAY REVISION-
BUT FOR A LITTLE BIT OF A
BROADER CONTEXT I KNOW THAT IN
AGGREGATE THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDE VERY LARGE SPENDING
INCREASES. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
SO IN FACT IF YOU LOOK IN YOUR
AGENDA YOU'LL SEE THAT- FOR
EXAMPLE ON PAGE FIVE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE SUMMARY OF THE CDFA
IS BUDGET THERE IT PROPOSED
INCREASES OF MORE THAN HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS- JUST FOR CFA
RELATIVE TO THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. SIMPLY IF YOU
MOVED TO PAY FOURTEEN OF YOUR
AGENDA YOU'LL SEE THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
DEPARTMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING NOW EIGHT POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THIS IS MORE THAN FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS GREATER THAN
WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN JANUARY
THAT'S A 90% INCREASE RELATIVE
TO JANUARY AND THEN SIMILARLY
FOR THE NATURAL RESOURCE
DEPARTMENTS. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING ANIME REVISION AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OR 61% MORE THAN WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN JANUARY. CITY YOU
CAN SEE IS. QUITE QUITE A LARGE.
IN OR- TO- TO. AND SO WHERE DO
THOSE RUN. WHERE THAT WHERE
COMING. I'M REALLY FROM TWO
SOURCES ONE IS. THERE IS THE
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FISCAL RELIEF FUND. AND
THE GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION
INCLUDES OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
WATER BOARD- AND- WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER. FOR WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS DEBT
RELIEF ON WATER UTILITY BILLS.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE
A VERY LARGE GENERAL FUND
REVENUE INCREASES AND OUR
OFFICE HAS. IDENTIFIED AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND SURPLUS
RELATIVE. TO WHAT WAS ASSUMED
IN JANUARY SO. THERE'S THE
REVENUES OF COURSE IN PROVIDE A
REALLY. UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ADDRESS MANY OF YOUR
PRIORITIES. NOT JUST IN
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION IN AGRICULTURE BUT-
ACROSS THE BUDGET. AND SO-
WHILE LOOKING AT THESE-
PROPOSAL THAT I THINK IMPORTANT
KNOW THAT MANY OF THEM DO A
LINE WITH SOME OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS DISCUSSED IN RECENT WEEKS
WHETHER THAT'S WITH. RESPECT
TO- CLIMATE ADAPTATION. OUR
SUSTAINABLE. THERE A LOT OF
PARALLELS TO WHAT THE
COMMITTEES THE DISCUSSION IN
THE RECENT WEEKS AND SO AGAIN
THIS DOES THESE REVENUE TO
PROVIDE. A SUBSTANTIAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU. I THINK
THAT'S THE SORT OF THE
POSITIVE- I DO I DO WHEN IT
TURNS JIM THIS IS BEEN ALLUDED
TO I THINK IN A COUPLE OF YOUR
COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR AND
OTHERS AS WELL. IS THAT IT IS
NOT ONLY JUST A LOT OF FUNDING
BUT- IT'S A LOT OF PROPOSALS-
IF YOU CAN TELL JUST BY THE
LENGTH OF YOUR AGENDA THERE IS
QUITE A BIT HERE FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER AND- WHAT IS REALLY A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME- IT'S
NOT YOUR TYPICAL. NAY REVISION
WHERE WE ARE ACTIVELY LOOKING
AT- JUST MODEST ADJUSTMENTS
BASED ON CASE LOW DIDN'T AND-
MODEST REVENUE AS ADJUSTMENT.
REALLY WHAT WE HAVE ARE A LOT
OF PROPOSAL OVER ONE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT PROPOSAL THAT YOU
TAKE APART THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS FOR EXAMPLE OF ALL
THE PACKAGES THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF YOU- AND YOU DO HAVE THE
PACKAGES. MANY OF THEM ARE BIG-
YOU YOU YOU FOR COMPARISON- YOU
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
EARLIER THIS YEAR DISCUSSING
THE WILDFIRE PACKAGE WHICH WAS
A ONE BILLION DOLLAR. PACKAGE
RIGHT NOW OVER THE WITH THEM. A
YOU. A FOUR BILLION WATER
PACKAGE OF THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND PACKAGE OF BILLION
DOLLAR CLIMATE PACKAGE ANOTHER.
BILLION DOLLARS FOR ENERGY AND
OTHERS AS WELL AND SO THERE'S
JUST A QUITE A BIT HERE QUITE A
BIT OF IT. IS ALSO NEW- AS MY
COLLEAGUE ROSS BROWN MENTIONED
EARLIER JUST WITH RESPECT TO
THE- ENERGY PACKAGE IN
PARTICULAR. THEY'RE A LOT OF
NEW PROGRAMS AND THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE- WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE PROPOSAL
THE OTHER ONES WHAT WE DON'T
HAVE A HISTORY OF IMPLEMENTING
THIS PROGRAM. AND THERE'S NOT
EXISTING STATUTORY GUIDANCE AND
SO THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
IMPORTANT POLIY DECISIONS
COULD BE MADE WITH RESPECT TO
THESE PROPOSAL SO. IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING TO PROVIDE AND WHETHER
THAT MEET YOUR- OVERALL BUDGET.
PRIORITIES BUT THERE ARE
IMPORTANT DECISION TO BE MADE
ABOUT WHAT THE MEASURABLE
OBJECTIVES OF THE PROGRAM NOT
TO BE. A HOW THEY SHOULD BE
STRUCTURED. HOW FUNDING WILL BE
ALLOCATED OR PRIORITIZE WHAT
CRITERIA WILL BE USED FOR
GRANTS. AND HOW ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL BE INSURED. I IN AB TO
THAT WELL THERE IN MANY CASES.
A LOT OF THE PROPOSAL DON'T
REALLY HAVE WHAT WE WOULD
DESCRIBE SUFFICIENT DETAIL-
SOME OF THE PACKAGES FOR
EXAMPLE THE- NARRATIVE THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDE JUST ONE
OR TWO PARAGRAPHS. ON WHAT
COULD BE SUBSTANTIAL PROPOSAL
OF TENS OR HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. AND SO. THE STAGE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IS WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION WE'VE-
HAD. ONGOING DIALOGUES ARE
SENDING QUESTIONS TO THEM
ASKING FOR MORE INFORMATION
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH US AND SO WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GATHER MORE
INFORMATION. AND WILL CONTINUE
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE IS THAT- AS WE LEARN
MORE. I'M NOW ALL THESE
CHALLENGES YOU KNOW THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE FUNDING UNDER
CONSIDERATION AND THE NUMBER
FOR POE'S SOULS. THE NEW
POLICIES ALL THIS S ALSO
COMPOUNDED AS I NOTED ALREADY
BY THE SHORT TIME THAT YOU
HAVE. TO MEET A JUNE FIFTEENTH
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE. IS
THAT WE DO AN OFFER- AND JUST A
COUPLE OF OPTIONS FOR YOU. TO
CONSIDER AND YOU DECIDE HOW YOU
WANT APPROACH THE BIG COMPLEX
PACKAGES THE NEW PROPOSALS. THE
ULTIMATE END UP ENSURE THAT YOU
END UP WITH THE BUDGET PACKAGE.
THAT BEST MEETS YOUR PRIORITIES
AND THAT THE- WHATEVER PROGRAMS
ARE FUNDED ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO BE IMPLEMENTED EFFECTIVELY.
AND SO SPECIFICALLY- WHAT WE'VE
LAID OUT. FOR YOU IN SOME OF
OUR DOCUMENTS IS. TO IDENTIFY.
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE. IF THERE
ARE AREAS WHERE YOU PROPOSAL
MAY REFLECT PRIORITIES OF YOURS
BUT WHERE YOU WHERE YOU THINK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE EITHER
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
NEED TO BE PROVIDED. OR
ADDITIONAL HIGH NEED TO BE
SPENT TO DEVELOP IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS. TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT THE COUPLE CHOICES
THAT YOU YOU HAVE. ONE OPTION
IS YOU CAN TO FIRST ACTIONS- IS
NOT BEEN UNCOMMON IN RECENT
YEARS WHEN- THERE BEEN THESE
KIND OF PROPOSALS OF HAPPEN
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN HAS BEEN
ONE EXAMPLE. WHERE WE DEFERRED
ACTION EVEN DEFERRED ACTION
UNTIL THE SUMMER. AND TO GIVE
YOURSELF SOME MORE TIME TO
DEVELOP A PLAN AND ENSURE THAT.
MEMBERS ARE ON- ON THE SAME
PAGE IN TERMS OF WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE SO YOU CAN DO
THAT YOU COULD. IDENTIFY
CERTAIN AREAS THAT YOU ARE OF
IMMEDIATE CAN- CONCERN IN
PRIORITY INCLUDE THOSE IN YOUR
JUNE FIFTEENTH BUDGET. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE- WATER PACKAGE
WE'VE EMPHASIZED THAT WE DO
THINK FUNDING IMMEDIATE DROUGHT
RELIEF. SHE I SHOULD BE A NEAR
TERM PRIORITY BUT ON OTHER ONES
THAT MAYBE ARE NOT AS IMMEDIATE
OF THE NEED YOU HAVE THAT
OPTION TO DEFER SOME ACTIONS
UNTIL. UNTIL THE SUMMER- IN
OTHER CASES IT MAY MAKE SENSE-
MAYBE FOR SOME OF THE NEW
PROGRAMS TO PROVE SOME SMALLER
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN THE NEAR
TERM IN THE BUDGET YEAR- THAT
COULD FIND. INITIAL STAFF A
COMPLAINT. FUND PLANNING
ACTIVITIES. THAT CAN MAYBE.
ALLOW AND A DEMONSTRATION BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING A NEW PROGRAM A
NEW EFFORT. BUT THEN THEY COULD
COME BACK NEXT YEAR IN THE
BUDGET CYCLE. TO REQUEST
SUBSEQUENT FINDING- YOU CAN
ALSO. POTENTIALLY A SOME.
PROPOSALS CONTINGENT SUBSEQUENT
POLICY LEGISLATION IF SOMETHING
THE PRIORITY YOU GTU. YOU WANT
IMPROVE THE FUNDING BUT
ULTIMATELY THINK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL. WE WOULD NOT YOU
ALSO HAVE THE OPTION OF
APPROVING A FUNDING BUT WITH
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS. PRETTY
TYPICALTHAT COULD BE IF IT'S
MEDIA REPORTING IT COULD BE TO
JAIL THE C. FORGET. OR COULD BE
REPORTING IN SUBSEQUENT. THAT
COULD ALLOW YOU TO APPROVED BY
FINDING IT A PRIORITY TO YOU-
BUT ULTIMATELY ENSURE THAT
THERE'S SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
THERE'S REPORTING BACK TO YOU
ON HOW. PROGRAMS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN HALF WHAT
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE- IN
ANOTHER THESE ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE IT COULD BE A
COMBINATION OF ANY OF THESE
DEPENDING ON THE PACKAGE IN THE
PROPOSAL. SO I TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT COULD PRETTY QUICKLY
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU PROBABLY
HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS FOR THE
MINISTRATION OUR STAFF SO I'LL
STOP THERE AGAIN OUR STAFF IS
AVAILABLE. TO ALL OF YOU AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND THEN AS WELL
AS TODAY AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. WHILE
EVERYONE'S FREE MAY BE COMING
TO FRUITION BECAUSE AS HE RAN
OUT OF TIME TO CHEER HAS
LIMITED HAS LESS AND LESS
OPTIONS ASK QUESTIONS. I WANTED
TO GO BACK TO FINANCES. THE US
FINANCED TO WEIGH IN ON SOME
OTHER. REFLECTIONS. WE HAVE.
FROM THE OVERALL PUT. HI GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS SERGIO I
OVER THE BAR TO FIND A SOLDIERS
MAKE UP BRIEF GIVEN THAT THERE
FOR- VARIOUS- INTO FOR BOTH IN
THE MAYOR. SO BE CALM OF THE-
AND FEDERALLY FUND. ARE REALLY
ALLOWING. TO MAKE ONE IN A
LIFETIME INVEST IN THE FEW OF
THE STATE. AND PROVIDES A
HISTORIC UP. TO THE MYSTERY
CLAY INITIAL. WE WENT COME WITH
THE- FROM THE GOVERNORBUDGET.
THE MAYOR VISION FOR OF THE-
OVER FIFTY BILL DOLLARS. IN
ADDITIONAL FIND THAT WOULD. THE
UNDER THE ALLIANCE. REDUCE
CARBON. THE SUSTAIN AGRO.
SUPPORT PARKS ACT AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AND ALSO. TO GROW.
AND MARK. AMONG OTHER
INVESTMENTS. NOW WHILE ACTOR
OUTLOOK AS- REVENUES HAVE
IMPROVED IN. THE SENSE THE
COVER BUDGET. THE SAME BUDGET
RESERVE AL THE STATE GET
THROUGH THAT AND- WILL BE TO
PROTECT PROGRAM IN THE FUTURE.
AND ALSO THE STATE PREPARE
FORMER. ALTHOUGH THE FORECAST
DOES NOT PROJECT AND LARGE
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS. THE RISK
TO THE FOR ME. I AND REST WE
THE TIME OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
AND ONE TIME OF SURPLUS. REALLY
DO CAN. THE A BILL TO SEE. X.
ONGOING COMMIT. SO THIS. AT THE
VERY. I FRONT OF YOU REALLY ARE
ARE SIGNATURE ONE TIME INVEST
THAT ARE NEEDED NOW IN ORDER TO
OUR BANDS ARE ARE CLIMBING AND
ALSO HELP THE STATE. OF ITS
RECOVERY FROM THE PEN- I'LL
LASSIE JUST KNOW THE WE'RE- AS
AN ADMINISTRATION WORKING TO
BILL. TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND
LEGISLATIVE. IS A LOT OF-
PROPOSAL HERE AS OVER TRY TO
PROVIDE MUCH IF AS- AFTER THEIR
HOUSE. THANK YOU SIR. WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE DISCUSSION ONE
OF. OUR I DO Và C BY STERN
ONE OF THINGS MAYBE FOR CONCERN
OFF AND THEN THE SECRETARIES
TAKEN. IF WE LOOK AT EACH
NUMBER FOR DECLINE. RESILIENCE
PACKAGE. AND IT'S SEVEN AND
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE. WE
HAVE A CENTER PROPOSAL FOR OF
UPON OUR BOND SEEMS LIKE A BILL
TIME OPPORTUNITY SINCE WE HAVE
SO MUCH MONEY AND WITH FEDERAL
MONIES AND SURPLUS MONIES. BUT
THAT'S IN THE TUNE OF FIVE
POINT SIX FIVE POINT FIVE
BILLION THEN YOU HAVE THE ADMIN
THE ASSEMBLY WHO'S BEEN WORKING
ON A CLIMATE RESILIENCY PACKAGE
IN THERE. NORTH THE SEVEN POINT
EIGHT I THINK IS WHAT. IT'S UP
TO RIGHT NOW- IS THIS. ENOUGH
OF IN THE- GIVEN THE URGENCY
THAT WE HAVE WITH CLIMATE
RESILIENCY THAT WE'RE BUSY
BEING PROPOSED I KNOW THAT
THERE'S OTHER THINGS IN THE
OTHER PACKAGES BUT- YOU GET THE
LEGISLATURE. BETWEEN FIVE AND A
HALF AND SEVEN AND A HALF OR
SOMETHING IN THOSE LINES AND
THIS IS SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION. AND THIS AND ON
THE THAT INVESTMENT COULD YOU.
RESPOND TO THAT. YEAH HAS
LARGEST- CAN MAKE A CLEAR
BUYING CLEAR BUYING THE
CLIMBERS BILLION PACKAGES
BILLING. THE SENATE EIGHTY FOUR
IS A TWO ONE TO TWO. BUT
THERE'S AMOUNTS INDIA HERE SO
IT'S A TOUGH OF ONE THREE- SO
GLAD YEAR'S INDUSTRY AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD PROPOSED
A TO AND FIND BUT IT INCLUDED
MORE THAN THIS COME. I THINK AS
VIEW OF TO WE THE WA IS GOING
AT WE THE WALLS ARE PACKED. WE
HAVE THE ACT PACKAGE AND THE
CLIMATE IS BY PACKAGE. AS SO
KIND OF A AND. IF YOU CAN OF
COMPARE. AFTER THE BOND LAST
YEAR IT'S SOME OF ALL THOSE
THAT WE WERE KIND CAN OVERALL
CLIMATE REVEAL INVEST AND SO I
THINK THAT THE ONE THREE AND A
CLIMB EVERY PACKAGE DENNIS. IS
ISN'T THERE SO OF TIME TO GO
INTO BASS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
SOME THE OLDER PACKAGE TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THAT. MORE KIND
OF A COOL. TO THE- OTHER
PROPOSALS YOU RECKON. IT'S
SECRETARIES ANYBODY WILL. AT
HONOR THIS. I WOULD JUST
REINFORCE WHAT SURGE SAID I
THIS IS THE OF NO BOB. BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE CLIMB RESILIENCE BY
BROUGH THAT WERE BEING THIS
LAST YEAR INCLUDED THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN WATER IN
WILDFIRE MORE BROADLY THAN
WHAT'S BEEN DEFINED AS CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN THE EIGHT PAGES
SO AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON I THINK WOULD
DEMONSTRATE THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING MORE NOW THROUGH THIS
ANNUAL BUDGET THEN AT LEAST
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL DEAD
LAST JANUARY AS A- AS A BOND
PROPOSAL. MICELLAR C. CAN YOU
OF ELIMINATE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING STILL MORNING GOOD
MORNING RACHEL A LIST WITH THE
LARGEST ANALYST'S JUST JUST I
THINK THIS YOUR QUESTION MISTER
TEARS A GREAT ONE AND REALLY
HIGHLIGHTS HOW COMPLICATED THIS
ISN'T FOR YOU ALL BECAUSE IT
ISN'T JUST THINKING ABOUT ONE
OF THESE PACKAGES TOGETHER YOU
REALLY DO NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THEM ALL INTERCHANGEABLY AND
WHAT ARE YOUR OVERALL GOALS FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION FOR- YOU KNOW FOR
DROUGHT. YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T
REALLY LOOK AT THESE AND
ISOLATION- AND THAT DOES MAKE
IT MORE COMPLICATED- BUT WE
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE YOUR
OVERALL GOALS AND THEN
REGARDLESS OF WHICH PACKAGE IT
IS IT IS CAP AND TRADE ALSO
NEEDS TO BE ANOTHER PIECE OF
THIS PUZZLE BUT AND MAKING SURE
THAT EACH OF YOUR PRIORITIES
THAT WHETHER IT'S FROM YOUR
BOND PROPOSALS OR OR ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. THAT THEY ARE
LOCATED SOMEWHERE YOU CAN'T YOU
CAN'T KIND OF ISOLATED INTO
ONE. MISTER SEPARATE I KNOW
THAT THIS. OR THIS CAN CHICKEN.
FOR A FIVE YEAR. WILDFIRE PLAN
THAT MEANT IN WITH THE EARLY
ACTION THAT THAT NEGOTIATED
WHAT WAS. IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
THIS MAY REPOSITION. AT LEAST
FOR THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO GO
ON AND THE WILDFIRES JUST A
REPEAT FROM JANUARY. RATHER
THAN. A REFLECTION OF THE I'D
LOOK AT LEAST THE SENATE CAN'T
TALK ABOUT THE ASSEMBLY LOUIS
LOOKING FOR A FIVE YEAR TERM.
OF A LONG TERM INVESTMENT INTO
THESE. THIS AREA. CAN YOU
RESPOND TO THAT IS IF IT SEEMS
TO GET OUT OF. THERE IF THERE
IS A. A LITTLE BIT OF A TWO
WOULD BE. TO REPEAT FROM JAN.
AT WOULD DO YOU TAKE FROM THE
IS YEAH I CAN. TO THE MINISTER
AND THE MY CALLING- BECAUSE
HELEN KIRSTY CAN COME AS WELL
BUT YES IT'S MY UNDER. THAT THE
WILD HARBOR IS THE PIECES THEY
WERE NOT INCH. WITH- WANTED
PIECE FROM THAT CAT FUND THAT
WASN'T. IN THE EARLY ACTION
OTHERWISE IT'S LARGELY THE SAME
AND IT IS JUST ONE YEAR OF
FUNDING NOT MULTIPLE YEARS.
WITH THE EXCEPTION I'M SORRY
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FOREST
HEALTH MANY THAT I THINK IS
INTENDED TO CONTINUE FROM
MULTIPLE YEARS-WHICH I THINK
IS IN THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE IT'S ADVISORY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT FOR THE PUBLIC
IS JUST ADVISORY. IT'S NOT YOU
CAN'T HOLD FUTURE. LEGISLATURES
TO SPEND MONEY BUT WITH. M.
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
FIVE YEARS HERE MICEX. PLEASE I
AM HUNGRY THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE I SO I HAVE MUCH IDEA
WHAT MAKES. RACHEL I SHE THAT
PACKAGE S. IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WAS HER IN JAN FOR THE
YEAR JUST THAT WITH THE K. WELL
JUST BECAUSE OVER THE CAN BEEN
WASN'T A PRE- AS PART OF OUR
ACTION FULLY- I WOULD THE- ONLY
OTHER OF THING TO JUST KIND OF
FIGHT FOR. IN THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE USED
FOR WILD IS A- POTENTIAL AS
WELL AS HAS THAT. THE OFF OF A
MEMBER SERVICES FOR THERE'S TWO
IN YOUR FIFTY NINE THAT COULD
BE USED FOR HIGH. A OF THAT
PROPOSED. AND OF COURSE THAT IS
THE NECESSARY GETTING FOR WHILE
SPECIFICALLY COULD BE USED A
VARIETY TO TYPES OF. BUT THAT'S
I KNOW BEHIND IF THAT THE
MINISTRY HAS PROPOSED AND COULD
IT KIND OF FIGURE IN YOUR-
DELIVERY AS YOU ABOUT HOW MUCH
HE WON ABOUT TWO WILDFIRE
CERTAINLY AS YOU YOU MENTIONED
THE SENATE HAS FOR. ON THE
SENATE DEMS THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE- ANSWER ABOUT TERM SO IN
TERMS OF HAVING YEAR. OKAY
YOU'RE FINE THIS REALLY A JUST
A WAY YEAR PROPOSAL VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN
JAN SAID THAT THAT WOULD BE ONE
ONE THING THAT I. ME WANNA
CONSIDER I DID WAYS WHETHER
THIS IS THAT THE FINE LEVEL
THEY PREFER OR WHETHER HER FOR
A DIFFERENT FUNDING. FORGET
HAVE BEFORE I GO TO SAN REQUIRE
IF YOU HAVE A- A CAN RESILIENCE
QUESTION SENATOR STERN HE WAS
TALKING TO THE- NINETY MILLION
FOR STRUCTURE GROWTH. FOR REACH
CLIMB CLEVER. HE WENT TO THE-
AND IT SAYS IT APPEAR. DESCRIBE
THE PROBE BEYOND THE PRESS
RELEASE OF NINETY NINE. WHICH
DESCRIBES. THIS ROLE INTENDS TO
TAKE THIS STEP OF A PROGRAM
SEES HE'S ASKING ABOUT THE
STATE. THE STATUS IS AFTER IF
WE ANYBODY. THE GROWTH CAL.
SERVER TECHNICAL. IF YOU WERE
TO TARA FROM I CAN GIVE A-
QUICK AND THAT'S OKAY WE WERE
LOVE TO HEAR THE DATA TO ZARA
IS THIS HEARING HEY WELL. IT
FINDS THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE'S HER SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY TWO SO IT WOULD
FUND THE CAPACITY BUILDING
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT THAT
STATUTE CALL FOR THAT HAD NOT
HAS NOT YET BEEN FUNDED AND SO
THAT IS INTENDED TO SUPPORT
DIRECT COMMUNITY CAPACITY TO
ENABLE COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES THAT
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN RESILIENCE AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
JUST TRANSITION PLANNING AND
COMMUNITY WORKERS SO THAT IS
THE FUNDING THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THAT SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
REGIONAL CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE.
PROGRAM IN THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CHAPTER- I'M NOT
SURE AGAIN I'LL HAVE TO CIRCLE
BACK AND LOOK AT WHERE THEY
NINETY ONE MILLION IS THAT MUCH
THAT'S IN REFERENCE TO- BUT
THAT TWENTY MILLION AS WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THAT AGES. AGO
SENATE MCGUIRE. RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
JUST GOING THROUGH SOME OF
THESE ITEMS I JUST WILL TAKE
DOWN SOME- SOME SPECIFIC POLICY
ISSUES FIRST AND FOREMOST FOR
MISTER CRAWFORD MISTER CRAWFORD
I THINK YOU SEE SECRETARY FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY. AT
THROUGH THE CHAIR. AND ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THERE'S A LOT TO
LIKE AND WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO SECTOR CRAWFORD FOR ALL THE
WORK WHETHER IT'S ON ISSUES OF
FIRE. FOCUSING ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND STATE PARKS
ADVANCINGJUSTICE I NEEDED
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
WORK TO YOU IN THE GOVERNOR. ON
THE ISSUE OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION REALLY HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE LEADERS IN WITH STATE
AGENCIES ON THEIR MISSION AND
C. LEVEL RISE AND- THE BEEN
VERY HELPFUL ESPECIALLY IN THE
NORTH COAST. IN A DISTANCE HE
NEED TO SHOW FUNDING THROUGH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. ON THE
SEA LEVEL RISE INITIATIVE
LAUNCHED. MR SECRETARY I KNOW
THERE'S I THINK TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN THERE- FOR PLANNING
OUTSIDE OF THE COMMISSION I
JUST DIDN'T KNOW IF THERE IS
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. ON
THE COMMISSION'S FOCUS ON ON
SEA LEVEL RISE AS WELL. YEAH I
THINK SO MUCH SENATOR YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS BEEN A LEADER-
ON ALL THINGS RELATED TO SEA
LEVEL RISE GIVEN ITS
JURISDICTION. THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
PART OF WHAT HAS BEEN A REALLY
CONSTRUCTIVE. EFFORT ACROSS
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS WITHIN
OUR AGENCY AND BEYOND OUR
AGENCY TO GETON THE SAME PAGE
AND START TO BE MORE
PROGRAMMATIC. MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MORE COHESIVE
ABOUT HOW WE'RE PLANNING AND
ACTING ON SEA LEVEL RISE-
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
THIS. THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
DOESN'T FIVE PROPOSED MORE
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. I WOULD
DESCRIBE DAY THE PROPOSALS WITH
AN R. C. LEVEL RISE PROVISION
AS A DOWN PAYMENT- ALTERNATELY
ON ON WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIND
THAT. HITHANK YOU HEY THAT'S
IS ONE ITEM THAT I THINK WILL
NEED TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON A MISTER CHAIR
JUST THROWING THAT AT YOU IN
REGARDS TO CLOSE COMMISSION IN
AGAIN- LOT TO LIKE AND
APPRECIATE THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE COAST
COMMISSION THE REASON WHY I
BRING THAT UP THEY HAVE BEEN-
THE OVERSEE SO MUCH
DEVELOPMENT- AND HAVE THAT LONG
RANGE PLANNING- AND AT THINK IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE OF PUTTING
SOME DOLLARS INTO THEIR
INITIATIVE. THE SECOND PIECE IS
JUST SOME COMMENTS. THAT THE
EIGHTY MILLION FOR NON
MOTORIZED TRAILS AND THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED- I THINK THAT IS
GOLDEN- ESPECIALLY BUILDING
UPON OUR NINETY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL
ICONOMI WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT TRAILS DUE TO REVITALIZE
RURAL COMMUNITIES- IT'S
CRITICAL AND I THINK THAT IS. A
RULE JOBS INITIATIVE AS WE LOOK
AT THAT EIGHTY MILLION. FOR NON
MOTORIZED TRAILS THAT WILL HELP
SOME OF THE POOREST COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE. ON THE THIRTEEN
ADDITIONAL FIRE CREWS. GRATEFUL
FOR THAT INVESTMENT I THINK
THAT THE CONCERN REMAINS IS
THAT WERE STILL UNDERSTAFFED
COMPARED TO WHERE WE WERE WITH
PEAK STAFFING WITH CAL FIRE. HI
HUNDRED AND 10% AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK UPSTREAM THAT'S%
BEEN A MISSION I HAVE A CHAIR
Y. CASKETS HERE FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS IN REGARDS TO.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ETCETERA- AND WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WILDFIRE
RESPONSE. GRATEFUL FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN FIRE CREWS
TO BE OUT OF BACKFILL THOSE
FORTY TWO HUNDRED- INMATE FIRECREWS THAT WE HAD THAT WE LOST.
I SINCE OVER THE LAST DECADE I
THINK THERE'S STILL NEEDS TO BE
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK WITH CAL
FIRE- IS WELL. A COUPLE OTHER
ITEMS IN REGARDS TO SECRETARY
ROSS SECRETARY RICE IF WE COULD
TALK QUICKLY ABOUT THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION. THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
AT FAIRGROUND TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I TO BE ABLE TO
PREPARE ESPECIALLY FOR HEAT AND
FIRE. SECRETARY ROSS CAN YOU
TALK WITH US ABOUT YOUR-
ADDITION FOR A PROCESS OF
ENGAGING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- AND
HAD TO GO TO GET THOSE DOLLARS
MOVED. INTO WHETHER IT'S AN
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION I
COUNTY FAIRGROUND EXEDRA CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW THAT'S GOING
TO ROLL OUT IN. YOUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH LOCALS PLEASE. IF THIS IS
A VERY DANGEROUS WOULD BE
ADOPTED. YEAH THIS WOULD HAVE
TO BE DONE- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH- WE AS A BILL PR WILL BE
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL TO THIS
PROCESS. BECAUSE OF THEIR
ONGOING WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO WE ENVISIONED
DOING ROUNDS OF LISTENING
SESSIONS AND WORKSHOPS- TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY PRIORITY
AREAS- AND WHAT WHAT'S BEING
EXPRESSED ACROSS FROM. FOR
EXAMPLE COUNTY SUPERVISORS THAT
DUSTY SACK NOW HAS A RESILIENCY
COMMITTEE THAT MEETS FREQUENTLY
AND I'VE SPOKEN WITH THEM
SEVERAL TIMES. TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
AS WE START START TO ESTABLISH
CRITERIA FOR WHAT NEEDS TO BE
GOING INTO PLANNING. ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING
THE COMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS LIKE
WHAT YOU TARA ALREADY MENTIONED
AS FAR AS CAPACITY BUILDING. SO
THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD AND
THAT PLANNING PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN SAFELY
EVACUATE PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
THE LONG LIST OF NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT ARE THAT ARE
CAUSING THE EVACUATION. AND
THAT WE HAVE FACILITIES THAT
ARE BETTER EQUIPPED TO DO
SEVERAL THINGS ONE IS TO BE
SAFE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND HIGHER CHISEL
OF THESE AND WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE SAFE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. EXPANDED
BATHROOM AND SHOWER CAPACITY IS
THAT'S NOT NORMALLY SOMETHING
THAT SHE WAS A LOT OF FOCUS ON
FOR YOU KNOW THE EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED ONE OTHER TIME SURE
FOR PERSONAL KITCHENS. BUT HOW
DO THESE FACILITIES ALSO HAVE
THE BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S BEEN SOME
EFFORTS- TO ENHANCE THAT
PROCESS. AND THEN PRIORITIZING
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO DO THIS
WIH LIMITED DOLLARS WITH INPUT
FROM STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITIES
WHERE ARE THE MOST FREQUENTLY
USED FACILITIES. WHAT IS THE
STATE OF THOSE FACILITIES SO
THAT WE CAN DEVELOP A GOOD PLAN
FOR THOSE INVESTMENTS CHECK OUT
AFTERWARDS I DON'T KNOW THAT
COMPLETELY ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTIONS. BUT IT HAS TO BE
DONE WITH EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT GOING TO
THE COMMUNITIES AND HEARING BUT
THEY NEED AND WHAT THEY WOULD
RECOMMEND. THAT WE DO AS FAR AS
I DON'T FINE PLANNING TO. FROM
IMPLEMENTING. OF FACILITY AND-
PROJECTS IT KNOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH MY SECRETARY I KNOW THE
EDITORS GO TO TALK ABOUT
HARDENING JUST. IT MA'AM CENTER
JUST PRETTY QUICKLY SECONDS OR
LESS BECAUSE I KNOW WE ARE TIME
IS LIMITED MISTER CHAIR. CAN
YOU JUST ANSWER- SO YOU LOOK AT
IS A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION. IN
YOU BELIEVE THAT THE ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS WOULD
ROLL OUT. IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUT YOU'RE NUMBER
ONE I THINK THE OTHER REALLY
BIG PIECE THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
EVACUATIONS WE'VE EVACUATED.
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF FOLKS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. IS THE NEED FOR PETS.
PEOPLE NOT EVACUATE IN FOR NOT
BUILDING IN- IN AREAS FOR PETS-
I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE REALLY
CRITICAL- LARGE ANIMALS CAN BE
TAKEN CARE OF WE TYPICALLY GET
CAPACITY IT MOST OF OUR
PROGRAMS BY SPECIALLY CATS AND
DOGS. THAT BECOMES IF I COULD
BE CANADA REAL CLUSTER- AND I
THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE FOCUSING
ON AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT SHOWERS
AND BATHROOMS BECAUSE FOLKS
JUST ONE OF ACCURATE WITHOUT
THEM. MIGHT MY LAST PIECE ON
THIS IF IT'S ALL RIGHT. MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO SAY ON THE
ADVENTURE PASS THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT- HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK WITH SOMETHING SIMILAR
TO WHAT. ASKED AFTER CRAWFORD
IS ADVANCED IN SONOMA COUNTY
ANY KID CAN GET IN WITH A
LIBRARY CARD TO REGIONAL PARK.
AND REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
FOCUS ON EQUITY SECTOR CRAWFORD
IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU SAID
THAT YOU'RE VERY INTERESTED IN
IN- I THINK IT WAS- LAST
DECEMBER NOVEMBER. WE MET IN
PRESHEAF OR FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THIS ONE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
HUGE ESPECIALLY. FOR KIDS WHO
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE ACCESS A
PARK- I THINK THIS IS GONNA BE
A GAME CHANGER FOR THAT IN THE
SECTOR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANTED TO MENTION X. I KNOW.
THAT'S BEEN A PARTY FOR YOU AS
WELL. I'LL CAN CURRENT JUST
SHARE THAT IN A CINEMA WAS A MY-
I WE ARE THINK ABOUT THIS.
THESE PILOTS AND- THERE ARE ALL
TYPES OF CREATIVE APPROACHES TO
BRING FAMILIES AND KIDS IN THE
PARKS THAT NORMALLY CAN'T
ACCESS THEM. SO THAT THESE
PROPOSED PILOTS ARE BUILT ON
THOSE EXPERIENCES AND CINNAMON
BEYONCE JUST THANK YOU. I AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND INNOVATION
NETWORK SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER DEPUTY. MUST A HORA
CAN YOU WE TOOK WE HEARD ABOUT
THE WE S. HAVING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR HARDENING OF
ALL TYPES OF FACILITIES. CAN
YOU TIE THAT MONEY INTO THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
FARES AND WHAT HOW THAT MIGHT
WORK TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU NEED
TO. GET FIFTY A. COUNTY SEE ALL
HAVE COUNTY FAIRS AND DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS THAT MAY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE HOME HARDENING
AND THAT. THAT BATCH OF- PART
OF MONEY. YET YOUR WIFE WHITE
COUNTY THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
I'M IT'S KIND OF PREMATURE TO
MAKE A LOT OF SPECULATION ON
THE APP IS SECRETARY ROSS
ALLUDED TO. WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH A VERY PUBLIC PROCESS.
BEST TO GET STAKEHOLDER AND
BUT- IN JUST TO REEMPHASIZE OUR
CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH- YES
MEANS THAT WILL BE SHARING A
LOT OF INFORMATION SO THAT WE
WANT TO GIVE IT UP OF THOSE
DIFFERENT EFFORTS AND SO THAT.
WE CAN OPTIMIZE HOW THAT MONEY
ROLLS OUT IN PROVIDES THE MOST.
RESILIENCY TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
SO WE'LL BE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM WE WILL BE
TAKING AN OVERALL LOOK ALL THE
AGENCIES RESPONSIBILITIES AS WE
DEVELOP THOSE PLANS TO GET
INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC. THANK U.
S. SECTOR S. CENTER DOLLY. THE
USER CARE AND THANK YOU TO THE
REGISTRATION AND ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY I'M GOING TO
JUST DO IT THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT
LEVEL BECAUSE- I GOT THIS
INFORMATION LAST NIGHT AND I
STAYED UP VERY LATE. DIGGING
THROUGH IT AND YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT HERE I HAVE NEVER IN THE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF BEING
ELECTED EVER HAD TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING SO. LARGE AND JUST-
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAIL LAW A
LACK OF DETAIL I SHOULD SAY
THERE'S A LOT OF PROPOSERS I
JUST WANT TO SAY FIRST OFF. I
WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR- DOING ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS I THINK ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN A IN A
TIME WHEN WE HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE. TONY JUST SHARE
THAT WITH YOU I THINK. TO THAT-
WE HAVE FIRES AND DROUGHT THAT
I THINK ARE TO THE TOP
PRIORITIES IN THE STATE- NOT
ONLY FOR- YOU KNOW THE HABITAT
AND WILDLIFE IN THE WATERSHED
TO GET AFFECTED BY FIRE WHICH
IMPACTS DROUGHT- ALSO- YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE A STRUCTURE. ISSUES
WE HAVE WITH FAIRGROUNDS IN THE
LIKES OF WHICH WOULD WHICH WE
SEEM TO BE USING EVERY SINGLE
YEAR NOW AND WAS IT USED TO BE-
MAYBE MORE. YOU KNOW EVERY
THREE OR FOUR YEARS SO I WILL I
WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M
CONCERNED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THEM HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
GET THIS ALL ACCOMPLISHED IN
THERE'S NOT BEEN MUCH DETAIL
AND IN THE POLICY PART OF IT
IS. IS THE SPENDING IS THERE
AND NOW IT'S- THE POLICIES IN
MORE HOW WE'RE HOW WE'RE GONNA
IMPLEMENT THIS AND- AS SOMEBODY
WHO'S RUNNING LEGISLATION TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
SOME OF THESE IMPACTS LIKE
WILDLIFE IMPACTS I'M I'VE HAVE
LEGISLATION THAT IN ITS IN ITS
MY BILLS ARE GOING TO SET THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHICH BECOMING
OUT. AT THE END OF THE WEEK
IT'S- INTERESTING TO ME THAT WE
HAVE WE WOULD HAVE ANYTHING ON
SUSPENSE ARE SO MUCH RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA THE
LIKES LIKE NONE OF US EVER SEEN
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
SEEING INFLATION- BUILDING
RIGHT NOW JUST BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH MONEY AND FUSED.
NOT ONLY. IN CALIFORNIA BUT-
NATIONWIDE. AND SO I'M I'M NOT
GOING TO COMMENT MORE THAN THAT
I JUST WANNA SAY I DO. THINK WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING THESE
RESOURCE ON ONE TIME PROJECTS
THAT ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED AND
THEN- HITTING THOSE TARGETED
AREAS THAT WE KNOW. HAVE BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR SPURS FOR SOMETIME
WHICH YOU HAVE ADDRESSED THE
FIRE IN THE IN THE DROUGHT
ISSUES AND TO GET THOSE. OF
MONIES AVAILABLE- TO THE
AGENCIES AND PLACES WHERE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS DROUGHT TIME- I
THINK IS A- WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE SO WITH THAT. I'LL
SAVE A LOT OF MY COMMENTS
ACTUALLY FOR WHEN WE SEE THE
FINAL BUDGET WHERE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO. DIG A
LITTLE DEEPER- BUT THIS IS
REALLY LARGE AND I THINK THAT
IT IS SOMEWHAT SCARY TO ME THAT
WE HAVE THIS MUCH. MOVING THIS
FAST AND TO TRY TO. HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE KEEP THEIR ARMS ON
EVEN THE L. A. O.'S OFFICE-
ADMITTED THAT THEY- YOU KNOW
THEY HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY DIG INTO THIS AND SO
I THINK. WE SHOULD MAYBE LOOK A
LITTLE BIT OF CAUTION AS WE GO
FORWARD AND JUST MAKE SURE
THAT- NO THE RESOURCES ARE
SPENT WISELY SO AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL TODAY FOR A PARTICIPATING.
A SUPER XCITED ABOUT- SEEN
SOME OF THESE THINGS HAPPEN AND
ALSO A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS AT
THE SAME TIME ABOUT HOW MUCH
THERE IS- HAPPENING AS WELL.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THOUGHT TESTIFIED
TODAY WERE UNFORTUNATELY OUT OF
TIME SO I HAVE TO MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC HEARING. I APPRECIATE.
THE CHALLENGE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS LAID ON THE
SENATE'S FEET AND I. HOPE TO
RISE TO THE OCCASION. OF HER
ALL THE DETAILS. AND SORT
THINGS OUT. WE WILL BE HAVING A
HEARING NEXT TUESDAY OR-
SOMETIME NEXT WEEK- SO WE CAN
TAKE ACTION ON THINGS SO. I
DON'T KNOW IF I'LL GET ANY
SLEEP IN THE NEXT WEEK BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT. I COULD HAVE
TALKED ALL MORNING ABOUT THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. OR ABOUT THE
L. TO R. FIVE EXPERIENCE FOR
ALL WORK. ALL THE DIFFERENT DIE
GESTURES WE HAVE FOR. MISCIBLE
WASTE AGRICULTURAL WASTE.
BROUGH OF FOREST WASTES IN
WHETHER IT'S IN THE CATALYST
FUNDER THE CAP AND TRADE WE'RE
JUST IN THE BUDGET BUT- ALL
HOLD THOSE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
HER YOUR COMMENTS AND MOVED TO.
THE PUBLIC HEARINGS. THANK YOU-
THIS IS THE TIME WE WILL OPEN
IT UP FOR. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO- YES
THE. THE COMMITTEE ON. ANY ITEM
THAT HAS BEEN LISTED ON THE
AGENDA FROM PARKADE THE FIVE
DIFFERENT ISSUES FOR PART B.
THE- FIFTY TWO ISSUES OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COME FORWARD HERE IN A-
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I
DO. ALL THE WASHING FROM.
INSTRUCTORS DO NOT TAKE ANY
ACTION. AND IN THE FUTURE- OF
ALWAYS. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE
CITY OF ENCINITAS- BECAUSE WE
DID DISCUSS IT BUT VOICING
OPPOSITION TO THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL TO SUSPEND THE BEACH
SAND REPLENISHMENT PROGRAM.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS BEEN
ON THE BOOKS SINCE- THE BILL
ORIGINALLY CREATED THE PROGRAM
BACK IN I THINK IT WAS NINETEEN
NINETY NINE- JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS AND
WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT BOTH FOR
OUR CITY AND I BELIEVE THE
STATE ONE THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
NEEDED FUNDING TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS THIS IS A CLOSURE
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
ABOUT 65% FEDERAL FUNDS TO
STATE FUNDS. SO WE BRING MONEY
INTO THE STATE FOR THIS- IN THE
CASE OF AN FOR THIS THIS BE
SAND. PROGRAMS BEEN GOING ON
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND THE
STUDY PHASE WERE READY TO BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION- WE'VE HAD DEATHS
IN ENGINEERS FROM BOTH CLASSES
THESE BEACH SAND REPLENISHMENT
PROGRAMS PROTECT THOSE BLUFFS-
ALSO PROTECTS. CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THE COASTAL
RAIL LINE AND THE BEACHES THAT
ARE GOING TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM ARE ACTUALLY ST
FEATURES SO. I KNOW YOUR LIMIT
FOR TIME I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT
THAT BUT WE REALLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REJECT
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL CONTINUE
FUNDING THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY GOOD- I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE ONE TO
THE OTHER WITNESSES HERE SO
WE'LL MOVE TO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA.
A REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR
SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVEN NINE
EIGHT SEVEN. DO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. AS YOU'VE SEEN
THERE'S A LOT HERE TO TRY TO
DIGEST I APOLOGIZE. BECAUSE
WE'LL HAVE TO INSTITUTE A TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ARE ASKING
PICKED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF
THEY COULD LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE WE'RE- OBVIOUSLY
GOING THROUGH YOUR WRITTEN
COMMENTS WITH THAT- WE'LL MOVE
TO THE MODERATOR IF YOU CAN-
QUEUE UP THE FIRST SERVE
WITNESS. THEY LIKE TO TESTIFY
TELLING YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ONCE CONNECTED TO
THE AUDIO CONFERENCING PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD TO PLACE YOURSELF IN Q.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOCAL TO
OUR FIRST LINE WHICH IS. NINE
THIRTY ONE. THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALONG ONE OF
COHEN. HELLO THE MORNING CARE
ACT MICHAELS HE THANK YOU
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE NEED TO
CURTAIL AND I'M GOING TO THE
LOCAL MEMBER WITH THE LOCAL
ACTIVATION CODES CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC MAYBE MEDICAL SUPPORT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND IT
WOULD NOT INCLUDE ANY DIRECT
INVESTMENT FOR THE FOURTEENTH
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION GROUPS
WELCOME OF COURSE PROGRAM
EMPIRE YOUNG PEOPLE LET ME BE A
PART OF THE STATE'S WORK.
EQUIPMENT BUYERS. I AM NOT
LOOKING THEM. THE CLIMATE
CHANGE ONLINE TO MAKE IT. WE
HAVE A LONG PROJECTIONIST
SENATE BY THE I WANT TO BE A
CRIME LEADER AND ONE HOW MUCH.
DO YOU DON'T LEAVE ME ANOTHER I
NEED. AND YOUR FINANCIAL
CONNECTION MEASURES THAT. THANK
MAX. MY FIFTY. THANK YOU MISS
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
IN OUR STATE I JUST WANTED TO
BE BEFORE YOU TODAY AND EXPRESS
OUR PROFOUND GRATITUDE AND
THANKS TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR PUTTING FORWARD SOME VERY
VERY STRONG PROPOSALS AS IT
RELATES TO ELECTRIFICATION I'M
MORE VERY HARD TO SEE THE
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY THAT
BENEFIT DURING MISSION WHAT'S
THE POINT ALL THESE ARE SPOKEN
TO IMPART A ISSUES THREE AND
FIVE. OF YOUR AGENDA ONE
PARTICULAR WE DO SUPPORT THE
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FOR HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE HE
WON EMPHASIZED THAT THAT.
PROGRAM THE INVESTMENTS WOULD
INCLUDE A SPECIFIC SET ASIDE
FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES IN SUPPORT
HI THERE ALL THE MEN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD'S
REQUIREMENT TO TRANSITION TO A
2% GERMINATION FLEET BY TWENTY
FORTY ALSO WANT TO SHOW OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WOULD FLOW TO THE PC THAT
WE'VE ISSUED A LETTER THAT
SPEAKS TO A VARIETY OF OUR
PRIORITIES WILL KNOW THAT IT
ALIGNS VERY CLOSELY WITH WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION ACCORDING.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SHARE THAT
WITH THE COMMITTEE AGAIN TODAY
I SAW IT ON YOUR ON YOUR
REGISTER. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT. BLIND FORTY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU LETTER WITH
THE BY ASSOCIATE AND- I WANT TO
ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT
THE FIGURES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION MADE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY AND CERTAINLY PUTTING
OUR ORGANIC WASTE TO BENEFICIAL
USE FOR ENERGY AND OIL AND THEN
ANOTHER PRODUCT IT'S A CRITICAL
PART OF THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
WHICH COULD REDUCE OPEN BURNING
OF FORESTS AND AGRICULTURAL
WASTE LANDFILLING NOTHING
LESSONS FROM DAIRIES SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FUNDING
THAT IS PROPOSED FOR FOREST
BIOMASS UTILIZATION IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO TAKE THE MATERIAL OUT
OF THE FOREST WE NEED TO STOP
OPEN BURNING PILE BURNING
FOREST WAY SIMILARLY WITH THE
MONEY PROPOSED. TO SAY THAT
OPEN BURNING OF AGRICULTURAL
WASTE WHICH IS REALLY CRITICAL
TO PROTECT THEIR QUALITY REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS WE ONLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
FUNDING SO IT CAN BE UNIQUE
STATEWIDE NOT JUST IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WE NEED TO PHASE
OUT THE OPEN BURNING EVACUATION
EVERYWHERE NOT JUST IN THE
VALLEY SH ARE WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR LIVESTOCK METHANE
PRODUCTION CRITICALLY FROM
DAIRIES THESE HAVE BEEN SOME OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS THE STATE
HAS MADE. IN REDUCING CHARLIE
KIND OF COULDN'T. AND FINALLY
WE STRONG SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSED. FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FOR DIVERTIDO.
WASTE OF ANOTHER CRITICAL PART.
EIGHT HUNDRED. AND LOCAL NEED.
BUT WE ALSO URGE SENATE PROVIDE
FOR TO CARRY CYCLE COUNTY CYCLE
HAS FUNDED THE MOST BECAUSE
EFFECTIVE CRIME PROGRAMS DIVERT
ORGANIC WASTE ON SO. WE SHOULD
BE A BOTH READY. TO DIVERT
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS
AND HELPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. NEXT LEVINE SEVENTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPEND INTO A
COMBAT FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS FACING
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES IN MEETING
HEALTH BASED AIR QUALITY
ATTAINMENT STANDARDS AND
REDUCING YOUR POLLUTION TOXICS
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE FUNDING IS CRITICAL
FOR MEETING THE STANDARDS AND
SELLING YOUR TERMINATIONS
REDUCTIONS IN IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK QUICKLY ACCORDINGLY
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE MAY
REVISION PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND SENATE
FUNDING IN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN MILLION FOR THE FARM
THE PROGRAM IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAR. AND
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE HOWEVER GIVEN
THE BUDGET SURPLUS AND THE
ENORMOUS NEED WE URGE YOU TO
INCREASE FUNDING LEVELS FOR
THESE IMPORTANT CLEAN AIR
PROGRAMS FURTHERMORE WE
APPRECIATE THE MAY REVISION
RETAINS THE FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
SB SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION. FROM THE
GOVERNOR ST YOU'RE A BUDGET BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS AMOUNT
CONTINUES TO BE INSUFFICIENT TO
COVER COSTS INCURRED
IMPLEMENTING THE STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM IN ORDER SAID. ACCOUNT
FOR ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY. THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU TO A- WE'RE
GOING. DOLLAR WORK YOU TO A
GUIDE FOR APPRECIATE SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH JUST HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS ON THE LINE AND DON'T
MEAN BUT- THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE
IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE A TO BRING IN THE NECK
BUDGET COMMITTEE WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME TODAY LAYS IN
GERMAN. SO WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL
CALLERS TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS AT TWO. TO ONE
MINUTE PLEASE TO ONE MINUTE ALL
RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FOUR SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S MY NAME'S LISA MELANIE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
KNOW WE ARE VERYMUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET. AND JOHN
THIS HISTORICAL INVESTMENT
HOWEVER THERE ARE TWO ITEMS I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT. ONE IS
THAT BORDER REGION THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER REGION HAS
BEEN PERSISTENTLY IGNORED. AND
WE NEED TO TALLY BE A MULTI
MEDIA CARD BORDER UNIT AND WE
HAVE NOT GONE AND THE OTHER
MORE CONCERNING IS THAT DGSE.
WE NEED A STUDENTS TO STEP
PROCESS I'M GLAD TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT TO DATE THAT IT'S IN THE
RADAR OF THE OF THIS COMMITTEE
BUT WE NEED TO WEED OUT THE BAD
APPLES. AND WE NEED
CONSIDERABLE OVERSIGHT BEFORE
BAILING THEM OUT- THEN THIS
NEEDS TO HAPPEN AT THE SAME
TIME SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU NEXT. EIGHTY FOUR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS FAITHFUL ALSO ON
<c.green>EHALF OF WATER REUSE</c>
CALIFORNIA WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- ONLY HAVING ONE
HUNDRED AND IFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR RECYCLED WATER AND
THAT HAVE TO SHARE HER WITH
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP OVER TWO
YEARS I'M AS YOU HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND THERE'S OVER
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN SHOVEL
READY RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS
AT THE STATE COURT ON A LAST-
IDENTIFIED IN THEIR INTENDED
USE PLAN. WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
THE SENATE TO PICK WITH AN
INCREASE THEIR ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL IN THE DROUGHT PACKAGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SIXTY SIX
YEAR. NEXT EIGHTY NINE. THIS
PROPOSAL. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
TO THE JUST AFTERNOON TURN
NUMBERS- THIS IS EVEN MY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
BARNES FUND- WE'RE SPEAKING ON
THE ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN AND ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT OUR
STATE PARKS I'M NOT ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR PARKS READY TO
GREET THE PUBLIC BETTER THAN
EVER BEFORE. IN THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR FIRE
RESTORATION IS CRUCIAL FOR FIRE
DEVASTATED PARTS OF HIS BIG
BASIN REDWOODS STATE PARK AMONG
THE MANY OTHER STATE PARKS
DAMAGED BY WILDFIRES IN THE
PAST YEAR WELL THE DEMANDS FOR
RESTORATION OR GREAT THIS
FUNDING IS A GOOD START TO
FUNDING THE WORK NEEDED TO
RESTORE THE NATURAL LANDSCAPE
AND PARK AMENITIES FORMER GLORY.
THANK YOU. SIX NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS SOME
PALM. PAUL MASON WITH THE CIVIC
POLISH TRUST I WANTED TO SPEAK
TO BRIEFLY TO THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THE FIRE WATER AND
CLIMATE PACKAGES- WHICH IN THE
FOURTH OF LANDSCAPE THE
INTERVENTION IS GONNA BE DOING
FOR ALL THOSE PURPOSES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY THE SAME
RESTORING RESILIENCE- REDUCING
SOME OF THE OVERLY DENSE
FORESTS AND TRYING TO RECREATE.
THE MORE STRUCTURALLY DIVERSE
FORESTS WITH A BIG OLD TREES
WITH THE FIRE RESISTANT ARE
THEY WILL BETTER SURVIVE YOU
KNOW THE. FIRES ARE GOING TO
SEE IN THE FUTURE. IN THE
PROPOSALS WE IN THE MAYOR. TO
SEE LOTS OF INTERVENTION IN THE
NEAR TERM OR OR SPENDING THOSE
ARE TWO ACTIVITIES PER
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT. PART OF
THE PLAN. THERE ISN'T MUCH
FUNDING THEY ARE FOR THE SWORD
SO LONG TERM CONSERVATION
INTERVENTIONS THAT WILL HELP
SECURE GOOD MANAGEMENT INTO THE
FUTURE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
PLACE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY NEEDS TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BORDER SIMILAR AND
CONTINUES. TO DO SOME OF THOSE
LONG TERM CONSERVATION
INTERVENTIONS FOR WATER
RESILIENCE FIRE BIODIVERSITY
AND CLIMATE SO WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
BILLION IN ON A PARTICULAR
ISSUE THANK. YOU THANKS RESUME
CENEX. WINDS TWO. BUT SURE
ENOUGH ACTUALLY ARE WORKING OUT
I'M INCLUDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TO GET FROM TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY ONE ON ISSUE
NUMBER NINE. ASIAN NETWORK WE
REALLY FOR IS AN ACTOR 60% OF
OR TO YOU WITH LITTLE STUFF ON.
A FARMER AND FARMWORKER TRAIN
TO BE ANYMORE. BY REUTERS WE
WELCOME ADMINISTRATION'S ADDED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION. AND WE
WILL. GUIDE YOU MONITORING AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTION WE ALSO
WOULD AGAIN REQUEST LANGUAGE
SHE ADDED FOR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE REALLY NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
BY PESTICIDE USE THAT GIVE THEM
GREEN SPACES. PROTECTED BUFFER
ZONE. WOMEN IN YOUR AREA. OTHER
MEDIA PRODUCTIONS. ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE DENTAL. H. WE HAVE A
LOT OF THE MANY TRANSFER AND
PROVIDES YOUR BODY OKAY. YOU
ARE THE POLLINATOR HABITAT
PROGRAM COULD BE VERY IMPORTANT
AND SHALL IN ORDER TO THE WAY
WINDOWS IS IN THE- IN THIS CASE.
CURRENT APPOINTED OR HAVE AS
ARE LIMITED BY THE AVAILABILITY
OF APPROPRIATE WILL NATIVES A
LOT OF THE LIKE RUNNING AND
LIKE THAT. IN ORDER TO. DO
BECAUSE EXACT WE ARE THERE SO
WE WOULD RECKON IT THAT
STUDENTS THE MYSTERY DOLLARS.
BY EARLY TO A MODERN PROGRAM TO
SURE THAT MONEY ARE TO BY THE
TIME THE EASY GROUND SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DO SALMON. I DON'T
BELIEVE OUT TO STATEWIDE FOR
LOCAL NATIVE PLANTS EACH AGAIN
WILL NATIVE PLANTS HE AND ALL
OTHER AND ON ORDER REFORM
DOLLARS. AND IT REALLY WILL
EVER SHE THE BIGGER INVESTMENT
AND ALL THE OTHER THAT WERE ALL
MEETING IN THE STATE'S I THINK
AGAIN FOR YOUR CONSIDER AND FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK THANK YOU
NECK. NINE EIGHTY. BETTER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE DOW APPS BEAR ERIC
MANAGEMENT DOES I'D LIKE TO
ECHO COMMENTS ARE FROM APART
FROM CASH UP INTO ZERO MAKE PRO
CLEAN TRANSFER IN EQUITY. AND
RE AUTHOR IS OF EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH INCLUDES BOY PRO ONE
SHORTFALL LIKE TO KNOW THE-
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY PROTECT
PROGRAM FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S REMAIN FLAT
FOR FOUR YEARS WHILE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTED BY THE PROGRAM THAT
INCREASED BY 50% AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ADDED WE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR THIS
VITAL PROGRAM BEING CREATED BE
SUPPORTED WITH MULTI YEAR
FUNDING COMMITMENT SIMILAR TO
OTHER PROGRAMS IMPORTANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FIVE ANNEX. I AM SEVENTY
SIX. YEAH IT CHAIR WOOD COUNTY
AND MEMBERS GAVE AROUND THAN
WITH THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS CAPTAIN
BUSY ETHICALLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS TO INVEST
NEARLY A BILLION IN NEW FUNDING
AIMED AT SUPPORTING A
TRANSITION TO SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE BUT ON BEHALF OF
OUR MORE THAN EIGHT THOUSAND
SMALL AND MID SCALE FAMILY
FARMERS CAP URGES YOU TO ADD
NEEDS VERY MODEST CRITICAL ONE
TIME INVESTMENT. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON SEVENTEEN MILLION
FOR REGIONAL FOOD HUBS TO HELP
SMALL SCALE FARMERS ACTIVE
INSTITUTIONAL MARKET AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT MILLION FOR
THE BEST PROGRAM TO DEMONSTRATE
IPM METHODS AND REDUCE CHEMICAL
USE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
PER BEGINNING FARMER AND
FARMWORKER TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MILLION
AND TEN MILLION PER TO
LIBRARIES SO URBAN AND RURAL
FARMERS CAN ACCESS QUICK AND
TECHNIQUE. FINALLY CAPTAIN TEN
USED TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TIERED PESTICIDE NO
FEET ALONG WITH ENHANCEMENTS
PROPOSED BY A BROAD COALITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT A
LINE SEVENTY NINE. MISTER CAREY
MEMBERS WILL BE ASKED TO LEAVE
SHOT BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT IN REGARDS TO PART B.
OF TODAY'S AGENDA SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY STATING ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES IN MEETING HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY OF PAYMENT
STANDARDS AND IN REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR OBLIGATIONS AS OUTLINED IN
OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE. EIGHTY
EIGHT PROGRAMS INCLUDING COM
WHERE. WHAT THE FUNDING FOR IN
THE MARY BY. FOR THE FARMER
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES FOR AIR
QUALITY AND ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO
THE VALLEY. THANK YOU. FOR THE
FUNDING COMES INCLUDED IN THEIR
PLAN FOR ALTERNATIVES TO ASK
BERNIE WHATEVER WE HOPE TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
FOR THE- FUNDING AT THE A. R.
P. HAS DETERMINED THAT THE NEED
FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS MUCH
GREATER. LASTLY THE DISTRICT
ALSO SUPPORTS INCREASED FUNDING
FOR NEAR TERM EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TAX. FIFTY FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. THANK YOU
STEVE ANY MEDICARE COMMERICAL
THE- BECAUSE I'M AND BY FRIDAY-
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO SAY
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT AIR
POLLUTION CHARGES IN THE US YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO TRANSPORTATION
SOURCES FROM WITHIN THE LEADING
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION IN THE
STATE OF COURSE THE IMPACT WILL
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED REDUCE
OUR- GIVEN THIS CONCERN SUPPORT
THE COMMITMENT TO THE POINTER
EMISSION VEHICLES ESPECIALLY
SUPPORT OF THE- THE PROPOSAL
SLATED TO DRAINAGE TRAFFIC
SCHOOL USES. WE GO TO THE BACK
OF THE CARD OUR MISSION AND
PROTECTING ONE THOUSAND
PRINTING QUALITY. FOR MOST
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES. THE ERROR
NUMBER. COMMUNITIES NUMBER SIX
ASK THE BEST IN THE HUNDRED.
DIRECTLY BASS ZERO TRACK. FOR
TO MATCH PROGRAM MAN. OR NEXT
TRANSIT TO ZERO VEHICLE. ALLEN
WE- BY THEM AROUND TODAY.
CONTINUE TO URGE FOR THE RIYADH.
TO BE. SINCE CRITICAL FUNDING
FOR THE CAR MORE THAN. AND
OTHER CREDIT POLLUTION CONTROL
PROGRAMS. CONSISTENTLY AFTER.
OF THE ENTITY COMMISSION BEING
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. YOU TO
PLAY IN AND BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. NEXT LINES. TWO GO
AHEAD LIKE FIFTY TWO NINE FIVE.
BIG. MEMBERS GATHERED ACTUALLY
I'LL BE APPLES AND ENERGY
ECONOMY AND SUPPORT- THE
STARGATE BASKETBALL LOW WHEREBY
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
VERSION MISSION CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BALANCE ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
SPECIFICALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSIT VEHICLE OF THEIR
MISSION INVESTMENT PROGRAM ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENT ALSO MADE
THE CHARGER INVESTMENT PLAN. AT
THE END OF YOUR COMMERCIAL.
NEXT WELL I AM THIRTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE WHITE HOUSE
SKIING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME PASSED THE NECKLACE I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
CORE THE LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORPS IN OAKLAND AND ALTHOUGH
THE MARION BINDING COULD
SUPPORT OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WE CERTAINLY
ARE EXCITED ABOUT IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY DIRECT INVESTMENT
TO SUPPORT THE FOURTEENTH
STREET CERTIFIED LOCAL
CONSERVATION CARDS. LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS PROGRAMS
EMPOWER YOUNG POPLE EIGHTEEN
DEAD TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD TO BE
PART OF THE STATE'S WORK TO
PREVENT FIRES AND HELP OUR
COMMUNITY PREPARE FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND MINIMIZE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT. FOR EXAMPLE
SHOULD CORE WORK DIRECTLY WITH
YOU BAY REGION PARK DISTRICT IN
EACH GAME. TO ELIMINATE FUEL
HAZARDS AND CREATE YOUR BREAK.
AND WE ASK THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THE WORK OF CORPS MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE AND LOCAL TAX
FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. NINE TWENTY FIVE. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTERS MY NAME
IS KRISH OTHERS ON THE DEPUTY
POLICY DIRECTOR COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR WHICH IS A MEMBER OF
THE CHARGE HEAD CALIFORNIA'S
GOT COALITION MY COMMENTS THEIR%
FOCUS ON THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION HAS ALSO
CHARGING INTO CLEAN FEELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR POLL
FOR HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION WE'VE
INVESTMENT APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BRING
CALIFORNIANS MUCH CLOSER TO A
FUTURE OF CLEAN MOBILITY FOR
ALL. WITHOUT LEAVING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
MEET ITS CLIMATE COMMITMENTS OR
MEET FEDERAL AND STATE AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS WHICH IMPACT
IS MOST SEVERE IN COMMUNITIES
THEY'RE GOOD IN THE CORRIDORS
WHICH ARE PREDOMINATELY
DISADVANTAGE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ONE AREA WHERE
LEGISLATURE CAN BUILD UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP IS TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS-
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO THESE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME NEXT. LINE. EIGHT EIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JACK
NEO- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO. THEY SAY THE URBAN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
DESIGNED DELIVER EVEN MORE
MONEY THAN THE SEVEN BILLION UP
FROM OTHER SOURCES OF THE LAST
MILE PIECES OF THE PROPOSALS-
OBVIOUSLY WOULD ACTUALLY
DELIVER BROADBAND TO PEOPLE
CURRENTLY WITHOUT IT. OR WITH
INADEQUATE BROADBAND BUT THE
REALLY TRANSFORMED IT IS BUT I
WANT TO FOCUS ON IS THE POOR
BILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED TO
BUILD A STATE WIDE OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK WHICH WILL
DRAMATICALLY BRING DOWN THE
COST OF LAST MILE DEPLOYMENT
FIRST OF ALL MAKING THE OTHER
DOLLARS. IN THE PROPOSAL GO
EVEN FURTHER BUT BY DOING SO IT
ALSO INCREASED AFFORDABILITY
AND NETWORK RESILIENCE NOT JUST
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
BROADBAND NOW BEEN BACK FOR
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW OVER 40% OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ONE OR FEWER CHOICES FOR
BROADBAND WOULD RESULT IN THE
SITUATION WITH BROADBAND
PROVIDERS BASICALLY GET ALL THE
BENEFITS OF NATURAL MONOPOLIES
IN INDUSTRIES LIKE ELECTRICITY
BUT WITHOUT THE REGULATIONS
WORK IMPORTANTLY. THE UNIVERSAL
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU
IMPACT. OF THANK YOU SO WE THE
MIDDLE NETWORK AND THE REST OF
THE BROAD BEEN MOBILE THANK YOU
EXCELLENT NEXT. LINE. TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHIRLA
KOWSKI AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TODD IS I'M TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD AND I AM REQUIRE
MEMBER WITH THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL CONSERVATION CORPS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALTHOUGH THE
LEGAL ADVICE INCLUDES SUPPORT
FOR WORKFORCE. DEVELOPMENT IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY DIRECT
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE FOURTEEN
LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE LOCAL
CORPS PROGRAMS EMPOWERS YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE ME TO BE A PART OF
THE STATE'S WORK TO PREVENT
FIRES AND HELP OUR COMMUNITY
PREPARE FOR CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
RECORDS IS CURRENTLY WORKING TO
MINIMIZE FIRE DANGERS BY
REDUCING VEGETATION BUT OUR
SACRAMENTO UTILITIES PROJECT I
WANT TO BE A CLIMATE LEADER AND
I WANT TO HELP MY COMMUNITY
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE ME AND
OTHERS LIKE ME BEHIND. AND
PLEASE INCLUDE DIRECT FUNDING
TO THE LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS
IS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. BY NINETY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS BECAUSE FOR A TIME
AFTER THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
THERE IS MUCH TO LIKE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMPLIMENT OF THE MINISTRATION
HOW THEY'RE PROPOSING TO MAKE
NEEDED INVESTMENTS AND WATER
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND MUCH
MORE IN PARTICULAR WE SUPPORT A
COMMITMENT OF FUNDING TO CDFW
ESPECIALLY THE NEED TO RESPECT
BINDING REMARK INCLUDING
CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVES FUNDING FOR
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND
COMMITTING SATELLITE
CONNECTIVITY FUNDING. THAT WE
ALSO SUPPORT PROPOSED
INVESTMENT IN RENEWABLE ENERGY
INCLUDING RESOURCES FOR
OFFSHORE WIND PLANNING WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED MESSENGER
STATE PARKS INCLUDING INCREASED
ACCESS TO ALL BECAUSE FINING
PERSONALIZED PLANNING AS WELL
PROPOSAL FOR LARGER COASTAL
WETLANDS RESTORATION FUNDING M.
AS REFERENCED EARLIER IN THE
HEARING NOW THERE WERE
ADDITIONAL CLOSE COMBATANTS
THAT WAS OPPOSED IN THE AREA
CLIMATE RESILIENT BOND
INCLUDING FOR LAND ACQUISITION
OF THE W. C. B. R. A. Y.
CONSERVANCY'S. THOSE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS ARE NOT PRESENT IN
THE REGION THE PROPOSAL FROM
THE GOVERNOR AND DNC URGES THE
SENATE TO SUPPORT A
COMPREHENSIVE BUDGET BUDGET
PACKAGE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT DOESN'T LEAVE
BEHIND PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
DURABLE LAND CONSERVATION
EFFORTS THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE
SENATE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES INCLUDING YOUR
PREVIOUS ACTIONS BY WILDFIRE
DROP TRACKAGE IS. HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU NEXT. BLIND FOUR.
GERMAN MEMBERS GROWTH IS
BECAUSE OUT CAL RIGHT TO AND
THOUSAND MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING
TO OF THE ARMY DEPARTMENT ISSUE
WHILE DEPARTMENT ISSUE ARE LIKE
A YOU DONE MORE WITH LESS
PUBLISHED FIRST AND I BINDING
AND IT'S ALL GOING CRITICAL.
ONE IS THE FUNDING OF TO THE
APPLE TO ALIGN WITH THE-
TRAFFIC- AND THE FUNDING OF.
INDIAN CULTURE TEN TWENTY THREE
AND THOUSAND POINTS. THIS
MORNING CRITICAL TO OUR SHOULD
NEVER OF COLLECTION THROUGH CAL.
PROP PLACE WHY LAKE ROAD CROSS
TO MAKE OUR HIGHWAY SHAPER. AND
OUR CITIZENS ALIKE SO WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE AND STRONGLY- WOULD
LIKE TO SEE TEN TWENTY THREE IN
TWO THOUSAND POINT SIX FUNDED.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE BEST PLACE
IN THE WILDLIFE OVER CROSSINGS
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU NEXT. SECONDS.
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MADDIE MONTHS AND ON
BEHALF OF SANTA ANA WATERSHED
PROJECT TO FORTY FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY NINE SOCCER
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FIVE
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL
WATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM HIGHER
W. M. ARE PROVEN REGIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT CAN INVEST IN
REGIONAL SOLUTION TO DROUGHT
IMPACTS THROUGHOUT THE DAY
THANK YOU. NEXT FINE. NINETY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION- I'M PART EIGHT
ISSUE FIVE THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT WORK EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TAKEN UP LAST WEEK.
FOR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THE EXISTING. GRAHAM
WHICH WE CAN PROVIDE GREEN ON
THE PRODUCTS THEY OF PRINCE.
AND THE EXISTING. A LOT THANK
YOU. MAX. NINE NINETY TWO FIFTH
HELLO OKAY ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY MAJOR CONNECTIONS AND
NATURE FOR ALL. WE SHOULD BE
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY ACCESS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION
INCLUDING TPR OUTDOOR EQUITY
GRANTS PROGRAM HOWEVER EVEN
WITH THESE INVESTMENTS THERE'S
A BIG DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
GAP. STILL INTO RESTORING TO
FILL TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS UNIQUE INAPPROPRIATE
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO UNDER
THAT THE OUTDOORS AND GET
SUPPORT. VENTURING INTO CRIME
AND NATURAL RESOURCE CAREERS.
FIRST REPLACE YOUR QUESTION
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN GENERALFUND DOLLARS
THIS YEAR TO EXPAND ABRUPTION
SCOPE OF THE EXISTING NEW
COMMUNITY ACTORS GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY C. N. ARI THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS MEANINGFUL
AND APPROPRIATE OUTDOOR
PROGRAMMING. SECOND QUESTION
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT CENTER HUESO AND CENTER
DRAWS THOSE SB SIX ZERO FOUR
WHICH WOULD SUPPORT MULTI
BENEFICIAL CRIME IN WORKFORCE.
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE. OTHER CRITICAL TO THAT
WE ARE TRULY A TO THE OUR TO.
COMMUNITY AND THIS YEAR'S BY
SURPLUS OCCUR TOOL CORRECT IN
STORAGE SURPLUS. INSTINCTIVELY
THAT TO THE CONCERN WILDFIRE.
OR GOOD START OVER WILDFIRES
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN AND ARE
HEADED INTO A DROUGHT. WE WANT%
TO CALL THE IMPORTANT ROLECONSERVANCY'S PLAY HER STAGE IS
DOING AND WE NEED TO DO MORE
SHE MEET THE DEMANDS. THANK YOU
BACK NEXT. BRIAN. ONE ONE. HI
NATALIE HER GARA ON BEHALF OF
THAT WE CAN AND CAL GRANT- ON
BEHALF OF BELLY CANDY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
CLIMATE EQUITY THROUGH THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO
CONGRESSIONAL AND OTHER EQUITY
PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET. CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL IMPORTANT PROGRAM
BUT SERVES CALIFORNIA'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HELPING STATE REJECT CHRONICLED
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
FUNDING TO BE PUT TO GOOD USE
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
MOST. I BEHALF OF. I THINK TWO
THOUSAND ONE CALVIN HAS
PROVIDED SERVICES AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS FROM THE STATE.
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS COMPRISING
A RIDERSHIP FOR TYPICALLY WELL
INCOME OUT LIVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND- WITH THE
ECONOMIC BARRIERS. AND WEALTHY
CHALLENGES GETTING TO WORK- WE
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
IN OUR COMMUNITY TO INCLUDE
AGRICULTURAL VANPOOL PROGRAMS
AS PART OF THE FUNDING THAT WE
CAN COMPETE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES TO OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU MAX.
SEVENTY NINE. I'M POLITICS.
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE A MEMBER
MEANT FOR A LARGE- WITH THE
COMMONSENSE- TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT ON THE
AGENDA ITEM WE'RE STILL
DIGESTING THE NAY REVISION BUT
WE ARE STARTING CONCEPT OF MANY
THE ALLOCATIONS FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. WE BELIEVE HOWEVER
THAT SOME MORE SPECIFICITY
AROUND UTILIZING CLEAN
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY ALTERNATIVES
NEEDED HAVE SUCH WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE SENATE TO ENSURE
THAT WE STILL UNDER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE RESPONSE
GOES TOWARDS COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESTORING FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SHOULD FOCUS ON
UTILIZING CLEAN E. OURS TO HELP
COMMUNITIES WEATHER CLIMATE
DISASTERS AS WELL AS OTHER
GREAT OUR DEFENSE WERE ALSO
LARGELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE JACK
ALLOCATION BUT WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THOSE DOLLARS GO
TOWARDS. LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
NECKS. NINETY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DEAL IN JAFFA BEHALF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION MY COMMENT ON PARTY
ISSUES THREE TO FIVE WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO STORE
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FOR YOUR
MISSION BE CALLED THE
TECHNOLOGY MORE SPECIFICALLY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE OPPOSING THE NAY
REVISION ADDITIONALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED TO ACT NOW
ON THE EIGHTY EIGHT
REOCCUPATION REPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REAUTHORIZE THE EXTEND THE
PROGRAM SPENT THEIR PROVISIONAL
TEN YEARS. THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS THE
FLAGSHIP INTENDED PROGRAM IT'S
BEEN CRITICAL TO HELPING YOUR
MISSION CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKET DEVELOP AND DEPLOY NEW
TECHNOLOGY TO SUPPORT THE DATE
CLIMB IMPERIAL MISSION GOAL THE
INDUSTRY NEED A STABLE LONG
TERM MARKET BIG OPEN AT EIGHT
TO CONTINUE INVESTING IN THE
POINT IN THE TECHNOLOGY WAITING
TO RE AUTHORIZE FUNDING UNTIL
THE LAST MINUTE COULD HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON MARKET
GROWTH AND INVESTMENT STATE
WHICH ONLY UNDERMINE OUR STATE
GOALS. FINALLY WE APPRECIATE
THAT BOTH THE SENATE AND
MINISTRATION INCLUDING EUROPEAN
EQUITY FUNDING AND WOULD LIKE
TO ENSURE THAT LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE FUNDING IS MAINTAINED
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TIME AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION. NEXT PINE SIXTEEN.
BUT AFTER MR CHAIRMAN NOEL
CREAMER A PLANE INSTITUTE WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INVESTMENT IN CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES AND CLIMATE RESILIENT.
BUT IF WE CAN- OUT OF
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED FOR FUEL
PRODUCTION AND POST FIRE
RECOVERY WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AROUND
THE STATE. WITH THAT IN MIND WE
ARE SUPPORTING THE WILDFIRE
ENFORCEMENT BILLION EXPENDITURE
PLAN. AND ADDITIONALLY ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOOD PRODUCTION
INVESTMENT PROGRAM OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
AND THE CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES ON NAME
I CAL THE SOIL THEN SWEEP AT
CDFA THANK YOU. NECKS. MINE.
NINETEEN HI GOOD MORNING OR
AFTERNOON- GERMAN WHITE HOUSE
MEMBERS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
OUTSIDE OF THE US MAP A CHARGE
POINT IS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL UNDER MISSION
LEGAL INSTRUCTOR FUNDING AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
FIRST ONE IS A LEADING PROVIDER
YOU TRANSITION HARD WORKING
SOFTWARE NORTH AMERICA FIRST
ONE IS A LARGE PART OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND THE
GOVERNMENT MAY REVISED RELATED
YOUR MISSION VEHICLE. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. INTERESTED
QUESTION PROPOSAL DISCUSSION
INSPECTOR. WE BELIEVE THAT MORE
EVIDENCE SHOULD BE PLACED ON
LIGHT DUTIES- MISSION MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION CONTAINED IN
THE MAY REPLACE. THE VEHICLE
THAT WILL USE THAT STRUCTURE
ARE INCREASINGLY. PROVIDING
PRODUCTION RAPIDLY AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE PAPER HAS BEEN
MORE THE NEXT TWO YEARS THIS
VEHICLE SEGMENT. I CAN'T WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CHEESY
BREAD IN THE FUNDING IN FORTY
FOUR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY HAVE THE
EXPERTISE AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENSURE THE SPENDING OF THE PLAY
QUICKLY IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
OR TO CONTINUE WITH THE WORKING
WITH MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS
ARE SUPPORTED BY ITS BUDGET.
BUILDING QUICK THE FISSION AND
EQUITABLE DEPLOYMENT ME
CHARGING A FEE STRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK.
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU NECKS.
NINETY FOUR. THANK BUT
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DANIELLE
LYNCH I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION WE WANT TO COMMEND
THE GOVERNOR FOR SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE PARK
SYSTEM AND THE ABILITY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS THEM
NOTABLY THE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION FOR
FIRE RESTORATION OF ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHT MILLION OUT EQUITY
GRANTS AND KEEP THREE TWELVE
PROGRAMS EXPANSION. AND IT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PILOT PROGRAMS TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND
LIBRARY CARD EVEN BACK MISTER
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND NEEDED
WE ARE CONCERNED HOWEVER THAT
INVESTMENT IN ACQUIRING NEW
STATE PARKS AND EXPANDING
EXISTING PARKS TEAMS HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED FROM THE MAY REVISED
AND MUCH NOTE THE ACQUISITIONS
ARE ANOTHER KEY WAY TO EXPAND
THE ABILITY OF CALIFORNIANS TO
**** ENJOYED NATURE. WORK
DURING FUNDING FOR SENATOR
NEWMAN SB TWO THICK THICK THAN
OTHER LEGISLATION SUPPORTING
THIRTY BY THIRTY GOAL ALSO
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY TO
INSURE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
LEAD THE WAY ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCE TOWARD THE END OF
YOUR QUESTION THE ADDITION OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
CORE ACQUISITION AND EXPANSION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. FORTY
THREE. YOUR VOICE BERKELEY NAY
LAB- I'M SPEAKING TO ISSUE
FORTY NINE ON PAGE EIGHTY FIVE
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY BUDGET
REVISION PROPOSES THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE NATIONAL
LIFE- WATER INNOVATION BASED A
LARGE BURKE IN NATIONAL
LABORATORY FOR RESEARCH TO
DEVELOP NEW LOW COST LOW ENERGY
DESALINATION AND WATER
TREATMENT TECHNOLOGIES. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS WATER
UTILITIES TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER
ORGANISATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OUR STATE IS FACING A SERIOUS
OFF WATER SUPPLIES DO
INTENSIFYING DROUGHT BOB NO
CRACK. CALIFORNIA HAS MANY
SOURCES OF WATERS THAT ARE
IMPAIRED BY DEFAULT AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS INCLUDING LARGE
RESURGENT INLAND BRACKISH
GROUNDWATER AND SIGNIFICANT
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRIAL
MUNICIPAL WASTEWATER. WITH
STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE NEW
SEMESTER RESTORATION AND THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY THE
NATIONALIZED THE WATER
INNOVATIONS DEVELOPING LOW COST
LOW ENERGY DESALINATION
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE CAN REMOVE
THE SALT AND USES AND REUSES
WATERS. BUT THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THE
MINISTRATIONS MARY FIVE IS
CRITICAL FOR GETTING THE STATE.
MINIMUMS THAT WILL BRING SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA AND MOVE
THIS RESEARCH FORWARD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NACS. BLIGHTED
EIGHTY. IT AFTER CHAIR I CAST
COMMITTEE MAY READY TO WHICH
THAT WATER OF CAL ANIMAL
PROTECTIVE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE WATER COME SHOULD BIRTH ONE
X. OUR SHARE APPRECIATE FOR THE
SENATE BUDGET PLAN AND GOVERNOR
MAYBE BASS I WOULD MAKE A
INVEST IN HIGH RESILIENT WATER
AND TRY THE SPOT. WE ARE STILL
THE MINI VERSION OF THE DATA
THAT MUCH OF CON SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR THE WATER CONTAINER
A MAJOR BASICALLY SHE AND WE
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH MY DETAILS
IN THE COMING DAYS AND SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF METROPOLITAN WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WITH REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MARCH I
NEED TO BE SET ASIDE FOR
RECYCLED WATER PROJECTS TO P.
FIVE GROUND WATER TREATMENT
WHICH IS A GROWING ISSUE FOR
SEVEN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE WORKING ON PUTTING
TOGETHER A CURRENT LIST OF
PROJECTS AND FUNDING NEEDS AND
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH MORE
DETAILED COMMENTS IN THANK YOU
FOR THE SENATE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE ROBUST
HAD BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. TIME THANK YOU
NEXT. SEVENTY GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE ACT HE COMMITTING MY NAME
IS LAST OF ALL AND I NAY
EXECUTIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUM ALONG
WITH MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
STATE AND LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE ARE REQUESTING
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
OVER FOUR YEARS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA ART CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY FACTOR ASKING UP
BEYOND BY SENATORS ALLEN RUBIO
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
KIRK SILVA AND IN THE AREA.
INCLUDING THOSE IN THE PROPOSAL
IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION TO
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ENDOWMENT WHICH IS
HOUSED WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY HE C. H. E.
WEBER ABOLITION TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE TO LIFT UP UNDER
REPRESENTED STORY IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY AND THIRD DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT TCHC HAVE BEEN
UNDER FUNDED FOR SEVERAL YEARS
THOSE THESE PROPOSED FUND WOULD
HELP ARE DEEPLY IMPACTED SECTOR
RECOVERED DEEP IN CALIFORNIANS
CONNECTIONS TO OUR HISTORICAL
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AND PRIORITIZE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MAX. WHY NOT
ONE FIVE. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERONICA THE A LEVELS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FLORIDA
ACTION FUND WE WOULD LIKE TO
URGE THE SENATE SUPPORT OF THE
MAY REVISED PROPOSAL IN PART
EIGHT TEN BEST SEVEN BILLION
SIX BRAND EIGHT. BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE ACCESS
TO OUR UNDERSERVED AND UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
BUILD OUT OF THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK AND BELIEVE THAT THE
CRITICAL PIECE IN MEETING THE
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY GOLDEN
STATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION TODAY. MAX
THAT. SEVENTY MILES. THANK YOU.
SEVENTY CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
CHARACTERS YOU MEMBERS- THIS IS
JULIET CHRISTIAN SMITH WITH THE
WATER FOUNDATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY NINE THE WATER RESILIENCE
AND DROUGHT PACKAGE. IN
PARTICULAR THE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION FOR DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE THE
STATE WATER BOARD NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IDENTIFIED AN
ADDITIONAL AND. FIVE YEARS AND
WE WOULD SUPPORT EVEN HIGHER
LEVELS OF FUNDING TO FINALLY
CLOSE THE WATER ACCESS GAP IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR P. FIVE. AND CLEAN
UP AND DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
AND THREE HUNDRED MILLION PER
SEGMENT IMPLEMENTATION IN
PARTICULAR HE SATISFIED REQUIRE
NO LESS THAN 30% TOWARDS
PROJECTS THAT PROTECT DRINKING
WATER AND NO LESS THAN 30% OR
ON PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES-
FINALLY THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EMERGENCY WATER
SUPPLIES ARE CRITICAL AS WELL
ARE GROWING GOING DRY CURRENTLY
DURING THIS DROUGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR THAT WILL CONCLUDE
THAT TELEFONICA CONFERENCE
UNFORTUNATELY- I WANT TO. WE
HAVE LIMITED TIME WE HAVE TO BE
OUT OF THIS ROOM FOR CLEANING
AND CLEANING PROTOCOLS I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TRUST MY TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITES
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT HERE
FOR DECEPTIVE MAYBE TO THAT YES
I WISH WE WOULD HAVE HAD MORE
TIME YOUR COMMENTS.
NEVERTHELESS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN ARTIFICIAL BY
HEARING RECORDS SO THANK YOU
FOR ALL THOSE AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE A SHORT
TIME PERIOD TO GET THIS BUDGET
DONE AND TO GIVE THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
LEADERSHIP OF. OUR BEST
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE CAN SO.
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE AND
FOR REVIEW COMMITTEE TO IS A.